hi everyone welcome to this fantastic
natural language processing and machine
learning course by simply learn but
before we begin if you enjoy watching
these videos and find them interesting
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
us so let's get started we will brief
you the detail introduction to machine
learning and moving forward we will
introduce to you
natural language processing after that
we will see NLP engineer road map and
NLP engineer salary we will walk you
through the Fantastic Concepts like AI
versus ml versus DL after which we will
see text mining using NLP what is
generative AI llm models in artificial
intelligence after covering all these
topics we will see algorithms and
projects like sentiment analysis and
spam classifiers speaking of inter
interviews we have covered you along
with the most frequently Asked ml
interview questions to help you crack
the toughest interviews but before we
begin to understand what machine
learning is if you want to become an AI
expert and gain handsome salary packages
look at the wide range of e IML courses
by simply learn in collaboration with
top universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
programs you will gain expertise in the
skills like generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT explainable AI
machine learning algorithms supervised
and unsupervised learning model training
and optimization and there is much more
on the list with hands-on experience in
the tools like chart GPT di python open
CV and tens oflow you will catch the eye
of top recruiters so what are you
waiting for hurry up and enroll Now find
the cost Link in the description box so
without any further delay over to our
training experts here we have our um
looks a little bit like Franken our
Frankenstein looking robot today let me
tell you what is machine learning
machine learning works on the
development of computer programs that
can access data and use it to
automatically learn and improve from
experience watch a robot builder
construct house in two days this was
back in July 29th
2016 so that's pretty impressive this
amount of time to continue to grow in
his development and it's smart enough to
leave spaces in the brick work for
wiring and plumbing and can even cut in
shaped bricks to size Amazon Echo relies
on machine learning and with more data
it becomes more accurate play your
favorite music order pizza from Domino's
voice control your home request rides
from Uber have you ever wondered the
difference between AI machine learning
and deep learning artificial
intelligence a technique which enables
machines to mimic human behavior this is
really important because this is how we
are able to gauge how well our
computations or what we're working on
works is the fact that we're mimicking
human behavior we're using this to
replace human work and make it more
efficient and make it more streamlined
and more accurate and so the center of
artificial intelligence is the big
picture of all this put together IBM
deep blue chess electronic game
characters those are just a couple
examples of artificial intelligence
machine learning a technique which uses
statistical methods enabling machines to
learn from their past data so this means
if you have your input from last time
and you have your answer you use that to
help prove the next guess it makes for
the correct answer IBM Watson Google
search algorithm email spam filters
these are all part of machine learning
and then deep learning which is a subset
of machine learning composing algorithms
that allow a model to train itself and
perform tasks Alpha go natural speech
recognition these are a couple examples
deep learning is associated with tools
like neural networks where it's kind of
a Black Block as it learns it changes
all these things that are as a human
we'd have a very hard time tracking and
it's able to come up with an answer from
that now let's see how machine learning
works first we start with training the
data once we've trained the data the
train we go into the machine learning
algorithm which then puts the data into
a processing which then goes down to
machine another machine learning
algorithm and then we take new data
because you have to test whatever you
did to make sure it works correctly and
we put that into the same algorithm once
we do that we check our prediction we
check our results and from the
prediction if we've set aside some
training data and we find out it didn't
do a good job predicing it and it gets a
thumbs down as you see then we go back
to the beginning and we retrain the
algorithm and a lot of times it's not
just about getting the wrong answer it's
about continually trying to get a better
answer so you'll see the first time you
might be like oh this is not the answer
I want depending on what domain you're
working in whether it's medical
economical business stocks whatever you
try out your model model and if it's not
giving you a good answer you retrain it
if you think you can get a better answer
you retrain it and you keep doing that
until you get the best answer you can
now let's look into the types of machine
learning machine learning is primarily
of three types first one is supervised
machine learning as the name suggest you
have to supervise your machine learning
while you train it to work on its own it
requires labeled training data next up
is unsupervised learning wherein there
will be training data but it won't be
labeled
finally there's reinforcement learning
wherein the system learns on its own
let's talk about all these types in
detail let's try to understand how
supervised Learning Works look at the
pictures very very carefully the monitor
depicts the model or the system that we
are going to train this is how the
training is done we provide a data set
that contains pictures of a kind of a
fruit say an apple then we provide
another data set which lets the model
know that these pictures wear that of a
fruit called
Apple this ends the training phase now
what we will do is we provide a new set
of data which only contains pictures of
apple now here comes the fun part the
system can actually tell you what fruit
it is and it will remember this and
apply this knowledge in future as well
that's how supervised Learning Works you
are training the model to do a certain
kind of an operation on its own this
kind of a model is generally used into
filtering spam Ma from your email
account as well yes surprise aren't you
so let's move on to unsupervised
learning now let's say we have a data
set which is cluttered in this case we
have a collection of pictures of
different fruits we feed this data to
the model and the model analyzes the
data to figure out patterns in it in the
end it categorizes the photos into three
types as you can see in the image based
on their
similarities so you provide the data to
the system and let the system do the
rest of the work simple isn't it
this kind of a model is used by flip
cart to figure out the products that are
well suited for you honestly speaking
this is my favorite type of machine
learning out of all the three and this
type has been widely shown in most of
the Sci-Fi movies lately let's find out
how it works imagine a newborn baby you
put a burning candle in front of the
baby the baby does not know that if it
touches the flame its fingers might get
burned so it does that anyway and gets
hurt the next time time you put that
candle in front of the baby it will
remember what happened the last time and
would not repeat what it did that's
exactly how reinforcement learning works
we provide the machine with a data set
wherein we ask it to identify a
particular kind of a fruit in this case
an Apple so what it does as a response
it tells us that it's a mango but as we
all know it's a completely wrong answer
so as a feedback we tell the system that
it's wrong it's not a mango it's an
apple what it does it learns from the
feedback and keeps that in mind when the
next time when we ask a same question it
gives us the right answer it is able to
tell us that it's actually an apple that
is a reinforced response so that's how
reinforcement learning works it learns
from his mistakes and experiences this
model is used in games like Prince of
Persia or Assassin's Creed or FIFA where
in the level of difficulty increases as
you get better with the games just to
make it more clear for you let's look at
a comparison between supervised and
unsupervised learning firstly the data
involved in case of supervised learning
is labeled as we mentioned in the
examples
previously we provide the system with a
photo of an apple and let the system
know that this is actually an apple that
is called label data so the system
learns from the label data and makes
future
predictions now unsupervised learning
does not require any kind of label data
because its work is to look for patterns
in the input data and organize it the
next point is that you get a feedback in
case of supervised learning that is once
you get the output the system tends to
remember that and uses it for the next
operation that does not happen for
unsupervised learning and the last point
is that supervised learning is mostly
used to predict data whereas
unsupervised learning is used to find
out hidden patterns or structures in
data I think this would have made a lot
of things clear for you regarding
supervised and unsupervised
hey everyone in this video we'll be
talking about NLP in the next 10 minutes
so what can you expect from this video
what's in it for you first we'll give
you a basic understanding of NLP we'll
tell you why we need NLP and we'll talk
about what NLP exactly is next we look
at NLP pipelines NLP pipelines cover the
basic processes involved in text passing
in NLP which means converting text to a
form suitable for machines to understand
understand as humans would understand it
and finally we'll talk about some real
world applications of NLP which are all
around us and a lot more common than you
might have realized so let's get started
so what exactly is NLP before we talk
about NLP let's talk about how humans
talk and interact with each other humans
communicate with each other mostly via
speech or text to convey your intent to
someone you may directly talk to them or
send them a message the human way of
communicating is known as natural
language around the globe many languages
are spoken and messages are shared
virtually every single day all these
conversations feedbacks and messages are
data in themselves this data is
extremely valuable as it can give us
customer information and insight into
human sentiment however this data is not
useful to computers as it is not in a
form that can be understood by machines
Mach machines communicate using ones and
zeros and not via words they cannot
understand English French or Spanish
only binary and this is where NLP comes
into the picture NLP stands for natural
language processing natural language
processing is a branch of artificial
intelligence that deals with the
interactions between humans and
computers using the natural language the
ultimate objective of NLP is to read
decipher under understand and make sense
of human languages in a manner that is
valuable and to build systems that can
make sense of text and perform tasks
like translation grammar checking or
topic classification NLP basically is
the task of processing written forms of
languages and making a computer
understand them companies are
increasingly using NLP equipped tools to
gain insights from data into automate
routine tasks a sentiment analyzer for
instance can help Brands detect emotions
in t text such as negative comments on
social
media NLP at the end of the day is
nothing more than accumulation of
artificial intelligence computer science
and the human language the next topic
that we'll be looking at are NLP
pipelines so what exactly are pipelines
a pipeline is a set of data processing
Elements which are connected in series
where the output of one element is the
input of the next one it basically
repres resents the various steps which
have to be taken in our computation and
the order in which they
occur in this pipeline we are going to
be passing our data parsing means
converting our data from one form to
another in this case we are passing our
input Text data to a file which can be
understood by a computer the text is
first broken into segments and the
segments are then converted into even
smaller
tokens the word step stems of all of
these tokens are found followed by
finding the root words of these stems in
a process known as
lemmatization we will then recognize
which part of speech the word belongs to
which means if the word is a verb a noun
or a pronoun and finally we will
separate the instances of everyday
popular entities from our words to
better understand what the sentence is
trying to convey the final file that
we'll get will be a file which will be
understood by a computer segmentation
the first process of a pipeline is
segmentation now what exactly is
segmentation sentence segmentation or
text segmentation is basically dividing
the given text into logically
decipherable units of information we
divide the sentence into its constituent
Subs sentences usually along the
punctuations like full stops or commas
or along line breaks and Page com
components for HTML files dividing a
document into its constituent sentences
allows us to process it without losing
its Essence and the necessary
information that it contains in this
case let's consider a sentence the
lemonade quenched her thirst but not her
longing after sentence segmentation we
are going to divide the sentence into
two the first sentence is going to be
the lemonade quenched her thirst and the
second one is going to be but not her
longing the next step of our pipeline is
called tokenization tokenization is
nothing but the process of dividing a
sentence into its constituent words the
sentence that is given to us will be
separated and all the words in the
sentence will be stored separately this
is done so we can understand the
syntactic and semantic information
contained in each sentence thus we
decipher the relevance of a sentence by
analyzing it word by word there by
making sure that no loss of information
occurs the computer does not understand
punctuations and special characters
hence we can remove any punctuations and
special characters which may occur let's
take a part of a previously segmented
sentence over here let's consider the
lemonade quenched her thirst after
tokenization we are going to separate
every single word in this sentence so
after tokenization we are going to get
five different tokens the L inade
quenched her and thirst all of these are
going to be treated as separate entities
after tokenization we perform stemming
stemming is a process of obtaining the
word stems of a word word stems are also
known as the base form of a word and we
can create new words by attaching a
fixes to them in a process known as
inflection stemming is a process of
recognizing the word stems of individual
words this is done by removing affixes
such as in s Ed etc for example consider
our sentence jump jump is the word stem
of various different words like
jumping jumped and jumps if we remove
all of these affixes we will get our
basic word stem which is Jump this is
basically what we want at the end of
stemming the next process in our
pipeline is called lemmatization
lemmatization is the process of figuring
out the root form or root word which is
nothing but the most basic form also
known as the LMA of each word in the
sentence lemmatization is very similar
to stemming where we remove word affixes
to get the base form of a word the
difference is that the root word is
always a word which is present in the
dictionary but the root stem may not be
so lemmatization uses a knowledge Base
called word net let's consider three
different words went going and gone at
the end of of the day all of these words
have originated from a single word which
is go in this case go is our Lemma all
the other words which are derived from
go can be traced back to it the next
part of our pipeline is called part of
speech tagging part of speech tagging is
a process of converting a sentence to
different forms it can be a list of
words or a list of
tuples the tag in case of is a part of
speech tag and signifies whether the
word is a noun adjective verb and so on
we are basically splitting our verbs
into the grammatical components to
understand the meaning of any sentence
or to extract relationships and to build
a Knowledge Graph part of speech tagging
is a very important step as the same
word can have different part of speeches
in different
sentences for example let's consider the
sentence give me your answer in this
sentence answer is a noun but if you
consider consider another sentence
answer the question over here answer
will be a verb using part of speech
tagging we can take our different tokens
and find the different part of speech
that it belongs to in this case the is a
determiner lemonade is a noun quenched
is a verb her is a pronoun and thirst is
a noun the final step in our NLP
pipeline that we are looking at here is
nothing but named entity recognition
named entity recognition also known as
named entity
identification entity chunking and
entity extraction is a subtask of
information extraction that seeks to
locate and classify named entities which
are mentioned in unstructured text into
predefined categories extracting the
main entities in a text helps us sort
unstructured data and detect important
information which is crucial if you have
to deal with large data sets the sub
categories that we are considering are
person whether the named entity is a
person whether it's a quantity like
kilogram a
location an
organization the name of a movie or
whether it's a monetary value like
dollars or
Euros so far we've looked at what NLP is
and how we can perform natural language
processing but what are some
applications of it and where is it used
in the real
world one of the applications of NLP is
in chatbots chat Bots can help you solve
issues while performing natural language
generation in other words they can hold
a conversation in plain English a
chatbot is nothing but a software
application which can be used to conduct
an online chat conversation either
through text or speech in place of
providing direct contact with a life
human agent you you might have seen
those talk to one of our agents section
on websites those are usually chat Bots
a lot of companies also use WhatsApp
chat Bots to make the process seem less
mechanical another application of NLP is
speech recognition probably the most
popular example of NLP in action are
virtual assistants like Google assist
Siri and Alexa natural language
processing understands and translates
the human language like hey Siri where
is the nearest gas station into numbers
making it easy for machines to
understand they recognize when you are
talking converting speech to text and
understand what you requested over the
years virtual assistants have become
streamlined enough to be able to emulate
human speech patterns almost flawlessly
another application of NLP is
autocorrection autocorrection also known
as text replacement replace as you type
or simply autocorrect is an automatic
data validation function commonly found
in word processors and text editing
interfaces for smartphones and tablet
computers it acts as a spell check and
corrects any spellings or grammar
mistakes which may arise as you are
typing some language check softwares
like grammarly paper RoR reverso and
others can even check how unique and
engaging your articles are and all of
this is done using NLP hello everyone
welcome to to this video on the natural
language processing engineer NLP
engineer road map by simply learn to
stay updated with our content make sure
to subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the Bell icon so in this video we
will Begin by examining the role of NLP
engineer progressing further our Focus
will shift toward the Essential
Knowledge and Skills required to excel
as an NLP engineer having
comprehensively explored these subjects
we will then proceed to explore the
intereses and conting of a professional
career road map tailor specifically for
individual aspiring to become
accomplished NLP Engineers on that note
if you are an aspiring AIML engineer
then there is no better time to train
yourself in the exciting field of
machine learning if you are looking for
course that covers everything from the
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our ctech program
partnership with IBM this AIML boot camp
in collaboration with keltech will help
you advance your career as AIML
specialist the AIML boot camp includes
live classes delivered by industry
expert handson L industry relevant
projects and master classes by ctech
Professor key features of this amazing
machine learning course includes earn up
to 22 cus from CCH ctme online
convocation by CCH CM program director
simply learn career service helps you
get notied by top hiring companies on a
boot camp certificate from CeX cdme
industry relevant project in three
domains CeX City Circle membership 25
plus Hands-On project across industry
verticals with integrated Labs so why
wait join now seats are filling fast
find the course link from the
description box below so without any
further Ado let's get started so what is
NLP engineer anual language processing
NLP engineer is a professional
responsible for crafting and cing
computer system that can process assess
and produce humanlike language NLP
branches out into numerous captivating
domains including semantic analysis
sentiment analysis face recognition
machine translation and speech
recognition the reach of NLP extend
across a diverse spectrum of application
notably featuring virtual assistant chat
bards sentiment analysis customer
service interaction and language
translation the task of NLP engineer
involves enacting these Innovative
application and seemingly embedding them
into the existing framework the average
salary for NLP engineer in India is 10
lakh per year and in the US average
annual salary for NLP engineer is
$120,000
so moving forward let's see skills
required as an NLP engineer so becoming
an NLP engineer entails acquisition of a
diverse set of application and knowledge
some of these encompasses first one is
Proficiency in programming Mastery of at
least one programming language such as
python Java or C++ coupled with the
solid graphs of data structure algorithm
and principle of software engineering
the second one is grasp of machine
learning building a strong foundation in
machine learning algorithm and
compassing both supervised and
unsupervised learning familiarity with
Advanced Techniques like CNN and RNN is
vital the third one is NLP techniques
cultivating a deep understanding of NLP
techniques which encompasses facets like
text pre-processing sentenc and semantic
analysis and the intricate domain of
sentiment analysis the fourth one is NLP
libraries and Frameworks navigate easily
through NLP libraries and Frameworks
such as natural language toolkit nltk
spy standord code NLP and genim
harnessing their capabilities to to
streamline your NLP Endeavors the fifth
one is data science acuma developing a
sound gaps of data science principles
and compassing facet such as data
visualization statical analysis and the
Art of data manipulation armed with
these multiac skill set you will be
primed to embark on a journey as an
accomplished NLP engineer ready to
navigate the complexity of natural
languages processing and contribute to
the exciting world of NLP Innovation
moving forward let's see the
professional NLP Engineer Road map here
is a comprehensive professional
trajectory for those aspiring to become
NLP Engineers the first one is
Educational Foundation embo your journey
by pursuing a degree in compitent fields
such as computer science Linguistics or
artificial intelligence many
accomplished NLP Engineers hold Advanced
degrees either a master or PhD in these
domains the second one is internship or
entry-level Ventures considering
immersing yourself in Practical
experience through internship or entry
Trel job within the industry these
opportunities not only equ with the
Hands-On expertise but also Aid in
constructing a robust portfolio the
third one on the list is skills and
knowledge acquisition develop a
comprehensive grasp of essential
proficiency request of NLP engineer this
encompasses programming processes and
machine learning and NLP techniques and
data science the fourth one is portfolio
development curate a diverse portfolio
teaming with projects that illuminate
your capabilities and expertise projects
like suffocated chatboard a sentiment
analysis tool or a lang model can
sustain your aptitude for solving real
world NLP challenges and validate your
skill set for potential employers the
fifth one is networking endears engage
in conference meetups and industries
even to forge connection with fellow NLP
professionals the sixth one is
specialization consideration Ponder the
prospect of specialization in specific
NLP realm be it machine translation
speech recognition or conversational
agent this specialization not only
differentiate you in the job market but
also enables you to attain expertise
within a particular need in summation
the part toward becoming an NP engineer
entails a fusion of educational
attainment hands-on experience and the
Mastery of electric area of skills and
knowledge domain hello everyone and
welcome to this new video on NLP
engineer salary with the world advancing
towards a more informed and database
future learning skills that help us to
be relevant in the job market is crucial
once such skill in the field of data and
AI is natural language processing let us
start by understanding what NLP is
natural language processing or NLP is a
branch of artificial intelligence or AI
that deals with understanding and
manipulating human language it seeks to
develop algorithms and systems that can
understand and process both structured
and unstructured language data to
support decision making processes LP is
a field that has been gaining more
momentum in recent years thanks to
advance in machine learning algorithms
and the availability of large data sets
such as social media conversations
customer reviews and medical records NLP
is used in various applications such as
language translation sentiment analysis
text summarization and text generation
if you want to master NLP and become an
expert NLP engineer then you should
enroll an amazing Ai and machine
learning program by calch CDM you will
gain skills like machine learning deep
learning reinforcement learning NLP
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT and more this Ai and machine
learning boot camp includes live classes
delivered by industry experts Hands-On
Labs industry relevant projects and
master classes by Caltech instructors so
hurry up what are you waiting for enroll
the course now find the course Link in
the description box so before we move
ahead consider subscribing to Simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from us so let's move
ahead by knowing what does NLP include
at its score NLP involves a series of
steps number one is pre-processing the
first step in NLP is to prepare the
language data for analysis this involves
activities such as cleaning tokenization
and normalization of the text Data step
two involves feature extraction the next
step is to extract relevant features
from the prepared date data this
involves identifying keywords stems and
parts of speech tags that are important
for the task at hand step three involves
model training the extracted features
are then used to train a machine
learning model such as neural networks
or a support Vector machine to predict
the target variable and the last step is
model evaluation once the model is
strained it needs to be evaluated to
ensure it performs well on new data now
let's move ahead by knowing NLP job
roles and responsibilities several job
roles that involves NLP and each role is
focused on different aspects of NLP here
are some most common NLP job roles the
number one is NLP engineer this role
involves developing and implementing NLP
Solutions including building machine
learning models designing pipelines and
developing apis NLP Engineers typically
have a background in engineering or
computer science and have not of machine
learning algorithms software development
and data structures the next we have is
text analytics specialist this role
involves analyzing large amount of Text
data to extract useful information text
analytics specialist typically have a
background in data analysis statistics
and machine learning and they use NLP
tools and techniques to process and
analyze text Data language model
engineer this role involves developing
and improving in natural language
processing models such as language
models and machine translation models
language model Engineers typically have
a background in computer science machine
learning and natural language processing
on number four we have NLP researcher
this role involves conducting Research
into new NLP methods and techniques NLP
researchers typically have a background
in computer science machine learning and
natural language processing and they
publish their research in various
academic journals and conferences and
the most awaited let's start with salary
of NLP Engineers let us now discuss the
salary of NLP engineers in India and USA
for the sake of better understanding we
will split up the salary ranges based on
the experience level of a professional
so let's start with entry level NLP
engineers in India the salary ranges
from 2.5 million rupees to 5 million
rupees however in us the salary ranges
between $60,000 to $90,000 per year
enter level NLP Engineers typically have
background in computer science
engineering or a related field and have
some experience with NLP but may not
have yet worked on large scale
Enterprise projects moving towards
midlevel NLP Engineers these Engineers
earn 5 million to 8 million rupees per
year however in United States they earn
between $90,000 to
$120,000 per year midlevel NLP engineer
have few years of experience working on
NLP projects and are typically
comfortable working on both Technical
and business related aspects of NLP
projects they may have some leadership
responsibilities and are often
responsible for ensuring that NLP
projects are completed on time and to
speec next we have a senior level NLP
Engineers these Engineers earn up to 8
million rupes to 15 million rupees in
India per year however in United States
they earn between between
$120,000 to
$165,000 per year senior level NLP
Engineers have extensive experience
working on Enterprise level NLP projects
and are often considered authorities in
NLP Technologies methods and tools they
may serve as subject matter experts lead
teams of Engineers and other NLP
professionals and be responsible for
ensuring the long-term success of NLP
projects human versus artificial
intelligence
humans are amazing let's just face it
we're amazing creatures we're all over
the planet we're exploring every Nick
and Nook we've gone to the Moon uh we've
gone into outer space we're just amazing
creatures we're able to use the
available information to make decisions
to communicate with other people
identify patterns and data remember what
people have said adapt to new situations
so let's take a look at this so so you
can get a picture you a human being so
you know what it's like to be human
human let's take a look at artificial
intelligence versus the human artificial
intelligence develops computer systems
that can accomplish taxs to require
human
intelligence so we're looking at this
one of the things that computers can do
is they can provide more accurate
results this is very important recently
I did a project on cancer where it's
identifying
markers and as a human being you look at
that and you might be uh looking at all
the different images is and the data
that comes off of them and say I like
this person so I want to give them a
very
good um Outlook and the next person you
might not like so you want to give them
a bad Outlook well with artificial
intelligence you're going to get a
consistent prediction of what's going to
come out interacts with humans using
their natural language we've seen that
as probably the biggest development
feature right now that's in the
commercial Market that everybody gets to
use as we saw with the example of Alexa
they learn from their mistakes and adapt
to new environments so we we see this
slowly coming in more and more and they
learn from the data and automate
repetitive learning repetitive learning
has a lot to do with the neural networks
you have to program thousands upon
thousands of pictures in there and it's
all automated so as today's computers
evolved it's very quick and easy and
affordable to do this what is machine
learning and deep learning all about
imagine this say you had some time to
waste not that any of us have a lot of
time anymore to just waste in today's
world and you're sitting by the road and
you have a whole lot of and a whole lot
of time passes by there's a few hours
and suddenly you wonder how many cars
buses trucks and so on passed by in the
six hours now chances are you're not
going to sit by the road for six hours
and count buses cars and trucks unless
you're working for the city and you're
trying to do City Planning and you want
to know hey do we need to add a new
truck route maybe we need a bicycle lane
we have a lot of bicyclists here here
that kind of thing so maybe City
Planning would be great for this machine
learning well the way machine Learning
Works is we have labeled data with
features okay so you have a truck or a
car a motorcycle a bus or a bicycle and
each one of those are labeled it comes
in and based on those labels and
comparing those features it gives you an
answer it's a bicycle it's a truck it's
a motorcycle let's look a little bit
more in depth on this and the model here
it actually the features we're looking
at would be like the tires someone sits
there and figures out what a tire looks
like takes a lot of work if you try to
try to figure the difference between a
car tire a bicycle tire a motorcycle
tire uh so in the machine learning field
this could take a long time if you're
going to do each
individual aspect of a car and try to
get a result on there and that's what
they did do that was a a very this is
still used on smaller amounts of data
where you figure out what those features
are and then you label them deep
learning so with deep learning one of
our Solutions is to take a very large
unlabeled data set and we put that into
a training model using artificial neural
networks and then that goes into the
neural network itself when we create a
neural network and you'll see um the
arrows are actually kind of backward but
uh which actually is a nice point
because when we train the neural network
we put the bicycle in and then it comes
back and says if it said truck it comes
back and says well you need to change
that to bicycle and then it changes all
those weights going backward they call
it back propagation and let it know it's
a bicycle and that's how it learns once
you've trained the neural network you
then put the new data in and they call
this testing the model so you need to
have some data you've kept off to the
side where you know the answer to and
you take that and you provide the
required output and you say okay is this
is this neural network working correctly
did it identify a bike as a bike a truck
as a truck a motorcycle as a a
motorcycle let's just take a little
closer look at that determining what
objects are present in the data so how
does deep learning do this and here we
have the image of the bike it's 28x 28
pixels that's a lot of information there
um could you imagine trying to guess
that this is a bicycle image by looking
at each one of those pixels and trying
to figure out what's around it uh and we
actually do that as human beings it's
pretty amazing we know what a bicycle is
and even though it comes in is all this
information and what this looks like is
the image comes in it converts it into a
bunch of different nodes in this case
there's a lot more than what they show
here and it goes through these different
layers and outc comes and says okay this
is a
bicycle a lot of times they call this
the magic Black Box why because as we
watch it go across here all these
weights and all the math behind this and
it's not it's a little complicated on
the math side you really don't need to
know that when you're programming or
doing working with the Deep learning but
it's like magic you you don't know know
you really can't figure out what's going
to come out by looking what's in each
one of those dots and each one of those
lines are firing and what's going in
between them so we like to call it the
magic box uh so that's where deep
learning comes in and in the end it
comes up and you have this whole neural
notwork it comes up and it says okay we
fire all these different pixels and we
connects all these different dots and
gives them different weights and it says
okay this is a bicycle and that's how we
determine what the object is present in
the data with deep learning machine
learning we're going to take a step into
machine learning here and you'll see how
these fit together in a minute the
system is able to make predictions or
take decisions based on past data that's
very important for machine learning is
that we're looking at stuff and based on
what's been there before we're creating
a decision on there we're creating
something out of there we're coloring a
beach ball we're telling you what the
weather is in Chicago what's nice about
machine learning is a very powerful
processing capability it's quick and ACC
accurate outcomes so you get results
right away once you program the system
the results are very fast and the
decisions and predictions are better
they're more accurate they're consistent
you can analyze very large amounts of
data some of these data things that
they're analyzing now are pedabytes and
terabytes of data it would take hundreds
of people hundreds of years to go
through some of this data and do the
same thing that the machine learning can
do in a very short period of time and
it's an expensive compared to hiring
hundreds of people so it becomes a very
affordable way to move into the future
is to apply the machine learning to
whatever businesses you're working on
and deep Learning Systems think and
learn like humans using artificial
neural networks again it's like a magic
box performance improves with more data
so the more data the Deep learning gets
the more it gives you better results
it's scalability so you can scale it up
you can scale it down you can increase
what you're looking at currently you
know we're limited by the amount of
computer processing power as to how big
that can get but that envelope
continually gets pushed every day on
what it can do problem solved in an end
to-end method so instead of having to
break it apart and you have the first
piece coming in and you identify tires
and the second piece is identifying uh
labeling handlebars and then you bring
that together that if it has handlebars
and tires it's a bicycle and if it has
something that looks like a large Square
it's probably a truck the neural
networks does this all in one network
you don't really know what's going on in
all those weights and all those little
bubbles uh but it does it pretty much in
one package that's why the neural
network systems are so big nowadays and
coming into their own best features are
selected by the system and it this is
important they kind of put it's on a
bullet on the side here it's a subset of
machine learning this is important when
we talk about deep learning it is a form
of machine learning there's lots of
other forms of machine learning data
analysis but this is the newest and
biggest thing that they apply to a lot
of different packages and they use all
the other machine learning tools
available to work with it and it's very
fast to test um you put in your
information you then have your group of
uh test and then you held some aside you
see how does it do it's very quick to
test it and see what's going on with
your deep learning and your neural
network are they really all that
different h AI versus machine learning
versus deep learning concepts of AI so
we have concepts of AI you'll see
natural language processing uh machine
learning an approach to create
artificial intelligence so it's one of
the subsets of artificial intelligence
knowledge representation automated
reasoning computer vision robotics
machine learning versus AI versus deep
learning or Ai and machine learning and
deep
learning so when we look at this we have
a AI with machine learning and deep
learning and so we're going to put them
all together we find out that AI is a
big picture we have a collection of
books it goes through some deep learning
the Digital Data is analyzed text mining
comes through the particular book you're
looking for maybe it's a genre books is
identified and in this case uh we have a
robot that goes and gives a book to the
patron I have yet to be at a library
that has a robot bring me a book but
that will be cool when it happens uh so
at some of the pieces here this
information goes into uh as far as this
example the translation of the
handwritten printed data to digital form
that's pretty hard to do that's pretty
hard to go in there and translate
hundreds and hundreds of books and
understand what they're trying to say if
you've never read them so in this case
we use a deep learning because you can
already use examples where they've
already classified a lot of books and
then they can compare those texts and
say oh okay this is a book on automotive
repair this is a book on robotic
building the Digital Data is in analyzed
then we have more text mining using
machine learning so maybe we'd use a
different program to do a basic classify
uh what you're looking for and say oh
you're looking for auto repair and
computers so you're looking for
automated cars once it's identified then
of course it brings you the
book so here's a nice summation of what
we were just talking about a with
machine learning and deep learning deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
which is a subset of artificial
intelligence so you can look at
artificial intelligence as a big picture
how does this compare to The Human
Experience in either uh doing the same
thing as a human we do or it does it
better than us and machine learning
which has a lot of tools uh is something
that learns from data past experiences
it's programmed it's uh comes comes in
there and it says hey we already had
these five things happen the six one
should be about the same and then uh
then there's a lot of tools in machine
learning but deep learning then is a
very specific tool in machine learning
it's the artificial neural network which
handles large amounts of data and is
able to take huge pools of experiences
pictures and ideas and bring them
together real life
examples artificial intelligence news
generation very common nowadays as it
goes through there and finds the news
articles or generates the news based
upon the news feeds or the uh backend
coming in it says okay let's give you
the actual news based on this there's
all the different things Amazon Echo
they have a number of different Prime
music on there of course there's also
the Google command and there's also
Cortana there's tons of smart home
devices now where we can ask it to turn
the TV on or play music for us that's
all our artificial intelligence from
front to back you're having a human
experience with these computers and
these objects that are connected to the
processing machine learning uh spam
detection very common machine learning
doesn't really have the human
interaction part so this is the part
where it goes and says okay that's a
Spam that's not a Spam and it puts it in
your spam folder search engine result
refining uh another example of of
machine learning whereas it looks at
your different results and it Go and it
is able to categorize them as far as
this had the most hits this is the least
viewed this has five stars um you know
however they want to waight it uh all
exam good examples of machine learning
and then the Deep learning uh deep
learning another example is as you have
like a exit sign in this case is
translating it into French sorti I hope
I said that right um neural network has
been PR program with all these different
words and images and so it's able to
look at the exit in the middle and it
goes okay we want to know what that is
in French and it's able to push that out
in French French and learn how to do
that and then we have chatbots um I
remember when Microsoft first had their
little paperclip um boy that was like a
long time ago that came up and you would
type in there and chat with it these are
growing you know it's nice to just be
able to ask a question and it comes up
and gives you the answer and instead of
it being were you just doing a search on
certain words it's now able to start
linking those words together and form a
sentence in that chat box types of AI
and machine
learning types of artificial
intelligence this in the next few slides
are really important so one of the types
of artificial intelligence is reactive
machines systems that only react they
don't form memories they don't have past
experiences they have something that
happens to them and they react to it my
washing machine is one of those if I put
a ton of clothes in it and they had all
clumped on one side it automatically
adds a weight to reiter it so that my
washing machine is actually a reactive
machine working with whatever the load
is and keeps it nice and so when it
spins it doesn't go thumping against the
side limited memory another form of
artificial intelligence systems look
into the past information is added over
a period of time and information is
shortlived when we're talking about this
and you look at like a neural network
that's been programmed to identify cars
it doesn't remember all those pictures
it has no memory as far as the hundreds
of pictures you process through it all
it has is this is the pattern I use to
identify cars as the final output for
that neural network we looked at so when
they talk about limited memory this is
what they're talking about they're
talking about I've created this based on
all these things but I'm not going to
remember any one
specifically theory of mind systems
being able to understand human emotions
and how they affect decision-making to
adjust their behaviors according to
their human understanding this is
important because this is our page mark
this is how we know whether it is an
artificial intelligence or not is it
interacting with humans in a way that we
can understand uh without that
interaction is just an object uh so we
talk about theory of mind we really
understand how it interfaces that whole
if you're in web development user
experience would be the term I would put
in there so a theory of mind would be
user experience how is the whole UI
connected together and one of the final
things is as we get into artificial
intelligence is systems being aware of
themselves understanding their internal
States and predicting other people's
feelings and act appropriately so as
artificial intelligence continues to
progress uh we see ones are trying to
understand well what makes people happy
how would they increase our happiness uh
how would they keep themselves from
breaking down if something broken inside
they have that self-awareness to be able
to fix it and just based on all that
information predicting which action
would work the best what would help
people uh if I know that you're having a
cup of coffee first thing in the morning
is what makes you happy as a robot I
might make you a cup of coffee every
morning at the same time uh to help your
life and help you grow that'd be the
self-awareness as being able to know all
those different things types of machine
learning and like I said on the last
slide this is very important this is
very important if you decide to go in
and get certified in machine learning or
know more about it these are the three
primary types of machine learning the
first one is supervised learning systems
are able to predict future outcome based
on past data requires both an input and
an output to be given to the model for
it to be trained so in this case we're
looking at anything where you have 100
images of a
bicycle and those 100 images you know
are bicycle so it's they're preset
someone already looked at all 100 images
and said these are pictures of bicycles
and so the computer learns from those
and then it's given another picture and
maybe the next picture is a bicycle and
it says oh that resembles all these
other bicycles so it's a bicycle and the
next one's a car and it says it's not a
bicycle that would be supervised
learning because we had to train it we
had to supervise it unsupervised
learning systems are able to identify
hidden patterns from the input data
provided by making the data and more
readable and organized the patterns
similarities or anomalies become more
evident uh you'll heard the term cluster
how do you cluster things together some
of these things go together some of
these don't this is unsupervised where
can look at an image and start pulling
the different pieces of the image out
because they aren't the same the human
all the parts of the human are not the
same as a fuzzy tree behind them it's
slightly out of focus which is not the
same as the beach ball it's unsupervised
because we never told it what a beach
ball was we never told told it what the
human was and we never told it that
those were trees all we told it was hey
separate this picture by things that
don't match and things that do match and
come together and finally there's
reinforcement learning systems are given
no training it learns on the basis of
the reward punishment ited for
performing its Last Action it helps
increase the efficiency of a tool
function or a program reinforced
learning a reinforcement learning is
kind of you give it a yes or no yes you
gave me the right response no you didn't
and then it looks at that and says oh
okay so based on this data coming in uh
what I gave you was a wrong response so
next time I'll give you a different one
comparing machine learning and deep
learning so remember that deep learning
is a subcategory of machine learning so
it's one of the many tools and so they
we're grouping a ton of machine learning
tools all together linear regression K
means clustering there's all kinds of
cool tools out there you can use in
machine learning enables machines to
take decisions to make decisions on
their own based on past data enables
machines to make decisions with the help
of artificial neural networks so it's
doing the same thing but we're using an
artificial neural network as opposed to
one of the more traditional machine
learning tools needs only a small amount
of training data this is very important
when you're talking about machine
learning they're usually not talking
about huge amounts of data we're talking
about maybe your spreadsheet from your
business and your totals for the end of
the year when you're talking about
neural networks usually need a large
amount of data to train the data so
there's a lot of training involved if
you have under 500 points of data that's
probably not going to go into machine
learning or maybe you have like the case
of one of the things 500 points of data
and 30 different fields it starts
getting really confusing there in
artificial intelligence or machine
learning and the Deep learning aspect
really shines when you get to that
larger data that's really
complex works well on a low-end systems
so a lot of lot of the machine learning
tools out there you can run on your
laptop with no problem and do the
calculations there where with the
machine learning usually needs a
higher-end system to work it takes a lot
more processing power to build those
neural networks and to train them it
goes through a lot of data when we're
talking about the general machine
learning tools most features need to be
identified in advanced and manually
coded so there's a lot of human work on
here the machine learns the features
from the data it is provided so again
it's like a magic box box you don't have
to know what a tire is it figures it out
for you the problem is divided into
parts and solved individually and then
combined so machine learning you usually
have all these different tools and use
different tools for different parts and
the problem is solved in an IND in
manner so you only have one neural
network or two neural networks that is
bringing the data in and putting it out
it's not going through a lot of
different processes to get there and
remember you can put machine learning
and deep learning together so you don't
always have just the Deep learning
solving the problem you might have
solving one piece of the puzzle with
regular machine learning and most
machine learning tools out there they
they take longer to test and understand
how they work and with the Deep learning
it's pretty quick once you build that
neural network you test it and you know
so we're dealing with very crisp rules
limited resources you have to really
explain how the decision was made when
you use most machine learning tools but
when you use the Deep learning tool
inside the machine learning tools the
system takes care of it based on its own
logic and reasoning and again it's like
a magic Black Box you really don't know
how it came up with the answer you just
know it came up with the right answer a
glimpse into the future so a quick
glimpse into the future artificial
intelligence be using it to detecting
crimes before they happen humanoid AI
helpers which we already have a lot of
there'll be more and more maybe it'll
actually be Androids that'd be cool to
have an Android that comes and gets
stuff out of my fridge for me machine
learning increasing efficiency in health
care that's really big in all the forms
of machine learning better marketing
techniques any of these things if we get
into the Sciences it's just off the
scale machine learning and artificial
intelligence go everywhere and then the
subcategory Deep learning increased
personalization so what's really nice
about the Deep learning is it's going to
start now catering to you that'll be one
of the things we see more and more of
and we'll have more of a hyper
intelligent personal assistant I'm
excited about that
in this lesson you are going to
understand the concept of text
mining by the end of this lesson you
will be able to explain text mining
execute text processing
task so let's go ahead and understand
text mining in detail let's first
understand what text mining is text
mining is the technique of exploring
large amounts of unstructured Text data
and analyzing it in order to extract
patterns from from the text Data it is
aided by software that can identify
Concepts patterns topics keywords and
other attributes in the data it utilizes
computational techniques to extract and
summarize the highquality information
from unstructured textual resources
let's understand the flow of text mining
there are five techniques used in text
mining system information extraction or
text
pre-processing this is used to ex
examine the unstructured text by
searching out the important words and
finding the relationships between them
categorization or text transformation
attribute generation categorization
technique labels the text document under
one or more categories classification of
Text data is done based on input output
examples with
categorization clustering or attribute
selection clustering method is used to
group text documents that have similar
content clusters are the partitions and
each cluster will have a number of
documents with similar content
clustering makes sure that no document
will be omitted from the search and it
deres all the documents that have
similar content visualization technique
the process of finding relevant
information is simplified by
visualization technique this technique
uses text Flags to represent a group of
documents or a single document and
compound pness is indicated using colors
visualization technique helps to display
textual information in a more attractive
way summarization or interpretation or
evaluation summarization technique will
help to reduce the length of the
document and summarize the details of
the documents it makes the document easy
to read for users and understand the
content at the moment let's understand
the significance of text
mining document clustering document
clustering is an important part of text
mining it has many applications in
Knowledge Management and information
retrieval clustering makes it easy to
group similar documents into meaningful
groups such as in newspapers where
sections are often grouped as business
Sports politics and so on pattern
identification text mining is the
process of automatically searching large
amount of text for text patterns and
recognition of features features such as
telephone numbers and email addresses
can be extracted using pattern matches
product insights text mining helps to
extract large amounts of text for
example customer reviews about the
products mining consumer reviews can
reveal insights like most loved feature
most hated feature improvements required
and reviews of competitor products
security monitoring text mining helps in
monitoring and extracting information
from news articles and reports for
national security purposes text mining
makes sure to use all of your available
information it is a more effective and
productive knowledge discovery that
allows you to make better informed
decisions automate information intensive
processes gather business critical
insights and mitigate operational
risk let's look at the applications of
text
mining speech recognition speech
recognition is the recog nition and
translation of spoken language into text
and vice versa speech often provides
valuable information about the topics
subjects and concepts of multimedia
content information extraction from
speech is less complicated yet more
accurate and precise than multimedia
content this fact motivates
content-based speech analysis for
multimedia Data Mining and retrieval
where audio and speech processing is a
key enabling
technology spam spam filtering spam
detection is an important method in
which textual information contained in
an email is extracted and used for
discrimination text mining is useful in
automatic detection of spam emails based
on the filtering content using text
mining an email service provider such as
Gmail or Yahoo mail checks the content
of an email and if some malicious text
is found in the mail then that email is
marked as spam and sent to the spam
folder sentiment analysis it is done in
order to determine if a given sentence
expresses positive neutral or negative
sentiments sentiment analysis is one of
the most popular applications of text
analytics the primary aspect of
sentiment analysis includes data
analysis of the body of the text for
understanding the opinion expressed by
it and other key factors comprising
modality and mood usually the process of
sentiment analysis works best on text
that has a subjective context than on
that with only an objective context
e-commerce
personalization text mining is used to
suggest products that fit into a user's
profile text mining is increasingly
being used by e-commerce retailers to
learn more about the consumers as it is
the process of analyzing textual
information in order to identify
patterns and gain insights e-commerce
retailers can Target specific
individuals or segments with
personalized offers and discounts to
boost sales and increase Customer
Loyalty by identifying customer purchase
patterns and opinions on particular
products let's look at natural language
toolkit library in
detail natural language toolkit is a set
of open-source python models that are
used to apply statistical natural
language processing on human language
data let's see how you can do
environment setup of
nltk go to Windows start and launch
python interpreter from Anaconda prompt
and enter the following commands enter
command python to check the version of
python installed on your system enter
import nltk to link you to the nltk
library available to download then enter
nltk dodownload function that will open
the nltk download Lo window check the
download directory select all packages
and click on download this will download
nltk onto your python once you have
downloaded the nltk you must check the
working and functionality of it in order
to test the setup enter the following
command in Python idle from nltk Doc
Corpus import Brown brown. word
parenthesis parenthesis the Brown is an
nltk Corpus that shows the systematic
difference between different genres
available words function will give you
the list available words in the genre
the given output shows that we have
successfully tested the nltk installed
on
python let's Now understand how you can
read a specific module from nltk corpora
if you want to import an entire module
from nltk corpora use asterisk symbol
with that module named import command
enter the command from nltk book import
asterisk it will load all the items
available in NLT K's book module now in
order to explore Brown Corpus enter the
command nltk do Corpus import Brown this
will import Brown Corpus on the python
enter brown. categories function to load
the different genres available select a
genre and assign that genre to a
variable using the following syntax
variable name is equal to brown. wordss
categories is equal to genre name now in
order to see the available words inside
the selected genre just enter the
defined variable name as a
command let's understand text extraction
and pre-processing in detail so let's
first understand the concept of
tokenization tokenization is the process
of removing sensitive data and placing
unique symbols of identification in that
place in order to retain all the
essential information concerned with the
data by its security it is a process of
breaking running streams of text into
words and sentences it works by
segregating words using punctuation and
spaces text extraction and
pre-processing
engrams now let's look at what engram is
and how it is helpful in text mining
engram is the simplest model that
assigns these probabilities to sequences
of words or sentences engrams are
combinations of adjacent words or
letters of length and in the source text
so engram is very helpful in text mining
when it is required to extract patterns
from the text as in the given example
this is a sentence all of these words
are considered individual words and thus
represent unigrams a two gr or Byram is
a two-word sequence of words like this
is is a or a sentence and a thre or
trigram is a three-word sequence of
words like this is a or is a
sentence let's Now understand what stop
words are and how you can remove
them stop words are natural language
words that have negligible meanings such
as a a n and or the and other similar
words these words also will take up
space in the database or increase the
processing time so it is better to
remove such words by storing a list of
stop words you can find the list of stop
words in the nltk data directory that is
stored in 16 different languages use the
following command to list the stop words
of English language defined in nltk
Corpus importing nltk will import the
nltk Corpus for that instance enter from
nltk Doc Corpus import Stop wordss will
import Stop wordss from nltk Corpus Now
set the language as English so use set
function as set under braces stopwords
do wordss set genre as English stop
wordss are filtered out before
processing of natural language data as
they don't reveal much information so as
you you can see in the given example
before filtering the sentence the
tokenization of stop word is processed
in order to remove these stop words and
the filtering is applied in order to
filter the sentence based on some
criteria text extraction and
pre-processing
stemming stemming is used to reduce a
word to stem or base word by removing
suffixes such as helps helping helped
and helper to the root word help the
steming process or algorithm is
generally called a stemmer there are
various stemming algorithms such as
Porter stemmer Lancaster stemmer
snowball stemmer Etc use any of the
stemmers defined under nltk stem Corpus
in order to perform stemming as shown in
the example here we have used Porter
stemmer When You observe the output you
will see that all of the words given
have been reduced to their root word or
stem text extraction and pre-processing
lemmatization lemmatization is the
method of grouping the various inflected
types of a word in order that they can
be analyzed as one item it uses
vocabulary list or a morphological
analysis to get the root word it uses
word net database that has English words
linked together by their semantic
relationship as you can observe the
given example the different words have
been extracted to their relevance
morphological word using
lemmatization text extraction and
pre-processing POS
tagging let's now look at different part
of speech tags available in the national
language toolkit Library A P tag is a
special label assigned to each token or
word in a Text corpus to indicate the
part of speech and often also other
grammatical categories such as tense
number either plural or singular case
Etc
POS tags are used in text analysis tools
and algorithms and also in Corpus
searches so look at the given example
here Alice wrote a program is the source
text given the POS tags given are Alice
is a noun wrote is a verb a is an
article and program is an adjective look
at the given example to understand how
POS tags are defined so the given
sentence or paragraph contains different
words that represent different parts of
speech we will first use tokenization
and removal of stop words and then
allocate the different POS tags these
are shown with different words in the
given sentence POS tags are useful for
lemmatization in building named entity
recognition and extracting relationships
between
words text extraction and pre-processing
named entity recognition now let's
understand what named entity recognition
is all about out Neer seeks to extract a
realworld entity from the text and sorts
it into predefined categories such as
names of people organizations locations
Etc many real world questions can be
answered with the help of name entity
recognition were specified products
mentioned in complaints or reviews does
the Tweet contain the name of a person
does the Tweet contain the person's
address as you can see in the given
example Google America Larry Page Etc
are the names of a person place or an
organization so these are considered
named entities and have different tags
such as person organization gpe or
geopolitical entity
Etc NLP process
workflow now you have an understanding
of all nltk tools so now let's
understand the natural language
processing workflow step one
tokenization it splits text into pieces
tokens or words and removes punctuation
step two stop word removal it removes
commonly used words such as the is R Etc
which are not relevant to the analysis
step three stemming and litiz it reduces
words to base form in order to be
analyzed as a single item step four POS
tagging it tags words to be part of
speech such as noun verb adjective Etc
based on the definition and context step
five information retrieval it extracts
relevant information from the
source demo1 Brown Corpus problem
statement the Brown University standard
Corpus of present-day American English
also known popularly as brown Corpus was
compiled in the 1960s as a general
Corpus in the field of Corpus
Linguistics it contains 500 samples of
English language text totaling roughly 1
million words compiled from Works
published in the United States in
1961 we will be working on one of the
subset data set and perform text
processing tasks let us import the nltk
library and read the
ca10 Corpus import
nltk we will have to make sure that
there are no slashes in between hence we
will use the replace function within
pandas for the
same let's have a look at the data
once
tokenization after performing sentence
tokenization on the data we
obtain
similarly after applying sentence
tokenizer the resulting output shows all
individual words
tokens stop word removal let's import
the stopword library from nltk Doc
Corpus import
stopwords we also need to ensure that
the text is in the same case nltk has
its own list of stop wordss we can check
the list of stopwords using stopwords do
wordss and English inside the
parenthesis map the lowercase string
with our list of word tokens
let's remove the stop wordss using the
English stop wordss list in
nltk we will be using set checking as it
is faster in Python than a
list
by removing all stop wordss from the
text we
obtain often we want to remove the
punctuations from the documents too
since python comes with batteries
included we have string. punctuation
from string import
punctuation
combining the punctuation with the stop
wordss from
nltk
removing stop words with
punctuation stemming and
litiz we will be using stemming and
lemmatization to reduce words to their
root form for example walks walking walk
will be reduced to their root word walk
importing Porter stemmer as the stemming
library from nltk stem import Porter
stemmer printing the stem
words import the word net lemmatizer
from nltk do
stem printing the root
words we also need to evaluate the POS
tags for each
token create a new word list and store
the list of word tokens against each of
the sentence tokens in data 2 for I and
tokenized
also we will check if there were any
stop words in the recently created word
list we will now tag the word tokens
accordingly using the POS tags and print
the tagged
output
for our final text processing task we
will be applying named entity
recognition to classify named entities
in text into predefined categories such
as the names of persons organizations
locations expressions of times
quantities monetary values percentages
Etc
now press the tagged sentences under the
chunk parser if we set the parameter
binary equals true then named entities
are just tagged as NE otherwise the
classifier adds category labels such as
person organization and
gpe create a function named as extract
entity names along with an empty list
named as entity
names
we will now extract named entities from
a nltk chunked expression and store them
in the empty created
above
again we will set the entity names list
as an empty list and will extract The
Entity names by iterating over each tree
in chunked
sentences
great we have seen how to explore and
examine the Corpus using text processing
techniques let's quickly recap the steps
we've covered so far One Import the nltk
library two perform tokenization three
perform stemming and lemmatization four
remove stop words five perform named
entity
recognition structuring sentences
syntax let's first understand what
syntax is syntax is the grammatical
structure of sentences in the given
example this can be interpreted as
syntax and it is similar to the ones you
use while writing codes knowing a
language includes the power to construct
phrases and sentences out of morphemes
and words the part of the grammar that
represents a speaker's knowledge of
these structures and their formation is
called syntax phrase structure rules are
rules that determine what goes into a
phrase that is constituents of a phrase
and how the constituents are ordered
constituent is a word or group of words
that operate as a unit and can be used
to frame larger grammatical units the
given diagram represents that a noun
phrase is determined when a noun is
combined with a determiner and the
determiner can be optional a sentence is
determined when a noun phrase is
combined with a verb phrase a verb
phrase is determined when a verb is
combined optionally with the noun phrase
and prepositional phrase and a
prepositional phrase is determined when
a preposition is combined with a noun
phrase a tree is a representation of
syntactics structure of formulation of
sentences or strings consider the given
sentence the factory employs 12.8% of
Bradford County what can be the Syntax
for pairing this statement let's
understand this a tree is produced that
might help you understand that the
subject of the sentence is the factory
the predicate is imploy and the target
is
12.8% which in turn is modified by Brad
for County syntax parses are often a
first step toward deep information
extraction or semantic understanding of
text rendering syntax
trees download the corresponding exe
file to install the ghost script
rendering engine based on your system
configuration in order to render syntax
trees in your
notebook let's understand how you can
set up the environment variable once you
have have downloaded and installed the
file go to the folder where it is
installed and copy the path of the file
now go to system properties and under
Advanced properties you will find the
environment variable button click on
that to open the popup box tab of the
environment now open the bin folder and
add the path to the bin folder in your
environment
variables now you will have to modify
the path of the environment variable use
the given code to test the working of
syntax tree after the setup is
successfully
installed structuring sentences chunking
and chunk
parsing the process of extraction of
phrases from unstructured text is called
chunking instead of using just simple
tokens which may not represent the
actual meaning of the text it is
advisable to use phrases such as Indian
team as a single word instead of Indian
and team as separate words the chunk in
segmentation refers to identifying
tokens and labeling refers to
identifying the correct tag these chunks
corespond to mixed patterns in some way
to extract patterns from chunks we need
chunk parsing the chunk parsing segment
refers to identifying strings of tokens
and labeling refers to identifying the
correct chunk type let's look at the
given an example you can see here that
yellow is an adjective dog is a noun and
the is the determiner which are chunked
together into a noun phrase similarly
chunk parsing is used to extract
patterns and to process such patterns
from multiple chunks while using
different
parsers let's take an example and try to
understand how chunking is performed in
Python let's consider the sentence the
little mouse ate the fresh cheese
assigned to a variable named scent using
the word tokenize function under nltk
corporate
you can find out the different tags
associated with the sentence provided so
as you can see in the output different
tags have been allocated against each of
the words from the given sentence using
chunking NP chunk and
parser you will now create grammar from
a noun phrase and will mention the tags
you want in your chunk phrase within the
function here you have created a regular
expression matching the string the given
regular expression indicat Ates optional
determiner followed by optional number
of adjective followed by a noun you will
now have to parse the chunk therefore
you will create a chunk parser and pass
your noun phrase string to it the parser
is now ready you will use the parse
parenthesis parenthesis within your
chunk parser to parse your sentence the
sentence provided is the little mouse at
the fresh cheese this sentence has been
parsed and the tokens that match the
regular expressions are are chunked
together into noun phrases
NP create a verb phrase chunk using
regular Expressions the regular
expression has been defined as optional
personal pronoun followed by zero or
more verbs with any of its type followed
by any type of adverb you'll now create
another chunk parser and pass the verb
phrase string to it create another
sentence and tokenize it add POS tags to
it so the new sentence is she is walking
quickly to the mall and the POS tag has
been allocated from nltk corpora now use
the new verb phrase parser to parse the
tokens and run the results you can look
at the given tree diagram which shows a
verb parer where a pronoun followed by
two verbs and an adverb are chunk
together into a verb
parse structuring sentences
chinking chinking is the process of
removing a sequence of token tokens from
a chunk how does chunking work the whole
chunk is removed when the sequence of
tokens spans an entire chunk if the
sequence is at the start or the end of
the chunk the tokens are removed from
the start and end and a smaller chunk is
retained if the sequence of tokens
appears in the middle of the chunk these
tokens are removed leaving two chunks
where there was only one
before consider you create a chinking
grammar string containing three things
chunk name the regular expression
sequence of a chunk the regular
expression sequence of your here
in the given code we have the chunk
regular expression as optional personal
pronoun followed by zero or more
occurrences of any type of the verb type
followed by zero or more occurrences of
any of the adverb types the
regular expression says that it needs to
check for the adverb in the extracted
chunk and remove it from the chunk
inside the chinking block with open
curly braces and closing curly braces
you have created one or more
adverbs you will now create a parser
from nltk do
regex parser and pass the grammar
to it now use the new parser to
parse the tokens sent three and run the
results as you can see the parse tree is
generated while comparing the syntax
tree of the parser with that of
the original chunk you can see that the
token is quickly adverb chined out of
the chunk let's understand how to use
context free
grammar a context free grammar is a four
Tuple sum NTR RS where sum is an
alphabet and each character in sum is
called a terminal NT is a set and each
element in NT is called a non-terminal r
the set of rules is a subset of n n t
times the set of sum U NT s the start
symbol is one of the symbols in NT a
context free grammar generates a
language L capturing constituency and
ordering in CFG the start symbol is used
to derive the string you can derive the
string by repeatedly replacing a
non-terminal on the right hand side of
the production until all non-terminals
have been replaced by terminal symbols
let's understand the representation of
context free grammar through an example
in context free grammar a sentence can
be represented as a noun phrase followed
by a verb phrase noun phrase can be a
determiner nominal a nominal can be a
noun VP represents the verb phrase a can
be called a determiner flight can be
called a noun consider the string below
where you have certain rules when you
look at the given context free grammar a
sentence should have a noun phe phrase
followed by a verb phrase a verb phrase
is a verb followed by a noun a verb can
either be saw or met noun phrases can
either be John or Jim and a noun can
either be a dog or a cat check the
possible list of sentences that can be
generated using the rules use the join
function to create the possible list of
sentences you can check the different
rules of grammar for sentence formation
using the production function it will
show you the different tags used and the
defined context free grammar for the
given
sentence demo two structuring sentences
problem statement a company wants to
perform text analysis for one of its
data sets you are provided with this
data set named tweets. CSV which has
tweets of six US Airlines along with
their sentiments positive negative and
neutral the tweets are present in the
text column and sentiments in Airline
sentiment column we will be be
retrieving all tags starting with at the
rate in the data set and save the output
in a file called references. txt let us
first import the panda library and read
the tweets data
set
extract the features text and Airline
sentiment we will iterate through the
data set using reg X find the relevant
tweets now we will import the itertools
module it returns efficient
iterators
the result is stored in a file named
references.
txt
let's extract all noun phrases and save
them in a file named noun phrases for
left carat Airline sentiment right carat
review.
txt
here left carat Airline uncore sentiment
right carrat has three three different
values positive negative and neutral so
three files will be
created
now we will iterate all the leaf nodes
and assign them to noun phrases
variable
this means means that the functions in
iter tools operate on iterators to
produce more complex
iterators using the map function we will
get all the noun phrases from the
text
putting it into
list
creating a file name in the name of
review.
txt
great we have now seen how to explore
and examine the Corpus using text
processing techniques if you're looking
for a course that covers everything from
the fundamentals to Advanced Techniques
then accelerate your career in Ai and
machine learning with a comprehensive
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning boost your career with this Ai
and ml course delivered in collaboration
with the Peru University and IBM in
demand skills such as machine learning
deep learning NLP computer vision
reinforcement learning generative AI
prompt engineering chat GPT and many
more you'll receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with five capstones in different
domains using real data sets you will
gain practical experience master classes
by perdu faculty and IBM experts ensure
top-notch education simply learns job
assist help you get noticed by Leading
companies this program covers statist
itics python supervised and unsupervised
learning NLP neural networks computer
vision G scas tensorflow and many more
suchar skills admission to this
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning requires a bachelor's degree
with an average of 50% or higher marks
along with the basic understanding of
programming Concepts and Mathematics and
candidates with two plus years of work
experience are preferred to enroll in
this school so enroll now and unlock
exciting Ai and machine learning
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below the term
generative AI has emersed seemingly out
of nowhere in recent months with a
notable search in interest according to
Google Trends even within the past year
the spike in curiosity can be attributed
to the introduction of generative models
such as d 2 B and
chgb however what does generative AI
entail as a part of our introdu series
on generative AI this video will provide
a comprehensive overview of a subject
starting from the basics the explanation
Will C to all levels of familiarity
ensuring that viewers gain a better
understanding of how this technology
operates and its growing integration to
our daily lives generative AI is after
all a tool that is based on artificial
intelligence a professional who El seats
to switch careers with AI by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
simply lar postgraduate program in Ai
and machine learning from perd
University in collaboration with IBM the
link in the description box should
navigate to the homepage where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered take action upskill and
get ahead what is generative AI
generative AI is a form of artificial
intelligence possesses the capability of
to generate a wide range of Conta
including text visual audio and
synthetic data the recent excitement
surrounding generative AI stems from the
user friendly interfaces that allow
users to effortlessly create high
quality text graphics and video within a
seconds now moving forward let's see how
does generative AI Works generative AI
begin a prompt which can take form of
text image video design audio musical
notes or any input that AI system can
process various AI algorithm that
generate new content in response to the
given prompt this content can range from
essay and problem solution to realistic
created using images or audio of a
person in the early stages of generative
AI utilizing the technology involved
submitting data through an API or a
complex process developers need to
acquaint themselves with a specialized
tool and writing application using
programming language like python some of
the recent and fully operational
generative AIS are Google Bart Dal open
AI chat GPT Microsoft Bing and many more
so now let's discuss chat GPT D and B
which are the most popular generative AI
interfaces so first is DAL 2 which was
developed using open a GPT
implementation in 2021 exemplify a
multimodel AI application it has been
trained on a v data set of images and
their corresponding textual description
Dal is capable of establishing
connection between various media forms
such as Vision text audio it
specifically links the meaning of words
to visual elements open a introduced an
enhanced version called d 2 in 2022
which empowers user to generate imagery
in multiple Styles based on their
prompts and the next one is chat GPT in
November 2022 chat GPT and AI power
chatbot built on open AI GPD 3.5
implementation gained immense popularity
worldwide open AI enabled user to
interact with and fine tune the chatbot
text response through a chat interface
with interactive feedback unlike earlier
version of GPT that was solely
accessible via an API chat GPT brought a
more interactive experience on March 14
2023 open a released GPT 4 chat GPT
integrate the conversational history
with a user making a genuine dialogue
Microsoft impressed by the success of
new chgb interface announced a
substantial investment in open Ai and
integrated a version of GPT into its
Bing search engine and the next one is
Bard Google bard Google was also an
earlier Fortuner in advancing
Transformer AI techniques for language
processing protein analysis and other
content types it made some of these
model open source for researchers but
were not made available through a public
interface in response to Microsoft
integration of GPT into Bing Google
hardly launched a public facing chat Bo
named Google b b deut was met by an
error when the language model
incorrectly claimed that the web
telescope was the first to discover a
planet in a foreign solar system as a
consequences Google stock price suffered
a significant decline meanwhile
Microsoft implementation of chat gbt and
GPT power system also face criticism for
producing inaccurate result and
displaying ER actic behavior in their
early irritation so moving forward let's
see what are the use cases of generative
AI generative AI has broad applicability
and can be employed across a wide range
of use cases to generate diverse form of
content recent advancement like GPT have
made this technology more accessible and
customizable for various application
some notable use cases for generative AI
are as follows chatbot implementation
generative AI can be utilized to develop
chatbots for customer service and
technical support enhancing interaction
with users and providing efficient
assistance the second one is language
dubbing enhancement in the dam in the
realm of movies and educational
accountant generative AI can contribute
to improving dubbing in different
languages ensuring accurate and high
quality translation and the third one is
content writing generative AI can assist
in writing email responses dating
profiles resumes and term papers
offering valuable support and generating
customized content tailor to specific
requirement and the fourth one is Art
generation leveraging generative AI
artists can create photo realistic
artwork in various Styles and abling the
exploration of new artistic expression
and enhancing creativity the fifth one
is product demonstration videos
generative AI can hun to enhance product
demonstration video making them more
engaging visually appealing and
effective in showcasing product features
and benefits so generative AI
versatility allow it to employ it in
many other application making it a
valuable tool for Content creation and
enhancing user experience across diverse
domains so after seeing use cases of
generative AI let's see what are the
benefits of generative AI so generative
AI offers extensive application across
various business domains simplifying the
interpretation and comprehension of
existing content while also enabling the
automated creation of a new content
developers are actively exploring ways
to leverage generative AI in order to
enhance the optimize existing workflows
and even to reshave workflows entirely
to harness the potential of Technology
fully implementing generative AI can
bring numerous benefits including
automated content creation generative AI
can automate the manual process of
writing content saving time and effort
by generating text or other form of
content the next one is efficient email
response responding to emails can be
made more efficient with generative a
reducing the effort required and
improving response time and the third
one is enhanced technical support
generative AI can improve responses to
specific technical queries providing
accurate and helpful information to
users or customers and the fourth one is
realistic person Generation by
leveraging generative AI it becomes
possible to create realistic
representation of people enabling
applications like virtual characters or
avatars and the fifth one is coherent
information summarization generative AI
can summarize complex information into a
coherent narrative this in key points
and making it easier to understand and
communicate complex concept the
implementation of generative AI offers
arrange of potential benefits steamingly
process and enhancing content Creation
in various areas of business operation
so after seeing advantages of generative
AI let's move forward and see what are
the limitations of generative AI early
implementation of generative AI serve as
Vivid examples highlighting the numerous
limitation associated with this
technology several challenges arise from
the specific approaches employed to
implement various use gifts for instance
while a summary of a complex topic May
more reader friendly than explanation
incorporating multiple supporting
sources the ease of readability comes at
the expense of transparent identifying
the information sources so the first one
is when implementing or utilizing a
generative AI application it is
important to consider the following
limitation I repeat the first one is
lack of source identification generative
AI does not always provide clear
identification of content Source making
it difficult to trace and verify origin
of the information the second one is
assessment of bias assessing the bias of
original sources used generative AI can
be challenging as it may be difficult to
determine the underlying perspective or
agendas of the data utiliz in the
training process the third one is
difficulty in identifying inaccurate
information generative AI can generate
realistic content making identifying
inaccuracy or falsehoods within the
generated output harder and the fourth
one is adaptability to a new
circumstances understanding how to find
tune generative AI for a new
circumstances or specific context can be
complex requiring careful consideration
and expertise to achieve desired result
and the fifth one is glossing over bias
Prejudice and hatred generative AI
results May amplify or preate biases
prejudices or hateful content present in
the training data data requiring
Vigilant scrutiny to prevent such issues
so awareness of these limitation is
crucial when the implementing of
utilizing generative AI as it helps
users and developers critically evaluate
and mitigate potential risk and
challenges associated with the
technology so future of generative AI
furthermore advances in AI development
platforms will contribute to the
accelerated progress of research and
development in the realm of generative
AI the development will Encompass
various domains such as text images
videos 3D contact drugs Supply chains
logistic and business processes while
the current loan tools are impressive
the true transformative impact
generative AI will realize while these
capabilities are seemingly integrated
into the existing tools with regular use
if you want to become an AI expert and
gain handsome salary packages look at
the wide range of eiml courses by simply
learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe so what
are you waiting for hurry up and enroll
Now find the cost link in the
description box my name is Richard
kersner I'm with the simply learn team
what's in it for you well today we're
going to cover what is a neural network
what can neural networks do how does a
neural network work types of neural
networks and then we're going to jump
into a use case to classify between the
photos of dogs and cats and we'll do
that on the carass with the tensor flow
in the back but it's a python script so
that's always my favorite part is when
we dive into the actual script so what
is a neural network so hi guys I heard
you want to know what a neural network
is here we have uh looks like he just
went shopping at a red tag sale my
robot's back so as a matter of fact you
have been using neural network on a
daily basis in today's world is just
amazing how much we use our new
technology we're not even aware of it
when you ask your Mobile Assistant to
perform a search for you you know like
saying uh your Google or Siri or whoever
you use Amazon web self-driving cars so
that's the newest thing coming out
they're just now trying to make those
legal in different states in the US and
around the world even in the UK they now
have a self-driving cars going up and
down the streets pretty amazing these
are all neural network driven computer
games use it so a lot of computer games
are driven by neural networks in the
back end as part of the game system and
how it adjusts to the players and it's
also used in processing the map images
on your phone so every time you do a
navigation someplace and it opens it up
they now use neural networks to help you
find the quickest way to get there
neural network a neural network is a
system or Hardware that is designed to
operate like a human brain in today's
development this is so important to
understand because we don't have
anything else to compare it to I'm sure
someday in the future the computer will
redefine or the neural network or the AI
artificial intelligence will redefine
what these mean but as far as we can
today's world and today's commercial
development we have to compare it to
what humans do so it's we want to
compare how it operates to a human brain
and how it solves problems s like a
human does what can a neural network do
and really we're just going to dive in
deeper to what we just covered and look
at other examples so what can a neural
network do well let's list out the
things neural networks can do for you
translate text boy we got Google
translate and Microsoft has their own
translate they have some really cool
they actually have an earpiece it's
supposed to start translating as you
talk what a cool technology what a cool
time to live identify faces can you
imagine all the uses for facial
identification in the case of our sample
or our code that we're going to look at
later we'll be identifying dogs and cats
so not quite as detailed as
understanding whose face belongs to who
I I'm waiting for the Google Glasses to
come out so I can see who's Who and the
identify faces as I'm walking around
have a little name tag over them not out
there yet but boy we are close we can
identify the faces and they have all
kinds of Technologies to bring that
information back to us recognize speech
goes along with the translate text so
now as you're talking into to your
assistant it can use that to do commands
turn lights on all kinds of things you
can do with recognizing speech read had
written text they're starting to
translate all these old text documents
that they've had in storage instead of
doing it individually where somebody's
going through each text by themselves in
a room picture like an old Raiders of
the Lost Arc theme where he's in the
back you know archaeologist studying the
text now it's fed into a computer they
take a picture they even use neural
networks to take a scroll that is so
messed up that they can't undo the
scroll and they x-ray it and then they
use that x-ray to translate the text off
of it without ever opening the scroll I
mean just way cool stuff they're
starting to do with all this and of
course control robots what would be a
neural network without bringing in the
robots and we have our own favorite
robot in the middle who goes to our red
tag sell and goes shopping for us so you
know these are just a few of the
wonderful things that neural networks
are being applied to it's such an infant
stage technology what a wonderful time
to jump in and there are a lot of other
things it goes into I mean we could
spend just forever talking about all the
different applications from business to
whatever you could even imagine they're
now applying neural networks to help us
understand so now we talked a little bit
about all the cool things you can do
with a neural network let's dive in and
say how does a neural network work so
now we've come far enough to understand
how neural network works let's go ahead
and walk through this in a nice
graphical representation they usually
describe a neural network as having
different layers and you'll see that
we've identified a Green Layer an orange
layer and a red layer the Green Layer is
the input so you have your data coming
in it picks up the input signals and
passes them to the next layer the next
layer does all kinds of calculations and
feature extraction it's called The
Hidden layer a lot of times there's more
than one hidden layer we're only showing
one in this uh picture but we'll show
you how it looks like in a more detail
in a little bit and then finally we have
an output layer this layer delivers the
final result so the only two things we
see is the input layer and the output
layer now let's make use of this neural
network and see how it works wonder how
traffic cameras identify Vehicles
registration plate on the road to detect
speeding vehicles and those breaking the
law they got me going through a red
light the other day well last month
that's like the horrible thing they send
you this picture of you and all your
information cuz they pulled it up off of
your license plate and your picture that
shouldn't have gone through the red
light so here we are and we have an
image of a car and you can see the
license plates on there so let's
consider the image of this vehicle and
find out what's on the number plate the
picture itself is 28x 28 pixels and the
image is fed as an input to identify the
registration plate each neuron has a
number called activation that represents
the grayscale value of the corresponding
pixel range and we range it from zero to
one one for a white pixel and zero for a
black pixel and you can see down here we
have an example where one of the pixels
is registered as like 082 meaning it's
probably pretty dark each neuron is lit
up when its activation is close to one
so as we get closer to black on white we
can really start seeing the details in
there and you can see again the pixel
shows this one up there it's like part
of the car and so it lights up so pixels
in the form of arrays are fed to the
input layer and so we see here the pixel
of a car image fed as an input and
you're going to see that the input layer
which is green is on Dimension while our
image is two Dimension now when we look
at our setup that we're programming in
Python it has a cool feature that
automatically does the work for us if
you're working with an older neural
network pattern package you then convert
each one of those rows so it's all one
array so you'd have like Row one and
then just tack row two onto the end you
can almost feed the image directly into
some of these neural networks the key is
though is that if you're using a 28x 28
and you get a picture of this 30 by3
shrink the 30X 30 down to fit the 28x 28
so you can't increase the number of
input in this case Green Dots it's very
important to remember when you're
working on neural networks and let's
name the inputs X1 X2 X3 respectively so
each one of those represents one of the
pixels coming in and the input layer
passes it to the hidden layer and you
can see here we now have two hidden
layers in this image in the orange and
each one of those pixels connects to
each one of those hidden layers and the
interconnections are assigned weights at
random so they gets these random weights
that come through if X1 lights up then
it's going to be X1 time this weight
going into the hidden layer and we sum
those weights the weights are multiplied
with the input signal and a bias is
added to all of them so as you can see
here we have X1 comes in and it actually
goes to all the different hidden layer
nodes or in this case uh whatever you
want to call them network setup the
orange dots and so you take the value of
X1 you multiply it by the weight for the
next hidden layer so X1 goes to Hidden
layer one X1 goes to Hidden layer 2 X1
goes hidden layer one node two hidden
layer one node three and so on and the
bias a lot of times they just put the
bias in as like another green dot or
another orange Dot and they give the
bias a value one and then all the
weights go in from the bias into the
next note so the bias can change we
always just remember that you need to
have that bias in there there's things
that can be done with it generally most
the package is out there control that
for you so you don't have to worry about
figuring out what the bias is but if you
ever dive deep into neural networks you
got to remember there's a bias or the
answer won't come out correctly the
weighted sum of the input is fed as an
input to the activation function decide
which nodes to Fire and for feature
extraction as a signal flows within the
hidden layers the weighted sum of inputs
is calculated and is fed to the
activation function in each layer to
decide which nodes to fire so here's our
feature extraction of the number plate
and you can see these are still hidden
nodes in the middle and this becomes
important we're going to take a little
detour here and look at the activation
function so we're going to dive just a
little bit into the math so you can
start to understand where some of the
games go on when you're playing with
neural networks in your programming so
let's look at the different activation
functions before we move ahead here's
our friendly red tag shopping robot and
so one is the sigmoid function and the
sigmoid function which is 1 over 1 + e
the minus X takes the x value and you
can see where it generates almost a zero
and almost a one with a very small area
in the Middle where it crosses over and
we can use that value to feed into
another function so if it's really
uncertain it might have a 0.1 or0 2 or3
but for the most part it's going to be
really close to one and really close to
this case 0o 0 to one the threshold
function so if you don't want to worry
about the uncertainty in the middle you
just say oh if x is greater than or
equal to zero if not then uh X is zero
so it's either zero or one really
straightforward there's no in between in
the middle and then you have the what
they call the ru relo function and you
can see here where it puts out the value
but then it says well if it's over one
it's going to be one and if it's uh less
than zero it's zero so it kind of just
dead ends it on those two ends but
allows all the values in the middle and
again this like the sigmoid function
allows that information to go to the
next level so it might be important to
know if it's a 0.1 or a minus 0.1 the
next hidden layer might pick that up and
say oh this piece of information is
uncertain or this value has a very low
certainty to it and then the hyperbolic
tangent function and you can see here
it's a 1 - e to Theus 2x over 1 + e- 2x
and it's very much along the same theme
a little bit different in here and that
it goes between minus one and one so
you'll see some of these they goes 0 to
one but this one goes minus one to one
and if it's less than zero it's you know
it doesn't fire and if it's over zero it
fires and it also still puts out a value
so you still have a value you can get
off of that just like you can with the
sigmoid function and the relo function
very similar in use and I believe the
originally used to be everything was
done in the sigmoid function that was
the most uh commonly used and now they
just kind of use more the relo function
the reason is one it processed is faster
cuz you already have the value and you
don't have to add another compute the 1
over 1 plus e Theus X for each hidden
node and the data coming off works
pretty good as far as putting it into
the next level if you want to know just
how close it is to zero how close is it
not to functioning you know is it minus
.1 minus point2 usually they're float
values you get like minus point youus
0138 or something so you know important
information but the relo is most
commonly used these days as far as the
setup we're using but you'll also see
the sigmoid function very commonly used
also now that you know what an
activation function is let's get back to
the neural network so finally the model
would predict the outcome of applying a
suitable activation function to the
output layer so we go in here we look at
this we have the optical character
recognition OCR is used on the images to
convert it into a text in order to
identify what's written on the plate and
as it comes out you'll see the red node
and the red node might actually
represent just a letter A so there
usually a lot of outputs when you're
doing doing text identification we're
not going to show that on here but you
might have it even in the order it might
be um what order the license plates in
so you might have a bcde e FG you know
the alphabet plus the numbers and you
might have the 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 nine 10
places so it's a very large array that
comes out it's not a small amount of u
you know we show three dots coming in
eight hidden layer nodes you know two
sets of four we just saw one red coming
out a lot of times this is uh you know
28 * 28 if you did 30 * 30 that's you
know 900 nodes so 28 is a little bit
less than that uh just on the input and
so you can imagine the hidden layer is
just as big each hidden layer is just as
big if not bigger then the output is
going to be there's so many digits you
know it's a lot it's a huge amount of
input and output but we're only showing
you just you know be hard to show in one
picture and so it comes up and this is
what it finally gets out on the output
is it identifies a number on the plate
and in this case we have 08- D-
03858 a error in the output is back
propagated through the network and
weights are adjusted to minimize the
error rate this is calculated by a cost
function when we're training our data
this is what's used and we'll look at
that in the code when we do the data
training so we have stuff we know the
answer to and then we put the
information through and it says yes that
was correct or no because remember we
randomly set all the weights to begin
with and if it's wrong we take that
error how far off are you you know are
you off by is it if it was like minus
one you're just a little bit off if it's
likeus 300 was your output remember when
we're looking at those different options
you know hyperbolic or whatever and
we're looking at the RL the RL could
doesn't have an limit on top or bottom
it actually just generates a number so
if it's way off you can have to adjust
those weights a lot but if it's pretty
close you might adjust the weights just
a little bit and you keep adjusting the
weights until they fit all the different
training models you put in so you might
have 500 training models and those
weights will adjust using the the back
propagation it sends the error backward
the output is compared with the original
result and multiple iterations are done
to get the maximum accuracy so not only
does it look at each one but it goes
through it and just keeps cycling
through these the data making small
changes in the network until it gets the
right answers with every iteration the
weights at every interconnection are
adjusted based on the error we're not
going to dive into that math because it
is a differential equation and it gets a
little complicated but I will talk a
little bit about some of the different
options they have when we look at the
code so we've explored a neural network
let's look at the different types of
artificial neural networks and this is
like the biggest area growing is how
these all come together let's see the
different types of neural network and
again we're comparing this to human
learning so here's a human brain I feel
sorry for that poor guy so we have a
feed for forward neural network simplest
form of a they call it Ann a neural
network data travel s only in One
Direction input to Output this is what
we just looked at so as the data comes
in all the weights are added it goes to
the hidden layer all the weights are
added it goes to the next hidden layer
all the weights are added and it goes to
the output the only time you use the
reverse propagation is to train it so
when you actually use it it's very fast
when you're training it it takes a while
because it has to iterate through all
your training data and you start getting
into Big Data because you can train
these with a huge amount of data the
more data you put in the better train
they get the applications vision and
speech recognition actually they're
pretty much everything we talked about a
lot of almost all of them use this form
of neural network at some level radio
basis function neural network this model
classifies the data point based on its
distance from a Center Point what that
means is that you might not have
training data so you want to group
things together and you create Central
points and it looks for all the things
you know some of these things are just
like the other if you've ever watch
watch the Sesame Street as a kid that
dates me so it brings things together
and this is a great way if you don't
have the right training model you can
start finding things that are connected
you might not have noticed before
applications power restoration systems
they try to figure out what's connected
and then based on that they can fix the
problem if you have a huge power system
and self-organizing neural network
vectors of random dimensions are input
to discrete map comprised of neurons so
they basically find a way to draw n
column they say Dimensions or vectors or
planes because they actually chop the
data in one dimension two Dimension
three dimension four five six they keep
adding dimensions and finding ways to
separate the data and connect different
data pieces together applications used
to recognize patterns in data like in
medical analysis the hidden layer saves
its output to be used for future
prediction recurrent neural networks so
the hidden layers remember its output
from last time and that becomes part of
its new input uh you might use that
especially in robotics or flying a drone
you want to know what your last change
was and how fast it was going to help
predict which your next change you need
to make is to get to where the Drone
wants to go applications text to speech
conversation model so you know I talked
about drones but you know just
identifying on Lexus or Google assistant
or any of these they're starting to add
in I'd like to play a song on my Pandora
and I'd like it to be at volume 90% so
you now can add different things in
there and it connects them together the
input features are taken in batches like
a filter this allows a network to
remember an image in Parts convolution
neural network today's world in photo
identification and taking apart photos
and trying to you know you ever seen
that on Google where you have five
people together this is the kind of
thing separates all those people so then
it can do a face recognition on each
person applications used in signal and
image processing in this case I use
facial images or Google picture images
as one of the options
modular neural network it has a
collection of different neural networks
working together to get the output so
wow we just went through all these
different types of neural networks and
the final one is to put multiple neural
networks together and I mentioned that a
little bit when we separated people in a
larger photo in individuals in the photo
and then do the facial recognition on
each person so one network is used to
separate them and the next network is
then used to figure out who they are and
do the facial recognition applications
still undergoing research this is a
Cutting Edge you hear the term Pipeline
and there's actual in Python code and in
almost all the different neural network
setups out there they now have a
pipeline feature usually and it just
means you take the data from one neural
network and maybe another neural network
or you put it into the next neural
network and then you take three or four
other neural networks and feed them into
another one so how we connect the neural
networks is really just Cutting Edge and
it's so experimental I mean it's almost
creative in its nature there's not
really a science to it because each
specific domain has different things
it's looking at so if you're in the
banking domain it's going to be
different than the medical domain than
the automatic car domain and suddenly
figuring out how those all fit together
is just a lot of fun and really cool so
we have our types of artificial neural
network we have our feat forward neural
network we have our radial basis
function neural network we have our
cohenon self-organizing neural network
recurrent neural network Evolution
neural network and modular neural
network where it brings them all
together and U Know the colors on the
brain do not match what your brain
actually does but they do bring it out
that most of these were developed by
understanding how humans learn and as we
understand more and more of how humans
learn we can build something in the
computer industry to mimic that to
reflect that and that's how these were
developed so exciting part use case
problem statement so this is where we
jump in this is my favorite part let's
use a system to identify between a cat
and a dog if you remember correctly I
said we're going to do some python code
and you can see over here my hair is
kind of sticking up over the computer
cup of coffee on one side and then a
little bit of old school a pencil and a
pen on the other side yeah most people
Now take notes I love the stickies on
the computer that's great that's that is
my computer I have sticky notes on my
computer in different colors so not too
far from uh today's programmer so the
problem is is we want to classify photos
of cats and dogs using a neural network
and you can see over here we have quite
a variety of dogs in the pictures and
cats and you know just sorting out it is
a cat is pretty amazing and why would
anybody want to even know the difference
between a cat and a dog okay you know
why well I have a cat door it'd be kind
of fun that instead of it identifying
instead of having like a little collar
with a magnet on it which is what my cat
has the door would be able to see oh
that's the cat that's our cat coming in
oh that's the dog we have a dog too
that's the dog I want to let in maybe I
don't want to let this other animal in
cuz it's a raccoon so you can see where
you could take this one step further and
actually apply this you could actually
start a little startup company idea
self-identifying door so this use case
will be implemented on python I am
actually in Python 3.6 it's always nice
to tell people the version of python cuz
that does affect sometimes which modules
you load and everything and we're going
to start by importing the required
packages I told you we're going to do
this in carass so we're going to import
from carass models a sequential from the
coros layers conversion 2D or CV 2D Max
pooling 2D flatten and dents and we'll
talk about what each one of these do in
just a second but before we do that
let's talk a little bit about the
environment we're going to work in and
uh you know in fact let me go ahead and
open a uh the website Caro's website so
we can learn a little bit more about
carass so here we are on the carass
website and it's uh
K.I that's the official website for
carass and the first thing you'll notice
is that carass runs on top of either
tensorflow cntk and I think it's
pronouned thano or Theo what's important
on here is that tensorflow and the same
is true for all these but tensor flow is
probably one of the most widely used
currently packages out there with the
carass and of course you know tomorrow
this is all going to change it's all
going to disappear and they'll have
something new out there so make sure
when you're learning this code that you
understand what's going on and also know
the code I mean look when you look at
the code it's not as complicated once
you understand what's going on the code
itself is pretty straightforward and the
reason we like carass and the reason
that people are jumping on it right now
it's such a big deal is if we come down
here let me just scroll down a little
bit they talk about user friendliness
modularity easy extensibility work with
python Python's a big one because a lot
of people in data science now use Python
although you can actually access carass
other ways is if we continue down here
is layers and this is where it gets
really cool when we're working with
carass you you just add layers on
remember those hidden layers we were
talking about and we talked about the
reu activation you can see right here
let me just up that a little bit in size
there we go that's big I can add in an
Ru layer and then I can add in a softmax
layer the next instance we didn't talk
about soft Max so you can do each layer
separate now if I'm working in some of
the other kits I use I take that and I
have one setup and then I feed the
output into the next one this one I can
just add hidden layer after hidden layer
with a different information in it which
makes it very powerful and very fast to
spin up and try different setups and see
how they work with the data you're
working on and we'll dig a little bit
deeper in here and a lot of this is very
much the same so when we get to that
part I'll point that out to you also now
just a quick side note I'm using
Anaconda with python in it and I went
ahead and created my own package and I
called it the carass python 36 CU I'm in
Python 36 Anaconda is cool that way you
can create different environments really
easily if you're doing a lot of
different experimenting with these
different packages probably want to
create your own environment in there and
the first thing is you can see right
here there's a lot of dependencies a lot
of these you should recognize by now if
you've done any of these videos if not
kudos for you for jumping in today pip
install numpy scipi the S kit learn
pillow and
h5py are both needed for the tensor flow
and then putting the carass on there and
then you'll see here uh and pip is just
a standard installer that you use with
python you'll see here that we did pip
install tensor flow since we're going to
do carass on top of tensor flow and then
pip install and I went ahead and used
the GitHub so git plus git and you'll
see here github.com this is one of their
releases one of the most current release
on there that goes on top of tensorflow
and you can look up these instructions
pretty much anywhere this is for doing
it on Anaconda certainly you'd want to
install these if you're doing it in a
buntu server setup you you'd want to get
I don't think you need the h5py and ab
buntu but you do need the rest in there
because they are dependencies in there
and it's pretty straightforward and
that's actually in some of the
instructions they have on their website
so you don't have to necessarily go
through this just remember their website
on there and then when I'm under my uh
Anaconda Navigator which I like you'll
see where I have environments and on the
bottom I created a new environment and I
called it carass python 36 just to
separate everything you can say I have
python 3.5 and python 36 I used to have
a bunch of other ones but I kind of
cleaned house recently and of course
once I go in here I can launch my
Jupiter notebook making sure I'm using
the right environment that I just set up
this of course opens up my um in this
case I'm using Google Chrome and in here
I could go and just create a new
document in here and this is all in your
um browser Winer when you use the
Anaconda do you have to use anaconda and
jupyter notebook no you can use any kind
of python editor whatever setup you're
comfortable with and whatever you're
doing in there so let's go ahead and go
in here and paste the code in and we're
importing a number of different settings
in here we have import sequen IAL that's
under the models cuz that's the model
we're going to use as far as our neural
network and then we have layers and we
have conversion 2D Max pooling 2D
flatten dense and you can actually just
kind of guess at what these do we're
talking we're working in a 2d photograph
and if you remember correctly I talked
about how the actual input layer is a
single array it's not in two Dimensions
it's one dimension all these do is these
are tools to help flatten the image so
it takes a two-dimensional image and
then it creates its own proper setup you
don't have to worry about any of that
you don't have to do anything special
with the photograph you let the carass
do it we're going to run this and you'll
see right here they have some stuff that
is going to be depreciated and changed
because that's what it does everything's
being changed as we go you don't have to
worry about that too much if you have
warnings if you run it a second time the
warning will disappear and this has just
imported these packages for us to use
Jupiter's nice about this that you can
do each thing step by step and I'll go
ahead and also zoom in there a little
control plus that's one of the nice
things about being in in a browser
environment so here we are back another
sip of coffee if you're familiar with my
other videos you notice I'm always
sipping coffee I always have a my case
latte next to me an espresso so the next
step is to go ahead and initialize we're
going to call it the CNN or classifier
neural network and the reason we call it
a classifier is because it's going to
classify it between two things it's
going to be cat or dog so when you're
doing classification you're picking
specific objects you're specific it's a
true or false yes no it is something or
it's not so first thing we're going to
create our classifier and it's going to
equal sequential so there sequential
setup is the classifier that's the
actual model we're using that's the
neural network so we call it a
classifier and uh the next step is to
add in our convolution and let me just
do a uh let me shrink that down inside
so you can see the whole line and let's
talk a little bit about what's going on
here I have my classifier and I add
something what am I adding well I'm
adding my first layer this first layer
we're adding in is probably the one that
takes the most work to make sure you
have it set correct and the reason I say
that this is your actual input and we're
going to jump here to the part that says
input shape equals 64x 64 by 3 what is
that mean well that means that our
pictures coming in and there's these
pictures remember we had like the
picture of the car was 128 by 128 pixels
well this one is 64x 64 pixels and each
pixel has three values that's where
these numbers come from and it is so
important that this matches I mentioned
a little bit that if you have like a
larger picture you have to reformat it
to fit this shape if it comes in as
something larger there's no input notes
there's no input neural network there
that will handle that extra space so you
have to reshape your data to fit in here
now the first layer is the most
important because after that coros knows
what your shape is coming in here and it
knows what's coming out and so that
really sets the stage most important
thing is that input shape matches your
data coming in and you'll get a lot of
Errors if it doesn't you'll go through
there and picture number 55 doesn't
match it correctly and guess what it
does it usually gives you an error and
then the activation if you remember we
talked about the different activations
on here we're using the reu model like I
said that is the most commonly used now
because one it's fast doesn't have the
added calculations in it it just says
here's a value coming out based on the
weights and the value going in and um
from there you know it's uh it's if it's
over one then it's good or over zero
it's good if it's under zero then it's
considered not active and then we have
this conversion 2D what the heck is
conversion 2D I'm not going to go into
too much detail in this because this has
a couple things it's doing in here a
little bit more in-depth than we're
ready to cover in this tutorial but this
is used to convert from the photo
because we have 64x 64x 3 and we're just
converting it to to two-dimensional kind
of setup so it's very aware that this is
a photograph and that different pieces
are next to each other and then we're
going to add in uh a second
convolutional layer that's what the co
NV stands for 2D so it's these are
hidden layers so we have our input layer
and our two hidden layers and they are
two-dimensional because we're doing with
a two-dimensional photograph and you'll
see down here that on the last one we
add a Max pooling 2D and we put a pool
size equals 22 and so what this is is
that as you get to the end of these
layers one of the things you always want
to think of is what they call mapping
and then reducing wonderful terminology
from the Big Data we're mapping this
data through all these layers and now we
want to reduce it to only two sets in
this case it's already in two sets cuz
it's a 2d photograph but we had you know
two Dimensions by we actually have 64x
64x 3 so now we're just getting it down
to a 2X two just the two-dimension
two-dimensional instead of having the
third dimension of colors and we'll go
ahead and run these we're not really
seeing anything on our run script
because we're just setting up this is
all set up and this is where you start
playing CU maybe you'll add a different
layer in here to do something else to
see how it works and see what your
output is that's what makes carass so
nice is I can with just a couple flips
of code put in a whole new layer that
does a whole new processing and see
whether that improves my run or makes it
worse and finally we're going to do the
final setup which is to flatten
classifier add a flatten setup and then
we're going to also add a layer a dense
layer and then we're going to add in
another dense layer and then we're going
to build it we're going to compile this
whole thing together so let's flip over
and see what that looks like and we've
even numbered them for you so we're
going to do the flattening and flatten
is exactly what it sounds like we've
been working in a two-dimensional array
of picture which actually is in three
dimensions because of the pixels the
pixels have a whole another dimension to
it of three different values and we'
kind of resized those down to 2x two but
now we're just going to flatten it I
don't want to have have multiple
Dimensions being worked on by tensor and
by carass I want just a single array so
it's flattened out and then step four
full connection so we add in our final
two layers and you could actually do all
kinds of things with this you could
actually leave out this um some of these
layers and play with them you do need to
flatten it that's very important then we
want to use the dents again we're taking
this and we're taking whatever came into
it so once we take all those different
the two Dimensions or three dimensions
as they are and we flatten it to one
dimension we want to take that and we're
going to pull it into units of 128 they
got that you say where did they get 128
from you could actually play with that
number and get all kinds of weird
results but in this case we took the 64
+ 64 is 128 you could probably even do
this with 64 or 32 usually want to keep
it in the same multiple whatever the
data shape you're already using is in
and we're using the activation the r l
just like we did before and then we
finally filter all that into a single
output and it has how many units one why
cuz we want to know whether true or
false it's either a dog or a cat you
could say one is dog zero is cat or
maybe you're a cat lover and it's one is
cat and zero is dog and if you love both
dogs and cats you're going to have to
choose and then we use the sigmoid
activation if you remember from before
we had the ru and there's also the
sigmoid the sigmoid just makes it clear
it's yes or no we don't want a any kind
of in between number coming out and
we'll go ahead and run this and you'll
see it's still all in setup and then
finally we want to go ahead and compile
and let's put the compiling our um
classifier neural network and we're
going to use the optimizer atom and I
hinted at this just a little bit before
where does atom come in where does an
Optimizer come in well the optimizer is
the reverse propagation when we're
training it it goes all the way through
and says error and then how does it
readjust those weights there are a
number of them atom is the most commonly
used and it works best on large data
most people stick with the atom because
when they're testing on smaller data see
if their model is going to go through
and get all their errors out before they
run it on larger data sets they're going
to run it on atom anyway so they just
leave it on atom most commonly used but
there are some other ones out there you
should be aware of that that you might
try them if you're stuck in a bind or
you might blore that in the future but
usually Adam is just fine on there and
then you have two more settings you have
loss and metrics we're not going to dig
too much into loss or metrics these are
things you really have to explore carass
cuz there are so many choices this is
how it computes the error there's so
many different ways to on your back
propagation and your training so we're
using the atom model but you can compute
the error by um standard deviation
standard deviation squared they use
binary crossentropy I'd have to look
that up to even know what that is
there's so many of these a lot of times
you just start with the ones that look
correct that are most commonly used and
then you have to go read the coros site
and actually see with these different
losses and metrics and what different
options they have so we're not going to
get too much into them other than to
reference you over to the carass website
to explore them deeper but we are going
to go ahead and run them and now we've
set up our classifier so we have an
object classifier and if you go back up
here you'll see that we've added in step
one we added in our layer for the input
we added a layer that comes in there and
uses the reu for Activation and then it
pulls the data so this is even though
these are two layers the actual neural
Network layer is up here and then it
uses this to pull the data into a 2X two
so into a two-dimensional array from a
three-dimensional array with the colors
then we flatten it so there's our add
our flatten and then we add another
dense what they call dense layer this
dense layer goes in there and it it
downsizes it to 128 it reduces it so you
can look at this as uh we're mapping all
this data down the two-dimensional setup
and then we flatten it so we map it to a
flatten map and then we take it and
reduce it down to 120 28 and we use the
ru again and then finally we reduce that
down to just a single output and we use
the sigmoid to do that to figure out
whether it's yes no true false in this
case cat or dog and then finally once we
put all these layers together we compile
them that's what we've done here and
we've compiled them as far as how it
trains to use these settings for the
training back propagation so if you
remember we talked about training our
setup and when we go into this you'll
see that we have two data sets we have
one called the training set and the
testing set and that's very standard in
any data processing is you need to have
that's pretty common in any data
processing is you need to have a certain
amount of data to train it and then you
got to know whether it works or not is
it any good and that's why you have a
separate set of data for testing it
where you already know the answer but
you don't want to use that as part of
the training set so in here we jump into
part two fitting the classifier nerve
Network to the images and then from
carass let me just zoom in there I
always love that about working with
Jupiter notebooks you can really see
we're going to come in here we do the
cross pre-processing an image and we
import image data generator so nice of
carass it's such a high-end product
right now going out and since images are
so common they already have all this
stuff to help us process the data which
is great and so we come in here we do
train data gen and we're going to create
our object for helping us trainer for
reshaping the data so that it's going to
work with our setup and we use an image
data generator and we're going to
rescale it and you'll see here we have 1
point which tells us it's a float value
on the rescale over 255 where does 255
come from well that's the scale in the
colors of the pictures we're using they
value from 0 to 255 so we want to divide
it by 255 and it'll generate a number
between zero and one they have sheer
range and zoom range horizontal flip
equals true and this of course has to do
with if the photos are different shapes
and sizes like I said it's a wonderful
package you really need to dig in deep
to see all the different options you
have for setting up your images for
right now though we're going to just
stick with some basic stuff here and let
me go ahead and run this code and again
it doesn't really do anything cuz we're
still setting up the pre-processing
let's take a look at this next set of
code and this one is just huge we're
creating the training set so the
training set is going to go in here and
it's going to use our train data gen we
just created flow from directory it's
going to access in this case the path
data set training set that's a folder so
it's going to pull all the images out of
that folder now I'm actually running
this in the folder that the data sets in
so if you're doing the same setup and
you load your data in there and you're
doing this make sure wherever your
Jupiter notebook is saving things to
that you create this path or you can do
the complete path if you need to you
know C colon slash Etc and the target
size the batch size and class mode is
binary so the class is we're switching
everything to a binary value batch size
what the heck is batch size well that's
how many pictures we're going to batch
through the training each time and the
target size 64x 64 a little confusing
but you can see right here that this is
just a general training and you can go
in there and look at all the different
settings for your training set and of
course with different data we're doing
pictures there's all kinds of different
settings depending on what you're
working with let's go ahead and run that
see what happens and you'll see that it
found 800 images belonging to one
classes so we have 800 images in the
training set and if we're going to do
this with uh the training set we also
have to format the pictures in the test
set now we're not actually doing any
predictions we're not actually
programming the model yet all we're
doing is preparing the data so we're
going to prepare a training set and the
test set so any changes we make to the
training set at this point also have to
be made to the test set so we've done
this thing we've done a train data
generator we've done our training set
and then we also have remember our test
set of data so I'm going to do the same
thing with that I'm going to create a
test data gen and we're going to do this
image data generator we're going to
rescale one over 255 we don't need the
other settings just the single setting
for the test data gen and we're going to
create our test set we're going to do
the same thing we did with the test set
except that we're pulling it from the
test set folder and we'll run that and
you'll see in our test set we found
2,000 images that's about right we're
using 20% of the images as test and 80%
to train it and then finally we've set
up all our data we've set up all our
layers which is where all the work is is
cleaning up that data making sure it's
going in there correctly and we're
actually going to fit it we're going to
train our data set and let's see what
that looks like and here we go let's put
the information in here and let's just
take a quick look at what we're looking
at with our fit generator we have our
classifier do fit generator that's our
back propagation so the information goes
through forward with a picture and it
says oh you're either right or you're
wrong and then the aor goes backward and
reprograms all those weights so we're
training our neural network and of
course we're using the training set
remember we created the training set up
here and then we're going steps per epic
so it's 8,000 steps epic means that
that's how many times we go through all
the pictures so we're going to rerun
each of the pictures and we're going to
go through the whole data set 25 times
but we're going to look at each picture
during each epic 8,000 times so we're
really programming the heck out of this
and going back over it and then they
have validation data equals test set so
we have our um training set and then
we're going to have our test set to
validate it so we're going to do this
all in one shot and we're going to look
at that and they're going to do 200
steps for each validation and we'll see
what that looks like in just a minute
let's go ahead and run our training here
and we're going to fit our data and as
it goes it says epic one of 25 you start
realizing that this is going to take a
while on my my older computer it takes
about 45 minutes I have a dual processor
you we're processing uh 10,000 photos
that's not a small amount of photographs
to process so if you're on your laptop
you which I am it's going to take a
while so let's go ahead and uh go get
her cup of coffee and a sip and come
back and see what this looks like so I'm
back he didn't know I was gone I was
actually a lengthy pause there I made a
couple changes and let's discuss those
changes real quick and why I made them
so the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to go up here and insert a
cell above and let's paste the original
code back in there and you'll see that
the original thing was steps per epic
8,000 25 epics and validation steps
2,000 and I changed these to 4,000 epics
or 4,000 steps per epic 10 epics and
just 10 validation steps and this will
cause problems if you're doing this as a
commercial release but for demo purposes
this should work and if you remember our
steps per epic that's how many f photos
we're going to process in fact let me go
ahead and get my drawing pen out and uh
let's just highlight that right here
well we have 8,000 pictures we're going
through so for each epic I'm going to
change this to 4,000 I'm going to cut
that in half so it's going to randomly
pick 4,000 pictures each time it goes
through an epic and the Epic is how many
processes so this is 25 and I'm just
going to cut that to 10 so instead of
doing 25 runs through 8,000 photos each
which you can do the math of 25 * 8,000
I'm only going to do 10 through 4,000 so
I'm going to run this 40,000 times
through the processes and the next thing
I not you'll you'll want to notice is
that I also changed the validation step
and this would cause some major problems
in releasing because I dropped it all
the way down to 10 what the validation
step does is it says we have 2,000
photos in our training or in our testing
set and we're going to use that for
validation well I'm only going to use a
random 10 of those to validate so not
really the best settings but let me show
you why we did that let's scroll down
here just a little bit and let's look at
the output here and see what that what's
going on there so I've got my drawing
tool back on and you'll see here it
lists a run so each time it goes through
an epic it's going to do 4,000 steps and
this is where the 4,000 comes in so
that's where we have we have epic one of
10 4,000 steps it's randomly picking
half the pictures in the file and going
through them and then we're going to
look at this number right here that is
for the whole epic and that's
2,411 seconds and if you remember
correctly you divide that by 60 you get
minutes if you divide that by 60 you get
hours or you can just divide the whole
thing by 60 * 60 which is 3600 if 3600
is an hour this is roughly 45 minutes
right here and that's 45 minutes to
process half the pictures so if I was
doing all the pictures we're talking an
hour and a half per epic times 36 or no
25 they had 25 up above 25 so that's
roughly a couple days a couple days of
processing well for this demo we don't
want to do that that I don't want to
come back the next day plus my computer
did a reboot in the middle of the night
so we look at this and we say okay let's
we're just testing this out my computer
that I'm running this on is a dual core
processor uh runs 0.9 GHz per second for
a laptop you know it's good about four
years ago but for running something like
this it's probably a little slow so we
cut the times down and the last one was
validation we're only validating it on a
random 10 photos and this comes into
effect because you're going to see down
here where we have accuracy
value loss value accuracy and loss those
are very important numbers to look at so
the 10 means I'm only validating across
10 pictures that is where here we have
value this is ACC is for accuracy value
loss we're not going to worry about that
too much and accuracy now accuracy is
while it's running it's putting these
two numbers together that's what
accuracy is and value accuracy is at the
end of the Epic what's our accuracy end
of the Epic what is it looking at in
this tutorial we're not going to go so
deep but these numbers are really
important when you start talking about
these two numbers reflect bias that is
really important we just put that up
there and bias is a little bit beyond
this tutorial but the short of it is is
if this accuracy which is being our
validation per step is going down and
the value accuracy continues to go up
that means there's a bias that means I'm
memorizing the photos I'm looking at I'm
not actually looking for what makes a
dog a dog what makes a cat a cat I'm
just memorizing them and so the more
this discrepancy grows the bigger the
bias is and that is really the beauty of
the carass neural network it is a lot of
built-in features like this that make
that really easy to track so let's go
ahead and take a look at the next set of
code so here we are into part three
we're going to make a new prediction and
so we're going to bring in a couple
tools for that and then we have to
process the image coming in and find out
whether it's an actual dog or cat if we
can actually use this to identify it and
of course the final step of part three
is to print prediction we'll go ahead
and combine these and of course you can
see me there adding a more sticky notes
to my computer screen hidden behind the
screen and you know last one was don't
forget to feed the cat and the
dog so let's go a and take a look at
that and see what that looks like in
code and put that in our Jupiter
notebook all right and let's paste that
in here and we'll start by importing
numpy as NP numpy is a very common
package I pretty much import it on any
python project I'm working on another
one I use regularly is pandas they're
just ways of organizing the data and
then NP is usually the standard in most
machine learning tools as the return for
the data array although you know you can
use the standard data array from Python
and we have cross pre-pressing import
image this that all look familiar
because we're going to take a test image
and we're going to set that equal to in
this case cat or dog one as you can see
over here and you know what let me get
my drawing tool back on so let's take a
look at this we have our test image
we're loading and in here we have test
image one and this one hasn't data
hasn't seen this one at all so this is
all new oh let me shrink the screen down
let me start that over so here we have
my test image and we went ahead and the
coros processing has this nice image
setup so we're going to load the image
and we're going to alter it to a 64x 64
print so right off the bat we're going
to coros this nice that way it
automatically sets it up for us so we
don't have to redo all our images and
find a way to reset those and then we
use Al to set the image to an array so
again we're all in pre-processing the
data just like we pre-processed before
with our test information and our
training data and then we use the numpy
here's our numpy that's uh from our
right up here import numpy as NP expand
the dimensions test image axes equal
zero so puts it into a single array and
then finally all that work all that
pre-processing and all we do is we run
the result we click on here we go result
equals classifier predict test image and
then we find out well what is the test
image and let's just take a quick look
and just see what that is and you can
see when I ran it it comes up dog and if
we look at those images there it is cat
or dog image number one that looks like
a nice floppy eared lab friendly with
his tongue hanging out it's either that
or a very floppy eared cat I'm not sure
which but according to our software it
says it's a dog and uh we have a second
picture over here let's just see what
happens when we run the second picture
we can go up here and change this uh
from dog image one to two we'll run that
and it comes down here and says cat you
can see me highlighting it down there as
cat so our process works you're able to
label a dog a dog and a cat a cat just
from the pictures there we go cleared my
drawing tool and the last thing I want
you to notice when we come back up here
to when I ran it you'll see it has an
accuracy of one and the value accuracy
of one well the value accuracy is the
important one because the value accuracy
is what it actually runs on the test
data remember I'm only testing it on I'm
only validating it on random 10 photos
and those 10 photos just happen to come
up one now when they ran this on the
server it actually came up about
86% this is why cutting these numbers
down so far for a commercial release is
bad so you want to make sure you're a
little careful of that when you're
testing your stuff that you change these
numbers back when you run it on a more
Enterprise computer other than your old
laptop that you're just practicing on or
messing with and we come down here and
again you know we had the validation of
cat and so we have successfully built a
neural network that could distinguish
between between photos of a cat and a
dog imagine all the other things you
could distinguish imagine all the
different Industries you could dive into
with that just being able to understand
those two difference of pictures what
about mosquitoes could you find the
mosquitoes that bite versus mosquitoes
that are friendly it turns out the
mosquitoes that bite us are only 4% of
the mosquito population if even that
maybe 2% there's all kinds of industries
that use this and there's so many
industries that are just now realizing
how powerful these tools are just in the
photos alone there is a myriad of
Industry sprouting up and I said it
before I'll say it again what an
exciting time to live in with these
tools and that we get to play with so
key takeaways well we covered what is a
neural network we use all kinds of
processing the map images on your phone
we talked about things that a neural
network can do translate text identify
faces all the way to control robots you
know lots of exciting things how does a
neural network work so we discussed that
with the different layers going from the
picture to the um input layer to the
hidden layers and their weights to the
final output layer we also talked about
how it does the math in Computing the
output as uh yes or no categorically
true false we discuss types of
artificial neural networks a lot of
vocabulary there from the feed forward
neural network which is the most
commonly used that's the one the neural
network we used is a feed forward neural
network that does backward propagation
to train and there's a lot of other ones
out there there's the radial biases the
cohenon self-organized ing recurrent
neural network convolution neural
network modular neural network the big
one was modular CU it incorporates
pieces of all the other ones so that
whatever you're working on now is a huge
conglomerate of multiple networks just
all Cutting Edge all of it's new people
even working on it don't even know where
it's going again very exciting times and
finally we dug through my favorite part
you can see with my uh latte on one side
my old school pens and pencil and all my
sticky notes working away that's not
actually me by the way you probably
guessed that and we walked through and
actually did a cat and dog photo a
simple cat and dog photo and you could
see where some of the problems are in
processing large amounts of photographs
and data where that starts to become
going from a single machine on my laptop
with it you know lower amount of
resources all the way to Big Data how if
you're processing hundreds and thousands
of these photos this now needs to be set
up on an Enterprise machine or even on a
cluster of computers again significantly
past the scope of this the neat part
part about it though is once you write
this code most of this code they now
have tools that you can almost take the
same ideas if not the actual code and
push it right onto a cluster computation
so really cool times for this if you
want to become an AI expert and gain
handsome salary packages look at the
wide range of e IML courses by simply
learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe so what
are you waiting for hurry up and enroll
Now find the cost Link in the
description box welcome to the video on
large language models large language
models are basically very Advanced
artificial intelligence systems that can
process and generate massive amounts of
text Data they are designed to learn
from and understand natural human
language and can be used to perform a
wide range of language related task such
as translation speech recognition and
automatic summary generation one of the
key advantages of large language models
is their ability to learn from vast
amounts of data which allows them to
generate highly accurate and realistic
responses to complex natural language
prompts additionally they can be trained
on multiple languages simultaneously
which means they can be used to perform
language translation between different
pairs of languages making them an
invaluable tool for businesses and
organizations that work with people from
diverse cultural backgrounds not just
language related task but llms can also
have the potential to revolutionize
Fields such as research science and
Healthcare by allowing researchers to
quickly analyze and process vast amounts
of complex text Data they can accelerate
progress in areas such as drug Discovery
Healthcare Diagnostics and AI
development that being said large
language models also present some
challenges for instance they require a
significant amount of compute resources
which can be prohibitively expensive for
some organizations additionally because
they are trained on huge amounts of data
they may inadvertently reinforce biased
or discriminate any patterns in language
use which is something that researchers
and Engineers are continuously working
to address overall large language model
are an exciting and rapidly developing
field with tremendous potential to
transform the way we live work and
communicate so if you want to embark on
a journey of AI and ml then try giving a
short to our postgraduate program in Ai
and ml that is in partnership with IBM
this artificial intelligence course
covers the latest tools and Technologies
from the AI ecosystem and features
master classes by celtech faculty and
IBM experts hecaton and ask me anything
sessions this program showcases celtech
ctm's excellence and IBM's industry
progress the artificial intelligence
course covers key Concepts like
statistics data science with python
machine learning deep learning NLP and
reinforcement learning through an
Interactive Learning model with live
sessions enroll now and unlog exciting
AI ml opportunities the link is
mentioned in the description box below
and with that having said hey everyone
welcome to Simply Lars YouTube channel
but before we dive into that don't
forget to like subscribe and share in
this video we will cover topics like
what are large language models after
that we'll look at what large language
models used for and after that we'll
cover how are large language models
trained after this we'll look at how do
large language models work and at the
last we'll see some applications of
large language models so without any
further Ado let's get
started so we'll start with what are the
large language models large language
models such as gpt3 generative
pre-trained Transformer 3 Advanced
artificial intelligent systems designed
to understand and generate humanlike
text these models are built using deep
learning techniques and have been
trained on vast amounts of text Data
from the internet these models use self
attention mechanisms to analyze the
relationships between words or tokens in
a text enabling them to capture
contextual information and generate Cent
responses these models use self
attention mechanisms to analyze the
relationship between different words or
tokens in the text text enabling them to
capture contextual information and
generate cerent responses these models
have significant implications for a wide
range of applications including virtual
assistants chat boards content
generation language translation and
aiding in research and decision-making
processes their ability to generate
cerent and contextually appropriate text
has led to advancement in natural
language understanding and human
computer interaction now we'll see what
are language models used for so large
language models are utilized in
scenarios where there is limited or no
domain specific data available for
training these scenarios include both
few short and zero short learning
approaches which rely on the models
strong inductive bias and its capability
to derive meaningful representations
from a small amount of data or even no
data at all now we'll see how are large
language models trained large language
models typically undergo pre-training on
a broad all and compassing data set that
shares statistical similarities with the
data set specific to the Target task the
objective of pre-training is to enable
the model to acquire high level features
that can later be applied during the
fine-tuning phase for specific task and
the training process of a large language
model involves several steps the first
is text pre-processing the textual data
is transformed into a numerical
representation that can be effectively
processed by the model this conversion
may involve techniques like token
ization and coding and creating input
sequences the next we have is random
parameter initialization the model's
parameters are initialized randomly
before the training process begins the
next is inputting numerical data the
numerical representation of Text data is
fed into the model for processing the
models architecture typically based on
Transformers allows it to capture the
contextual relationships between the
words and tokens in the text and the
next is low function fun calculation a
loss function is employed to measure the
discrepancy between the model's
predictions and the actual next word or
token in a sentence the model aims to
minimize this loss during training and
the next is parameter optimization the
model's parameters are adjusted through
optimization techniques such as gradient
descent to reduce the loss this involves
calculating gradients and updating the
parameters accordingly gradually
improving the model's performance and
the next is iterative training the
training process is repeated over
multiple iterations or repops until the
models outputs achieve a satisfactory
level of accuracy on the given task or
data set by following this training
process large language models learn to
capture linguistic patterns understand
context and generate coherent responses
enabling them to excel at a wide range
of language related tasks and now we'll
see how do large language models work so
large language models leverage deep
neural networks to generate outputs
based on patterns learned from the
training data typically a large language
model adopts a Transformer architecture
which enables the model to identify
relationships between words in a
sentence irrespective of the position in
the sequence in contrast to recent
neural networks that is RNN that rely on
recurence to capture token relationships
Transformer neural networks employees
self attention as their primary
mechanism self attention calculates
attention scores that determines the
importance of each token with respect to
other tokens in the text sequence
facilitating the modeling of intricate
relationships within the data now we'll
see applications of large language
models large language models have wide
range of applications across various
domains and here are some notable
applications the first one is natural
language processing large language
models are used to improve natural
language understanding task such as
sentiment analysis named entity
recognition text classification and
language modeling the next is chat
boards and virtual assistants large
language models power conversational
agents chat boards and virtual
assistants providing more interactive
and humanlike interactions with users
and the next is machine translation
large language models have been used for
automatic language translation enabling
the translation of text between
different languages with improved
accuracy and the next we have is
sentiment analysis large language models
can analyze and classify the sentiment
or emotion expressed in a piece of text
which is valuable for market research
brand monitoring and social media
analysis and the next we have is content
recommendation these models can be
employed to provide personalized content
recommendations enhancing user
experience and engagement on platform
such as news websites or streaming
services these applications highlight
the versatility and potential impact of
large language models in various domains
improving language understanding
Automation and interaction between
humans and computer
everyone knows the algorithm is a
step-by-step process to approach a
particular problem there are numerous
examples of algorithm from figuring out
sets of number to finding Roots through
maps to showing data on a screen let's
understand this by using an
example every algorithm is built on
inputs and outputs Google search
algorithm is no different the input is
the search field and the output is the
page of result that appears when you
enter a particular phrase or keyword
also known as sep or search engine
result page Google has a search
algorithm so it can sort results from
various website and provides the users
the best result when you start a search
you will see the search box you'll
attempt to guess what you are looking
for in order to better understand what
the user is looking for the algorithm is
trying to gather as many as suggestions
from them as possible the results from
the search field that best matches the
query will be ranked the choose F
website will Rank and in what position
using more than 200 ranking variables
now let's take an example of coding
program and see how the algorithm
works here we will use a case of
computer program wherein we want to
print the multiplication table of any
number let's take two the algorithm
start here and then it assign a value to
a variable the variable I is having an
initial value of one
the system will read the number the
number in case is two now the system has
a condition a condition can now either
be true or false if the value of I
reaches 11 then the loop will end
otherwise value of I will multiply by
the number the initial value of I is 1
so for the first time the system output
will be two now value of I will be
increased by one according to the loop
condition resistance will then move back
and check for the condition again the
new value of I is 2 which is still less
than 11 the system will again print 2
into I which is 2 into 2 on the screen
the new output result will be four the
system will keep following the same
procedure repeatedly until the value of
I becomes 11 once the value of I becomes
11 then only the algorithm will
terminate after discussing how an
algorithm work let's move forward and
see some popular machine learning
algorithms some popular machine learning
algorithms are first one is linear
regression algorithm second one is
logistic regression algorithm and the
third one is decision tree and the
fourth one is support Vector machine
algorithm
svm and the fifth one is KNN K nearest
neighbor algorithms and the sixth one is
K means clustering algorithms and the
seventh one is random Forest algorithms
and the last but not the least algorithm
is AI algorithms let's go through them
in detail one by
one linear regression is one of the most
famous and straightforward machine
learning algorithms utilized for
predictive analysis linear regression
show the linear connection between the
dependent and the independent factors
the equation of line is y = to mx + b
here y stand for for the response
variable or a dependent variable whereas
X is for the Predator variable or an
independent variable it attempts best to
fit line between the dependent and
independent variables and this best fit
line is known as line of regression or
regression
line let's take a real application
example in predicting consumer Behavior
businesses use linear regression to
forecast things like how much a client
is likely to spend things like targeted
marketing and product development May
benefit from this Walmart for instant
use linear regression to forecast which
good would be in high demand Across the
Nation moving forward let's see types of
linear
regression there are two types of linear
regression algorithm the first one is
simple linear regression and the second
one is multiple linear
regression in simple linear regression
if an independent variable is utilized
to forecast the worth of a mathematical
dependent variable then at that point
such a linear regression algorithm is
called Simple linear regression the
equation of line will be y = a 0 + A1 X
and the second one is multiple linear
regression if the dependent variables
declines on the Y and the independent
variable on the X then such a
relationship is known as negative linear
relationship the line of equation will
be minus of a0 + A1
X moving forward let's see logistic
linear
regression logistic regression is the
supervised machine learning algorithm
utilized to anticipate all the
categorical factors or discrete values
it could be very well used for the
grouping issues in machine learning and
the result of the logistic regression
can be either yes or no zero or one men
or wom and so on it gives the values
which lies between zero and one for
example a credit card business is
interested in knowing whether the
transaction amount and the credit scope
have an impact on the probability that a
particular transaction would be
fraudulent the business can use logistic
regression to determine how these two
Predator values can relate the
probability that a transaction is
fraudin the response variable in the
model has two possible outcomes first
one is the transaction is fraud and the
second one is the transaction is not
fraud in logistic regression rather than
fitting a regression line we fit an S
form logistic capability which predicts
two greatest value Z or one the logistic
regression equation can be calculated
from linear regression equation the
steps to get logistic regression
equations are the equation of a straight
line can be return as y = b 0 + B1 X1 +
B2 X2 till B and xn in logistic
regression y can be between 0 and 1 only
so for that let's divide the above
equation by 1 - y then the equation will
be y upon 1 - y that is 0 for y0 and
Infinity for y = 1 but range between
minus infinity to plus infinity then we
have to take the logarithm of equation
and now it will become
log of Y upon 1 - y = b 0 + B1 X1 + B2
X2 so on till B and xn let's move
forward and see types of logistic
regression there are three types of
logistic regression that can be
classified first one is binomial in
binomial logistic regression there can
be only two possible types of dependent
variables like yes or no pass or fail
man woman and many more
and the second one is multinomial in
multinomial logistic regression there
can be three or more possible unordered
ways of dependent variable such as horse
cow and sheep and the last one is
ordinal in ordinal logistic regression
there can be three or more possible
ordered ways of dependent variable such
as small medium or large moving forward
let's see decision trees in
detail a decision tree is a tree
structured classifier that could be used
for classification and regression a
decision tree is a tree in which each
non-leaf node is assigned to an
attribute additionally each are contain
one of the available values for its
parent node which is associated with
each Leaf node that is the node from
where the arc is directed let's see some
decision tree
terminology first one is root that
contains the entire data set the next
one is node attach for the data of a
certain attribute and the third one is
branch which connect the node to
internal node or the internal node to
Leaf node and the fourth one is leaf
node the terminal node that predicts the
outcome let's move forward and see
decision tree algorithms the first one
is select the best attribute to use the
current node in the tree the second one
is for each possible values select the
attributes the third one is partition
the example using the possible values of
this attribute and assign these disjoint
subset of the examples to the
appropriate child node the cursively
generate each child node until ideally
all examples for a node have the same
label like class moving forward let's
understand the decision tree for
building a decision tree step one is
Select an attribute then split the data
into its children in a tree continue
splitting with available attributes
and keep splitting until Leaf node are
pure like only one class remains a
maximum depth is reached a performance
metric is achieved let's move forward
and see svm algorithm support Vector
machine
algorithms a support Vector machine is a
well-known supervised machine learning
model it is utilized for both
information classification and
regression it is regularly utilized for
the grouping issues we can involve it in
different Life Care system and we can
involve it in typically happy or sad
look Arrangements we can involve it in
filters if we make specific looks it
would add the particular filter
according to the expression the scope of
articulation lies between happy and sad
support Vector machine helps him to
recognize hand return return characters
use yd like checks continue to be a
significant part of the majority of
non-cash transaction and are frequently
written by the pup
the current check processing system in
many developing nations involves a bank
employer to read and manually enter the
information in a check while also
verifying the data like signature and
date a handwritten text recognition
system can reduce expenses and labor
hours because a bank must handle several
checks each day moving forward let's see
the algorithm of
svm the object itive of support Vector
machine is to make the best line or
Choice limit that can isolate n
dimensional space into classes so we can
undoubtly put the new data of interest
in the right category later on this best
decision boundary is known as a
hyperplan let's move forward and see
types of support Vector machine support
Vector machine can be of two types first
one is linear SPM second one is
nonlinear sbm let's move forward and see
linear SPM linear sum is utilized for
linearly detachable information which
implies if a data set can be ordered
into two classes by utilizing a straight
line then such information are named
linearly separable information and a
classifier is utilized called linear sbm
classifier moving forward let's see
nonlinear
sbm nonlinear sbm is utiliz for
non-directly isolated information and
that implies in the event that a data
set can't can't be categorized by
utilizing a straight line such
information is named non-directed
information and the classifier utilize
is called a nonlinear svm classifier
moving forward let's see KNN algorithm
in
detail KNN is a supervised learning
technique KNN classifies new data into
our targeted classes depending on the
features of its neighboring points and
also be used for the regression problems
it is an instance based learning
algorithm and a bit lazy learning
algorithm Cann calculation stores every
one of its accessible information and
orders another information Point based
on the likeliness this means that when
new data information appears it usually
tends to be successfully categorized
into a good suit classes using the Canon
algorithm let's imagine we have an image
of animal that resembles a cow or Ox
however here we are not sure if it is a
cow or Ops SN method is based on a Lous
Matrix it will identify the properties
of new data that are related to the
image of cow or ox and based on those
quality it will classify the data is
belonging to either cow or o group
moving forward let's see how does qnn
work the steps to implement Cann
algorithms are step one decide on the
neighbor scale numbers step two
calculate the ukan distance between K
Neighbors in step two third one is based
on the determined ukan distance select
the K closest neighbors step four is
count the numbers of data points in each
category between these SK neighbors step
five assign the fresh data points in the
category where the highest neighbors
count and then KNN model is ready let's
say we need to add a new data point to
the vital category at first we will
decide on the number of neighbors
therefore we will pick K = to
5 then the ukan distance between the
data points and then can be determined
the distance between two points known as
the uclean distance can be determined by
under root of X2 - X1 whole square + Y2
- y1 Square then we determine the
closest neighbors by calculating the
ukine distance there are three closest
Neighbors in category a and two closest
neighbor in category B this new data
point Must Fall with category a because
as we can see it three closest neighbors
are also from group a after
understanding Cann algorithm let's move
forward and see K means algorithms in
detail the K means is a cluster false
under that is an unsupervised learning
algorithm it is used to address machine
learning clustering problems and utilize
to tackle the grouping issues in machine
learning it permits us to Bunch the
information into various Gatherings it
is a helpful method for finding the
classification of groups in the
unlabeled data set without the
requirement of any training this K means
algorithm groups the data into similar
classes let's see some application of K
means clustering let's see some
applications of K means clustering
diagnostic system the medical profession
uses K means cling in creating smarter
medical decision support system
especially in the treatment of lever
align ments the second one is search
engines clustering forms a backbone of
search engine when a search engine is
performed the search result need to be
grouped and the search engines very
often use clustering to do this moving
forward let's see how K means algorithm
works the steps to implement K means
algorithms are step one select the
number K to set the number of clusters
step two select a random K points or
centroid step three three assign each
data point the closest centroid data
forms to predefined K cluster step four
determine the variance and a set a new
Gravity points for each cluster step
five repeat the third step this means
reallocating each data point to the new
closest centroid cluster step six if a
reassignment occurs go to step four
otherwise go to exit step seven the
model is ready to use so now we have an
clear understanding of how K means
algorithm work let's move forward to see
the graphical representation of K means
algorithm consider that there are two
variables M1 and M2 this is a scatter
plot of these two variables along the X
and Y AIS we should accept the number of
K of bunches that is K = to 2 to
recognize the data set and to place them
into various groups it implies here we
will attempt to Bunch these data set
into two unique groups we will really
want to pick an irregular keyo or
centroid to frame this group these
centroids can be either the focus of the
data set or some of other points thus
here we are choosing under two points as
SK points which are not the piece of our
data set we will assign every data of
interest in the scatter plot to the
nearest K or centroid we will register
it by applying some math that we
consider to find the distance between
two points that is ukan distance thus we
will draw a median between both the
centroids from the graph the left half
of the line are Clos points to the right
and the K1 centroid green is near the
orange centroid we should variety them
as green and orange for Clear
representation as the need might arise
to track down the nearest group we will
repeat the cycle by picking another
centroid to pick the new centroid we
will figure out the center point of
gravity of these centroids and we'll
track down new centroids then we will
reassign every piece of of information
to highlight new croid for this we will
repeat a similar course of tracking down
a middle line the middle will be like as
seen in the picture one orange point is
on the left half of the line and two
green points are on the right thus these
three points will be appointed to the
new centroids as reassignment has
occurred we will again go to step four
tracking down new centroids or k points
we will repeat the cycle by tracking
down the center point of gravity of
centroids so the new centroids will be
displayed as like this we now have new
centroids so once more Define the middle
boundary and reassign the data of
Interest by this graph there are no
unique pieces of information on one of
the other side of the line implying our
model is shaped by the previous graph
there are no unique pieces of
information on one or the other line
implying our model is shaped as our K
means model is is ready and the two last
groups will be displayed as like these
now we have an clear understanding of
how K means clustering algorithm works
now let's move forward to understand
random Forest
algorithm random Forest is an adaptable
simple to utilize machine learning
algorithm that produces even without the
hyper boundary tuning an extraordinary
outcome more often than not it is
likewise quite possibly the most
utilized algorithm because because of
its effort and variety like it tend to
be utilized for both grouping and
classification task random Forest is a
classifier that contains various Choice
trees on different subsets of the given
data set and takes the normal to work on
the present exactness of the data set
instead of depending on the choice tree
the random Forest takes the forecast
from each tree and in light of the
larger part of vs of expectation it
predicts the final result now now let's
move forward and see how does random
Forest
work we should see the random forest in
order since the arrangement is now and
again thought to be the structured block
of machine learning this is what a
random Forest would look like with two
trees the random Forest has a similar
hypermeter to decision tree or a badging
classifier luckily there is a compelling
reason need to consolidate a decision
tree with a badging classifier since you
can undoubtly utilize the classifier
classes of random forest with random
Forest you can likewise manage task
using the algorithm regression random
Forest add extra aridness to the model
while deing the trees rather than
looking for the man element while
parting a node it looks to the best
component among an irregular subset of
highlights these outcomes in a wide
variety often result in a superior model
subsequently in a a random Forest just a
random subset of the element is thought
about the algorithms you might make
trees more random by involving random
edges for each component instead of
looking for the most ideal limits like a
typical Choice tree does let's move
forward and see some application of
random Forest
algorithms random Forest is involved at
work by researchers in numerous Ventures
including banking stock exchanging
medication and many more it is utilized
to predict things which assist these
businesses with running productively
like client activity patient history and
safety in banking random Forest is used
to identify clients who are more likely
to pay back their debts on schedule
additionally it is utilized to forecast
who will make more frequent use of Bank
Services even fraud detection uses it
the Robin Hood of algorithms indeed
random Forest is a tool used by stock
traders to forecast future stock
Behavior retail businesses utilize it to
make product recommendation and forecast
client satisfaction random Forest can be
used in healthcare industry to examine a
patient medical history and detect
disorders random Forest is a tool used
by pharmaceutical expert to determine
the ideal mix of ingredients in
treatment or to forecast drug
sensitivity by seeing application of
random Forest algorithm let's move
forward and see some difference between
decision trees and random
Forest let's see the difference between
random forest and decision tree the
first one is while building a random
Forest the number of rows is selected
randomly in decision trees it builds
several decision trees and find out the
output the second one is it combines two
or more decision trees together in
decision trees whereas the decision is a
collection of variables or data sets or
attributes the third one is it gives
accurate results whereas it gives less
accurate results the fourth one is by
using random Forest it reduces the
chance of overl whereas decision trees
it has the possibility of overl the
fifth one is random Forest is more
complicated to interpreters whereas the
decision tree is simple it is easy to
read and understand after seeing what is
zom Forest how it works let's move
forward to see a prior gorithms in
detail the aary algorithm utiliz
standard item sets to create affiliation
rules and is intended to chip away the
information basis containing exchanges
with the assistance of these affiliation
rules it decide how firmly or feebly two
objects are associated this algorithm
utiliz a breath first search and history
to work out the item set Association
effectively it is the iterative
interaction for for finding out the
successive item set from the huge data
set let's move forward and see steps for
a prior algorithms the steps for a PRI
algorithms are Step One is establish
minimal support and confidence for item
set in the transactional database the
second one is take all transaction
supports with a greater support value
the minimum or choosen support value in
step two the third one is track down all
the rules in these subsets with
confidence Ence value greater than the
threshold value the fourth one is
arrange the rules to lower the lift at
last we will see some advantages and
disadvantages of AI algorithm the
advantages of AI algorithms are easy to
understand an algorithm and the second
one is the join and prun steps of the
algorithms can be easily implemented on
the large data set the disadvantages of
AI algorithms are the AI algorithms work
slowly as compared to the other
algorithm and the second one is the PRI
algorithms times and space complexity
are o of 2D which is very low compared
to the other ones let's move forward and
see some Hands-On lab
demo so we will see a Hands-On lab demo
on linear regression as we know linear
regression is a way to find or to
predict the relationship between two
variables generally we use X and Y so
first we will open command promt to
write command to open jupyter notebook
so we will here write
Jupiter notebook and then press
enter so this is the landing page of
jupyter notebook and select open new
python
file so this is how jupyter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in mathematical functioning
so the first one is
numai napai is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has
functions for working in domains like
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numai stand for numerical python
so we will write like
import numpy as NP here NP is used for
denoting nire so we will import the next
libraries pandas pandas is a software
Library return for Python programming
for like data manipulation and Analysis
in particular it offers data structures
and operation for manipulating numerical
labels and time series so we will write
import
pandas as PD here PD is used for
denoting pandas so our next library is M
plot lip M plot Li is a graph plotting
library in Python that serves as a
visualization utility
M BL Li is a open source so we can use
it freely and it is most return in
Python a few segments in C and
JavaScript for platform
compatibility for importing M plot Li
you have to write import M plot
Li lip do
pelot s PL so after importing the
libraries we will move ahead and import
data set so for importing data set we
have to write data
set equals to PD do read uncore CSV and
here we have to give the path of the
file data
set do
CSV here PD is for Panda's library and
read is used for reading the data set
from the machine and CSV CSV is used for
the type of file which you want to read
so after reading let's see our data so
we will write data
set dot
head and press enter here head is used
for retrieving the first five lines from
the data so our data is coming properly
so moving ahead now let's first Define X
and Y axis for X we have to write xals
to data set do
iog braet col comma colon again minus
one dot values for x-axis and for y axis
we have to write yals to data
set do
iog bracket column comma
1 dot
values so if we will use data set. iog
for minus one values for x-axis it will
select till the second last column of
the data frame instead of the last
column and I know this is as the second
last column value and the last column
value for the row is different whereas
if you will use for the y axis values
return a series Vector a vector does not
have a column size so moving ahead let's
see the value for x and y axis first we
will see the value for x like just you
have to write X and press enter
so these are the arrays value for x and
for y axis you have to type Y and then
enter so these are arrays value for y
AIS so after this now let's split the
data set into training and testing
separating data into training and
testing set is an important part for
evaluating data mining models typically
when you separate a data set into a
training set and a testing set most of
the data set is used for training and a
similar portion of data set is used for
testing so we will split it into 70 and
30 ratio so for splitting we need to
import some more libraries for this
process so we will write from
skarn do model underscore
selection
import
train underscore test underscore
split psyched learn like SK learn is
most useful and robust library for
machine learning in Python it provides a
selection of efficient tools for machine
learning and statical modeling including
classification regression and clustering
so after importing let's write code for
the splitting data so we will write
here
xcore
train comma xcore test comma Yore
train comma
Yore
test equals
to
p underscore test underscore split in
Brackets we have to write X comma
y comma
testore
size equals to
0.3
comma
random _
State equals
to0
random ex with random State equals to
zero we get the same train and test sets
across different execution so after this
let's see the values together so we will
write xcore
train comma
xcore
test comma
Yore
train comma
test so these are the values of array X
and array y together moving ahead now
let's work with regression first we need
to import the library for regression so
we will use
from
Escalon do
linear
underscore
model model
import
linear
regression we already discussed skar is
used for machine learning and linear
regression is a major part of machine
learning so after this let's make a
function for regression as R for easy
use so we will write
R equals
to
linear
regression and brackets first we try to
train and then test and compare so we
will write here r
dot
bit braet xcore
train comma
Yore
train now let's predict values but
prediction values are always different
so we will predict values for y first so
we will write y underscore
predict equals to
R do predict
sorry
predict or xcore
test so like
Yore
predict then enter this is when the
predict functions come into the picture
python predict function enables us to
predict the labels of the data values on
the basis of training model the predict
function accept only a single argument
which is xor test here usually the data
to be tested so when you will check the
value for y test you will see the
different values like
y
underscore
test so you can see there are totally
different values from xaxis now let's
display on graph for training data set
so we have to write PLT do
scatter xcore
train comma Yore train
comma
color equals to you can choose by
yourself I will choose
R and then
PLT do
plot xcore
train comma regression point for
predicting
values for
xcore
Traina color equals to
Blue so this color is called the
regression line and the PLT do
title
linear
regression
okay
salary
versus
experience and I will prefer this size
would be uh
180 so let's set the labels for x and y
axis so X
label year of
employee employ comma size will be I
will prefer size will be 50
then for y axis we will
write
here like
salaries
ofy I will prefer this same size
15 let's show the plot by writing PLT do
show
then hopefully we are fortunate
everything is going to be fine perfect
so you can see we have linear regression
line fitting through our data set so
this is how the linear regression work
for training data set let's see how it
will work for testing data
set now let's predict for test data set
you can copy for the same and like you
can change it so we can copy
here so we can can paste here so we have
to just change here train to test data
set test here then
again test
here
then test
here everything everything we will
reduce some
size to 16 let's see then it will 12
and
so perfect so you can see we have linear
regression line fitting through our data
set so this is how the linear regression
works for testing data set if you're
looking for a course that covers
everything from the fundamentals to
Advanced Techniques then accelerate your
career in Ai and machine learning with a
comprehensive post-graduate programming
Ai and machine learning boost your
career with this Ai and ml course
delivered in collaboration with the Peru
University and IBM learn in demand
skills such as machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision
reinforcement learning generative AI
prompt engineering chat GPT and many
more you'll receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with five cap stones in different
domains using real data sets you will
gain practical experience master classes
by PD faculty and I M experts ensure
top-notch education simply learns job
assist help you get noticed by Leading
companies this program covers statistics
python supervised and unsupervised
learning NLP neural networks computer
vision G scas tensor flow and many more
such skills admission to this
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning requires a bachelor's degree
with an average of 50% or higher marks
along with the basic understanding of
programming Concepts and Mathematics and
candidates with two plus years of work
experience are preferred to enroll in
this course so enroll now and unlock
exciting Ai and machine learning
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below let's first
understand what text mining is text
mining is the technique of exploring
large amounts of unstructured Text data
and analyzing it in order to extract
patterns from the text Data it is aided
by software that can identify Concepts
patterns topics keywords and other
attributes in the dat dat it utilizes
computational techniques to extract and
summarize the high quality information
from unstructured textual resources
let's understand the flow of text mining
there are five techniques used in text
mining system information extraction or
text
pre-processing this is used to examine
the unstructured text by searching out
the important words and finding the
relationships between them
categorization or text text
transformation attribute generation
categorization technique labels the text
document under one or more categories
classification of Text data is done
based on input output examples with
categorization clustering or attribute
selection clustering method is used to
group text documents that have similar
content clusters are the partitions and
each cluster will have a number of
documents with similar content clust
string makes sure that no document will
be omitted from the search and it
derives all the documents that have
similar content visualization technique
the process of finding relevant
information is simplified by
visualization technique this technique
uses text Flags to represent a group of
documents or a single document and
compactness is indicated using colors
visualization technique helps to display
textual information in a more attractive
way
summarization or interpretation or
evaluation summarization technique will
help to reduce the length of the
document and summarize the details of
the documents it makes the document easy
to read for users and understand the
content at the moment let's understand
the significance of text
mining document clustering document
clustering is an important part of text
mining it has many applications in
Knowledge Management and information
retrieval clustering makes it easy to
group similar documents into meaningful
groups such as in newspapers where
sections are often grouped as business
Sports politics and so on pattern
identification text mining is the
process of automatically searching large
amount of text for text patterns and
recognition of features features such as
telephone numbers and email addresses
can be extracted using pattern matches
product insights text mining help helps
to extract large amounts of text for
example customer reviews about the
products mining consumer reviews can
reveal insights like most loved feature
most hated feature improvements required
and reviews of competitor's products
security monitoring text mining helps in
monitoring and extracting information
from news articles and reports for
national security purposes text mining
makes sure to use all of your available
information it is a more effective and
productive knowledge discovery that
allows you to make better informed
decisions automate information intensive
processes gather business critical
insights and mitigate operational
risk let's look at the applications of
text
mining speech recognition speech
recognition is the recognition and
translation of spoken language into text
and vice versa speech often provides
valuable information about the topics
sub objects and concepts of multimedia
content information extraction from
speech is less complicated yet more
accurate and precise than multimedia
content this fact motivates
content-based speech analysis for
multimedia Data Mining and retrieval
where audio and speech processing is a
key enabling
technology spam filtering spam detection
is an important method in which textual
information contained in an email is
extracted and used for
discrimination text mining is useful in
automatic detection of spam emails based
on the filtering content using text
mining an email service provider such as
Gmail or Yahoo mail checks the content
of an email and if some malicious text
is found in the mail then that email is
marked as spam and sent to the spam
folder sentiment analysis it is done in
order to determine if a given sentence
expresses positive neutral or negative
sentiments sentiment analysis is one of
the most popular applications of text
analytics the primary aspect of
sentiment analysis includes data
analysis of the body of the text for
understanding the opinion expressed by
it and other key factors comprising
modality and mood usually the process of
sentiment analysis works best on text
that has a subjective context than on
that with only an objective context
e-commerce
personalization text mining is used to
suggest products that fit into a user's
profile text mining is increasingly
being used by e-commerce retailers to
learn more about the consumers as it is
the process of analyzing textual
information in order to identify
patterns and gain insights e-commerce
retailers can Target specific
individuals or segments with
personalized offers and discounts to
boost sales and increase Customer
Loyalty by identifying customer purchase
patterns and opinions on particular
products let's look at natural language
toolkit library in
detail natural language toolkit is a set
of open-source python models that are
used to apply statistical natural
language processing on human language
data let's see how you can do
environment setup of
nltk go to Windows start and launch pyth
on interpreter from Anaconda prompt and
enter the following commands enter
command python to check the version of
python installed on your system enter
import nltk to link you to the nltk
library available to download then enter
nltk doownload function that will open
the nltk download window check the
download directory select all packages
and click on download this will download
nltk onto your python once you have
downloaded the nltk you must check the
working and functionality of it in order
to test the setup enter the following
command in Python idle from nltk Doc
Corpus imp import Brown brown. word
parenthesis
parenthesis the brown is an nltk Corpus
that shows the systematic difference
between different genres available words
function will give give you the list
available words in the genre the given
output shows that we have successfully
tested the nltk installed on
python let's Now understand how you can
read a specific module from nltk corpora
if you want to import an entire module
from nltk corpora use asterisk symbol
with that module name import command
enter the command from nltk book import
asterisk it will load all the items
available in NLT K's book module now in
order to explore Brown Corpus enter the
command nltk doc Corpus import Brown
this will import Brown Corpus on the
python enter brown. categories function
to load the different genres available
select a genre and assign that genre to
a variable using the following syntax
variable name is equal to brown. words
categories is equal to genre name now in
order to see the available words inside
the selected genre just enter the
defined variable name as a
command let's understand text extraction
and pre-processing in detail so let's
first understand the concept of
tokenization tokenization is the process
of removing sensitive data and placing
unique symbols of identification in that
place in order to to retain all the
essential information concerned with the
data by its security it is a process of
breaking running streams of text into
words and sentences it works by
segregating words using punctuation and
spaces text extraction and
pre-processing
engrams now let's look at what engram is
and how it is helpful in text mining
engram is the simplest model that
assigns these probabilities to se
quences of words or sentences engrams
are combinations of adjacent words or
letters of length and in the source text
so engram is very helpful in text mining
when it is required to extract patterns
from the text as in the given example
this is a sentence all of these words
are considered individual words and thus
represent unigrams a two gr or Byram is
a two-word sequence of words like this
is is a or a sentence and a thre or
trigram is a three-word sequence of
words like this is a or is a
sentence let's Now understand what stop
words are and how you can remove
them stop words are natural language
words that have negligible meanings such
as a n and or the and other similar
words these words also will take up
space in the database or increase the
processing time so it is better to
remove such words by storing a list of
stop words you can find the list of stop
words in the nltk data directory that is
stored in 16 different languages use the
following command to list the stop words
of English language defined in nltk
Corpus importing nltk will import the
nltk Corpus for that instance enter from
nltk Doc Corpus import stop wordss will
import Stop wordss from nltk Corpus Now
set the language as English so use set
function as set under braces stopwords
do wordss set genre as English stop
wordss are filtered out before
processing of natural language data as
they don't reveal much information so as
you can see in the given example before
filtering the sentence the tokenization
of stop word is processed in order to
remove these stop words
and the filtering is applied in order to
filter the sentence based on some
criteria text extraction and
pre-processing
stemming stemming is used to reduce a
word to stem or base word by removing
suffixes such as helps helping helped
and helper to the root word help the
stemming process or algorithm is
generally called a stemmer there are
various stemming algorithms such as
Porter stemmer l Caster stemmer snowball
stemmer Etc use any of the stemmers
defined under nltk stem Corpus in order
to perform stemming as shown in the
example here we have used Porter stemmer
When You observe the output you will see
that all of the words given have been
reduced to their root word or
stem text extraction and pre-processing
lemmatization lemmatization is the
method of grouping the various inflected
types of a word in order that they can
be analyzed as one item it uses
vocabulary list or morphological
analysis to get the root word it uses
word net database that has English words
linked together by their semantic
relationship as you can observe the
given example the different words have
been extracted to their relevant
morphological word using
lization text extraction and
pre-processing POS tagging
let's now look at different part of
speech tags available in the national
language toolkit Library a POS tag as a
special label assigned to each token or
word in a Text corpus to indicate the
part of speech and often also other
grammatical categories such as tense
number either plural or singular case
Etc POS tags are used in text analysis
tools and algorithms and also Inc Corpus
searches so look at the given example Le
here Alice wrote a program is the source
text given the POS tags given are Alice
is a noun wrote is a verb a is an
article and program is an adjective look
at the given example to understand how
posos tags are defined so the given
sentence or paragraph contains different
words that represent different parts of
speech we will first use tokenization
and removal of stop wordss and then
allocate the different POS tags these
these are shown with different words in
the given sentence POS tags are useful
for lemmatization in building named
entity recognition and extracting
relationships between
words text extraction and pre-processing
named entity recognition now let's
understand what named entity recognition
is all about Neer seeks to extract a
real world entity from the text and
sorts it into predefined categories such
as names of people organizations
locations Etc many real world questions
can be answered with the help of name
entity recognition were specified
products mentioned in complaints or
reviews does the Tweet contain the name
of a person does the Tweet contain the
person's address as you can see in the
given example Google America Larry paage
Etc are the names of a person place or
an organization so these are considered
named entities and have different tags
such as person organization gpe or
geopolitical entity
Etc NLP process
workflow now you have an understanding
of all nltk tools so now let's
understand the natural language
processing workflow step one
tokenization it splits text into pieces
tokens or words and removes punctuation
step two stop word removal it moves
commonly used words such as the is R Etc
which are not relevant to the analysis
step three stemming and litiz it reduces
words to base form in order to be
analyzed as a single item step four POS
tagging it tags words to be part of
speech such as noun verb adjective Etc
based on the definition and context step
five information retrieval it extracts
relevant information from The
Source M1 Brown Corpus problem statement
the Brown University standard Corpus of
present-day American English also known
popularly as brown Corpus was compiled
in the 1960s as a general Corpus in the
field of Corpus Linguistics it contains
500 samples of English language text
totaling roughly 1 million words
compiled from Works published in the
United States in
1961 we will be working on one of the
subset data set and perform text
processing tasks let us import the nltk
library and read the
ca10 Corpus import
nltk we will have to make sure that
there are no slashes in between hence we
will use the replace function within
pandas for the
same
let's have a look at the data
once
tokenization after performing sentence
tokenization on the data we
obtain
similarly after applying sentence
tokenizer the resulting output shows all
individual words
tokens stop word removal let's import
the stop word library from nltk do
Corpus import Stop
words we also need to ensure that the
text is in the same case nltk has its
own list of stop wordss we can check the
list of stop wordss using stopwords do
wordss and English inside the
parenthesis map the lowercase string
with our list of word
tokens
let's remove the stop words using the
English stop wordss list in
nltk we will be using set checking as it
is faster in Python than a
list by removing all stop words from the
text we
obtain
often we want to remove the punctuations
from the documents too since python
comes with batteries included we have
string. punctuation from string import
punctuation
combining the punctuation with the stop
wordss from
nltk removing stop wordss with
punctuation
stemming and
lemmatization we will be using stemming
and lemmatization to reduce words to
their root form for example walks
walking walked will be reduced to their
root word walk importing Porter stemmer
as the stemming library from nltk do
stem stem import Porter
stemmer printing the stem
words import the word net litier from
nltk do
stem
printing the root
words we also need to evaluate the POS
tags for each
token
create a new word list and store the
list of word tokens against each of the
sentence tokens in data 2 for I and
tokenized also we will check if there
were any stop words in the recently
created word
list
we will now tag the word tokens
accordingly using the POS tags and print
the tagged
output for our final text processing
task we will be applying named entity
recognition to classify named entities
in text into predefined categories such
as the names of persons organizations
locations expressions of times
quantities monetary values percentages
Etc
now press the tagged sentences under the
chunk parser if we set the parameter
binary equals true then named and
entities are just tagged as NE otherwise
the classifier adds category labels such
as person organization and
GP create a function named as extract
entity names along with an empty list
named as entity
names we will now extract named entities
from a nltk chunked expression and store
them in the empty created
above
again we will set the entity names list
as an empty list and will extract The
Entity names by iterating over each tree
in chunked
sentences
great we have seen how to explore and
examine the Corpus using text processing
techniques let's quickly recap the steps
we've covered so far One Import the nltk
library two perform tokenization three
perform stemming and thematization four
remove stop words five perform named
entity
recognition structuring sentences
syntax let's first understand what
syntax is syntax is the grammatical
structure of sentences in the given
example this can be interpreted as
syntax and it is similar to the ones you
use while writing codes knowing a
language includes the power to construct
phrases and sentences out of morphemes
and words the part of the grammar that
represents a speaker's knowledge of
these structures and their formation is
called syntax phrase structure rules are
rules that determine what goes into a
phrase that is constituents of a phrase
and how the constituents are ordered
constituent is a word or group of words
that operate as a unit and can be used
to frame larger grammatical units the
given diagram represents that a noun
phrase is determined when a noun is
combined with a determiner and the
determiner can be optional a sentence is
determined when a noun phrase is
combined with a verb phrase a verb
phrase is determined when a verb is
combined optionally with the noun phrase
and prepositional phrase and a
prepositional phrase is determined when
a preposition is combined with a noun
phrase a tree is a representation of
syntactics structure of formulation of
sentences or strings consider the given
sentence the factory employs 12.8% of
Bradford County what can be the Syntax
for pairing this statement let's
understand this a tree is produced that
might help you understand that the
subject of the sentence is the factory
the predicate is employ and the target
is
12.8% which in turn is modified by
Bradford County syntax parses are often
a first step toward deep information
extraction or semantic understanding of
tech
rendering syntax
trees download the corresponding exe
file to install the ghost script
rendering engine based on your system
configuration in order to render syntax
trees in your notebook let's understand
how you can set up the environment
variable once you have downloaded and
installed the file go to the folder
where it is installed and copy the path
of the file now go to system properties
and under Advanced properties you will
find the environment variable button
click on that to open the popup box tab
of the environment now open the bin
folder and add the path to the bin
folder in your environment variables now
you will have to modify the path of the
environment variable use the given code
to test the working of syntax tree after
the setup is successfully
installed structuring sentences chunking
and chunk
parsing the process of extraction of
phrases from unstructured text is called
chunking instead of using just simple
tokens which may not represent the
actual meaning of the text it is
advisable to use phrases such as Indian
team as a single word instead of Indian
and team as separate words the chunking
segmentation refers to identifying
tokens and labeling refers to
identifying the correct tag these chunks
correspond to mixed patterns in some way
to extract patterns from chunks we need
chunk parsing the chunk parsing segment
refers to identifying strings of tokens
and labeling refers to identifying the
correct chunk type let's look at the
given example you can see here that
yellow is an adjective dog is a noun and
the' is the determiner which are chunk
together into a noun phrase similarly
chunk parsing is used to extract
patterns and to process such patterns
from multiple chunks while using
different
parsers let's take an example and try to
understand how chunking is performed in
Python let's consider the sentence the
little mouse ate the fresh cheese
assigned to a variable named scent using
the word tokenize function under nltk
corpora you can find out the different
tags associated with the sentence
provided so as you can see in the output
different tags have been replicated
against each of the words from the given
sentence using
chunking NP chunk and
parser you will now create grammar from
a noun phrase and will mention the tags
you want in your chunk phrase within the
function here you have created a regular
expression matching the string the given
regular expression indicates optional
determiner followed by optional number
of adjective followed by a noun you will
now have to parse the chunk therefore
you will create a chunk parser and pass
your noun phrase string to it the parser
is now ready you will use the parse
parenthesis parenthesis within your
chunk parser to parse your sentence the
sentence provided is the little mouse at
the fresh cheese this sentence has been
parsed and the tokens that match the
regular expressions are chunked together
into noun phrases n p create a verb
phrase chunk using regular Expressions
the regular expression has been defined
as optional personal pronoun followed by
zero or more verbs with any of its type
followed by any type of adverb you'll
now create another chunk parser and pass
the verb phrase string to it create
another sentence and tokenize it add POS
tags to it so the new sentence is she is
walking quickly to the mall and the POS
tag has been allocated from nltk corpora
now use the new verb phrase parser to
parse the tokens and run the results you
can look at the given tree diagram which
shows a verb parser where a pronoun
followed by two verbs and an adverb are
chunk together into a verb
parse structuring sentences
chinking chinking is the process of
removing a sequence of tokens from a
chunk how does chunking work the whole
chunk is removed when the sequence of
tokens spans an entire chunk if the
sequence is at the start or the end of
the chunk the tokens are removed from
the start and end and a smaller chunk is
retained if the sequence of tokens
appears in the middle of the chunk these
tokens are removed leaving two chunks
where there was only one
before consider you create a chinking
grammar string containing three things
chunk name the regular expression
sequence of a chunk the regular
expression sequence of your here
in the given code we we have the chunk
regular expression as optional personal
pronoun followed by zero or more
occurrences of any type of the verb type
followed by zero or more occurrences of
any of the adverb types the
regular expression says that it needs to
check for the adverb in the extracted
chunk and remove it from the chunk
inside the chinking block with open
curly braces and closing curly braces
you have created one or more adverbs
you will now create a parser from nltk
do
regex parser and pass the grammar
to it now use the new parser to
parse the tokens sent three and run the
results as you can see the parse tree is
generated while comparing the syntax
tree of the parser with that of
the original chunk you can see that the
token is quickly adverb chined out of
the chunk let's understand understand
how to use context free
grammar a context free grammar is a four
Tuple sum ntrs where sum is an alphabet
and each character in sum is called a
terminal NT is a set and each element in
NT is called a non-terminal r the set of
rules is a subset of NT times the set of
sum U NT s the start symbol is one of
the symbols in NT a context-free grammar
generates a language L capturing
constituency and ordering in CFG the
start symbol is used to derive the
string you can derive the string by
repeatedly replacing a non-terminal on
the right hand side of the production
until all non-terminals have been
replaced by terminal symbols let's
understand the representation of context
free grammar through an example in
context free grammar a sentence can be
represented as a noun phrase followed by
a verb phrase noun phrasee can be a
determiner nominal a nominal can be a
noun VP represents the verb phrase a can
be called a determiner flight can be
called a
noun consider the string below where you
have certain rules when you look at the
given context free grammar a sentence
should have a noun phrase followed by a
verb phrase a verb phrase is a verb
followed by a noun a verb can either be
saw or met noun phrases can either be
John or Jim and a noun can either be a
dog or a cat check the possible list of
sentences that can be generated using
the rules use the join function to
create the possible list of sentences
you can check the different rules of
grammar for sentence formation using the
production function it will show you the
different tags used and the defined
context free grammar for the given
sentence demo two structuring sentences
problem statement a company want wants
to perform text analysis for one of its
data sets you are provided with this
data set named tweets. CSV which has
tweets of six US Airlines along with
their sentiments positive negative and
neutral the tweets are present in the
text column and sentiments in Airline
unor sentiment column we will be
retrieving all tags starting with at the
rate in the data set and save the output
in a file called references. XT let us
first import the Panda's library and
read the tweets data
set
extract the features text and Airline
sentiment
we will iterate through the data set
using reg X find the relevant
tweets now we will import the itertools
module it returns efficient
iterators
the result is stored in a file named
references.
txt let's extract all noun phrases and
save them in a file named noun phrases
for left character
Airline sentiment right carat review.
txt
here left carat Airline uncore sentiment
right carot has three different values
positive negative and neutral so three
files will be
created
now we will iterate all the leaf nodes
and assign them to noun phrases
variable
this means that the functions in itter
tools operate on iterators to produce
more complex
iterators
using the map function we will get all
the noun phrases from the
text putting it into list
creating a file name in the name of
review. txt
in a world where email is crucial spam
messages plag our inboxes disrupting our
digital lives but fear note a hero
emerges the email spam classifier this
intelligent system learns from past
encounters uncovering the tricks
employed by spammers deceitful subject
lines promising riches unreasonable low
prices it supports signs like excessive
capital letters misspellings and
suspicious URLs yet the battle doesn't
end here spammers constantly evolve
their tactics but the email spam
classifier doesn't Flinch it adapts
refining its knowledge and staying up to
date with the latest traits every new
spam email it encounters it provides
insights enhancing its accuracy and
ensuring our protection thanks to
Dedicated minds and Ai and ml power the
fight against email spam continues the
email spam classifier stands as a
faithful Guardian a symbol of Technology
victory over digital adversaries it
reclaims our in boxes and restores order
to our virtual world according to recent
studies Ai and machine learning related
job postings have increased by
staggering 344 in the past 5 years
companies across the global actively
seeking professionals who can harness
the power of data and build intelligent
systems the average salary is
$150,000 in the US and 15 lakhs perom in
India accelerate your career in Ai and
machine learning with a comprehensive
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning gain expertise in machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision and reinforcement learning you
will receive a presious certificate
exclusive alumni membership and
hackathons and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with three capstones and 25 plus
industry projects using real data sets
from Twitter Uber and more you will gain
practical experience master classes by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts andure
topnotch education simply Larn job
assist help you notice by Leading
companies live sessions on AI trends
like chat G generative Ai and
explainable AI this program C statistics
python super supervised and unsupervised
learning NLP neural networks computer
vision Gans caras tens of flow and many
more skills enroll now and unlock
exciting Ai and ml opportunities the
link is mentioned in the description box
below let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers you
need to keep updating your skills on a
regular basis no matter what level you
at I recently completed the professional
certificate program in Ai and machine
learning from Simply learn in
partnership with P University the course
material was comprehensive and the
faculty was extremely experienced uh The
Faculty was able to adjust their
teaching style in order to cater to the
overall skill set of the class in the
rapidly evolving world of technology
it's important to keep up Skilling for
every working professional stay relevant
with that having said hey everyone
welcome to Simply LS YouTube channel but
before we dive into that don't for for
get to like subscribe and share and now
over to our training
experts so hello and welcome to this new
video by simply learn email spam
classifier okay so first we will change
this name to
email spam
classifier okay let's rename
it so first what we going to do so first
what we going to do we will will import
some libraries then the main main
libraries like num skar and logistic
regression algorithm and then we will
move on to this importing of data set of
spam mail and ham mail ham is known as
like which is not a Spam okay so we will
do some categorization of spam email and
hem
email then we will split into the
training test and the testing of the
data set okay then we will transform the
text data to feature vectors that can be
used as input to the logistic regression
and then we will convert the white train
and the white test values as integers
and then moving forward we will some see
the features the model
extractions and then we will train the
model using logistic
regression and after that we will
predict the accuracy how much the
training data is giving how much the
testing data is giving and at the end we
will build a predictive system which
will tell whether a particular email is
Spam or not spam Okay cool so let's move
on to the coding part then okay so first
I will import some major libraries like
import
numpy as
NP okay then numai so numai is a
powerful python library for numerical
computing
so it stands for numerical Python and
provides support for efficient array
operations and mathematical function lar
algebra random number generation and
more with numai you can work with
multi-dimensional array known as ND
arrays and these arrays are highly
optimized for performance and allow you
to perform mathematical and logical
operations on large data set efficiently
so numai provides a wide range of
function and methods to manipulate and
analyze these arrays
and the second one
is
import
pandas as
PD okay this PD and NP is nothing we
don't want to write again and again
pandas and
napai so what is
pandas so pandas is a powerful python
Library used for data
manipulation and Analysis it provides
easy to use data structure and data
analysis tool making it essential tool
for working with structured data so the
third third one is psychic
Lear okay so I will write here
from okay I will write here
from
skar do
model
selection
import
train test
split okay so what is escalan model
selection and the train test
split so SK learn or psychic learn is a
popular python library for machine
learning it provides a wide range of
tools and algorithms for various machine
learning tasks including classification
regression and that clustering
dimensionally reduction and the model
evaluation okay and this train test
split this one
so the train times split function is a
utility in psychic learn that helps in
splitting the data set into training and
the testing subset later we will split
the data into training and testing so
this function is commonly used in
machine learning task to assess the
performance of a model on unseen data
okay so move on to the next algorithm we
will write
from we will write
here from
skon
dot
feature
extraction dot text
import
tfid
vectorizer okay so what is tfid
vectorizer
so tfid vectorizer is nothing is a
feature of extraction technique commonly
used in natural language processing NLP
and text mining task so it is a part of
psychic learn library in Python so tfid
vectorizer transform a collection of X
documents into a numerical
representation that machine learning
algorithm can work
with Okay so move on to we
will import from Escalon
dot
linear
model
ort
logistic
regression okay so what is logistic
regression so logistic regression is a
popular classification algorithm used in
machine learning it is a part of the
psychic learn library in Python logistic
learn and the regression is suitable for
binary classification problems where the
target variable has the two classes okay
and the last we will import accurac
score
okay so here I will write
from escalan do
Matrix
import
accuracy score okay so let me tell you
first what is that accuracy score the
accuracy score function is a performance
matric provided by the psy learn library
in Python it is commonly used to
evaluate the performance of a
classification model by measuring the
accuracy of the predictions okay so let
me run
it okay okay there is some
error maybe the spelling mistake
okay what I will do I will write it
again running it
again yeah it's working so now what I
will do I will import the data set so I
will write here dfal to data frame = to
pd.
read uncore
CSV
maincore data do
CSV you can find this data set link in
the description box below okay I'll run
it yeah so let's
see the data frame what's in it for us
so as you can see here is category then
message so these are the you know the
males ham means not a Spam and spam is
Spam okay those males which are not spam
known as ham
so there are two columns 5 five 7 two
rows so moving forward what I will do I
will convert this male data okay to Nal
so I will write
here data equals to
Raw raw data equals to DF dot
where BD Dot
not
null not
null is
D okay then some
space okay let me give you some spaces
for the better visual yeah so now I will
print data do
head so what is the meaning of head here
head means if you want to print the top
five lines of the particular data set it
is you can use the head and if you want
to print the last five rows of the data
set so you can use the tail instead if
you will write here
10 instead of giving it blank then run
it so it will give you the top 10 rows
of the particular data set okay so these
are the spam mail this ham M so later on
what we will do we will train this data
set using this particular data set okay
so let's move on
to and see the
info okay of the data set so data
doino so info you can see there are
columns this n n count this data type so
there are two columns like category and
the message and the particular rows are
the 5572 on the both and the data type
is object okay see the memory usage and
you can see
everything and there is one more you can
see the DAT
shape is 5572 comma 2 these are the rows
and these are the columns two columns
and 5572 rows okay so now what I will do
I will assign the category to spam M and
ham mail okay so what I will do
here I will write here data
dot
Lo then
data vers this
category equals to equals
to
spam
comma
category okay
comma equals to Z so if the zero will
show it is known as the spam and if one
will show it is known as the Hamil okay
I will write here data
dot lo location and
data
then
category to equals
to
ham
then
category
will
be
one okay then let me run it okay it's
running smoothly so I will write here x
equals to
data
then
message
okay and the Y value will
Beals to Main so not make
data then
category okay then let
me run
it so now what I will do
first so now what I will do I will write
here
print
X okay so these are only the messages
and
category
print
y so now as you can see 1 1 0 1 1 0 so
here zero means what is the zero means
zero means it's
spam and the one means it's Hamil
okay so moving forward what I will do I
will split this data set into testing
and the training okay so I will write
here x
train this is the most important part
and the X
test
okay then y
train then y
Das okay equals to
train test
split X comma y
comma test size
equals to
0.2
then
random okay random
State equals
to
three okay I will write
it so this is X train for the training
set and X test is the testing okay then
the same y you know that what is the X
and Y here and here we are splitting
using train test split then XA y test
size equal to
0.2 okay 0.2 means it will be 80 and 20%
and 80% will be draining and the testing
will be 20% okay we will train data 80%
of data using this data set will be
trained and for the test the 20% will
DET okay the random State equals to
three and the random state is a
hyperparameters used to control any such
Randomness involved in machine learning
model to get consistent result okay when
splitting a data set splitting a node in
a decision tree or a you know logistic
regression initializing centroids is
clustering takes place so that is why we
use random stre okay so let me run it
it's working fine so now I will show
print x.
shape okay then
print
xcore
train.
ship I will show you about the I'm
talking about the test size now print
print
xor test.
ship now see carefully okay this x will
be
Capital so as you can see total rows are
5572 total row of 80% is 4457 or else
you can calculate and the 20% is for the
testing is
the15 same goes for the Y so moving
forward okay let me show you for the Y
also so I will copy paste it here so
it's
y
y see same goes for the Y
also okay so now what I will do here I
will transform the text data to feature
vectors that can be used as input to the
logistic
regression so
feature
extraction equals to T
FID
vectorizer where the minimum difference
will
be one comma stop
words okay stop work
words equals
to
English and the lower
case okay here I'm transforming the test
data to the feature
vector and okay so here
x okay let me tell you so this is the
feature extraction we are using TF Dev
vectorizer okay we have import here as
you can see for the feature extraction
of the
text and this is the minimum difference
equal to one and then what is the stop
word stop words are the English words
which does not add much meaning to the
sentence they can safely be ignored
without sacrificing the meaning of the
sentence okay like for example you can
see the words like the he have such
words already computerized and the
capture this is a Corpus name and the
Corpus okay and this lower case equals
to two true so here I will write X
train
features equal to
Features
feature
extraction
fit
transform xcore
Dre xcore
test
features
feature
extraction do
transform to the X
test
okay yeah so moving forward I will
convert y train and Y test values as an
integers okay y train because they are 0
1 0 1 0 train equals to Y
train
as
in okay then y
testal to y test.
aspe
and
so
okay there is spelling
mistake we'll copy from
here paste it
here okay I will run
it okay why test it
is yeah it's rning so now what I will do
I will
print the X train
train as you can see the
xtrain so these are the messages and if
I will
print
exrain
features we created here now see extend
features okay then you can
see so these are the features accuracy
okay since 0 0 0 means spam 1 one means
ham okay so moving forward what I will
do I will now the Train the model OKAY
logistic regression so I will write here
model equals
to okay
logistic
regression so now we will you know train
the model so here I will
write model equals to
logistic
regression okay so we don't want to
write again and again again and again
logistic regation so I'm here assigning
model to it so let me run it so here I
will train the logistic regression model
with the training data so here I will
write model. fit
xra
features comma white
train okay here we are training the
logistic regression model with a
training
data let me run it yeah fine it's
running
fine so moving forward we will uh do the
evaluating of the training model train
model and the prediction of the training
data so for that I will write here
prediction
on
training data equals to model dot
predict X
Trin
features okay then I will write here
accuracy
on training data equals to
score y
train comma prediction okay I will write
from
here prediction from the tring
data okay let me run
it so now we will see the prediction so
I will write here prediction
or simply I will write
print accuracy on
training
data
comma okay I will copy it leave it
accuracy
on
training data okay let me run this so as
you can see accuracy on training data is
0.96 means almost 97% which is not bad
very very good okay we will see print
okay now we have to do for the testing
data this is for the training data and
let's see the accuracy for the testing
data so for that I will write same
prediction on
test data equals to model do
predict X
test
features okay then
accuracy
on test data equals to
score then y
test comma prediction
prediction
on test
data okay all
right okay accuracy
scod so here I will write
print the accuracy on test
data
okay
then I will write
accuracy
on test
data okay so as you can see the accuracy
on test data is almost same as the
training data okay almost 95% 97% sorry
so now what we will do we will build a
predicted system now okay
so I will write write here like
input okay you have to input the mail
here
then okay we will input later and we
will now write the line for the convert
text to feature Vector so for that I
will write here
input
data
features
to
feature
extraction do
transform
input
okay okay this is a function so I will
write here
input
your
mput
me
okay so here we will make the
prediction okay I will write the
prediction model do
predict
input
data
features okay so I have some spam
mails with myself so I will try to copy
them and let's
see okay I have some mail so I will copy
it
okay and I will paste it
here okay this is the second time we
have tried to contact you you have want
this this this these type of Mals are
spam
actually like you also know
so I will try to run
it let me run
it okay I forgot to write print
print
prediction okay so zero so here as you
can
see already zero means a
Spam okay so this is a spam mail
actually this is a spam mail so okay
wait let me right here
if
prediction is showing zero equals to
equals to
true
then
print printed
do
H
and
SSE then
print
[Music]
spam
spam me okay the prediction will be zero
is not equals to one okay so it will
show the ham mail or else the spam mail
simple pretty simple see Zero spam mail
okay I will try to put it put
here one
Hamil
okay
okay let me copy it paste it
here okay let me delete this
quickly okay let me run this so it is
showing ham mail means not spam
so quickly let me run one more spam
mail
okay
okay copy this and paste it
here you can try with your own like own
email with your
got
okay so let me run this so it is a spam
mail okay see you can see you have been
selected to stay marketing okay see in
so these type of males are like you know
deals and the vouchers this type of
males are the known as the spam mail see
holiday value this dial this and this
okay so here we are we have done with
our email spam classifier
as you can see if you want this scod so
you
can comment down below if you're looking
for a course that covers everything from
the fundamentals to Advanced Techniques
then accelerate your career in Ai and
machine learning with a comprehensive
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning boost your career with this Ai
and ml course delivered in collaboration
with the puru university and IBM learn
in demand skills such as machine
learning deep learning and NLP computer
vision reinforcement learning generative
AI prompt engineering chat GPD and many
more you'll receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with five capstones in different
domains using real data sets you will
gain practical experience master classes
by perd faculty and IBM experts ensure
top-notch education simply learns job
assist help you get noticed by Leading
companies this program covers statistics
python supervised and unsupervised
learning NLP neural networks computer
vision G scas tensorflow and many more
search skills admission to this
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning requires a bachelor's degree
with an average of 50% or higher marks
along with the basic understanding of
programming Concepts and Mathematics and
candidates with two plus years of work
experience are preferred to enroll in
this school so enroll now and unlock
exciting Ai and machine learning
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below we will take
you through the Hands-On lab demo of how
you can do the sentimental analysis of
Amazon customer reviews before we start
I hope the screen is clearly visible and
the audio is fine if yes please type in
yes if there are any shoes do let us
know in the chat section so that we can
resolve
them let's wait for some more minutes to
let other people
join let's wait for some more minutes to
let other people join
let me tell you guys that we have
regular updates on multiple Technologies
if you are a teag gig on a continuous
hunt for the latest technological Trends
then consider subscribing to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
great I think we can get started so in
today's session we will go through the
what is sentimental analysis after that
we will see types of sentimental
analysis we will see some application of
sentiment analysis and at the end we
will see Hands-On lab demo like how to
implement sentiment analysis using
python in detail we already have Amazon
Customer data set with us we will
perform different function and analyze
data for sentiment analysis using python
you can download data set from the
description box below so before we move
on the programming part let's discuss
what is sentiment analysis actually is
and proceed further for the
same sentiment analysis sometime known
as opinion mining is a technique used in
natural language processing NLP to
determine the emotional undertone of a
document this is a common method used by
organization to identify and group ideas
regarding a certain good service or
concept text is mined for sentiment and
subjective information using data mining
machine learning and artificial
intelligence tools for sentiment
analysis assist business
in extracting information from
unstructured unorganized language found
in online sources like emails blog post
support tickets web chats forums and
comments algorithm use rule based
automatic or hybrid technology to
replace manual data processing while
automatic system use machine learning to
learn from their data rule-based system
execute sentiment analysis using
predetermined lexicon based rules
combining the two method result in
hybrid sentiment
analysis sentiment analysis or opinion
mining can extract the subject opinion
holder and polarity or the degree of
positivity and negativity from the text
and identify sentiment additionally
other Scopes including document
paragraph sentence and Subs sentence
level can be used for sentiment analysis
after seeing what is sentiment analysis
let's discuss some types of sentiment
analysis so the first one is f grain
sentiment analysis by segmenting
sentiment each phrase or clause in a
sentence is broken down and examined in
relationship to the others simply said
you can tell who review a product and
what topics a person is specifically
discuss in their feedback and the second
one is emotion detection instead of
identifying positivity and negativity
emotion detection recognize particular
emotions example
could include shock rage grief
frustration and happiness and the third
one is intent based analysis in addition
to identify opinions in a text the
intent based analysis also identifies
behaviors for instance a frustrated
online comment about changing a battery
can motivate customer care to get in
touch to address that particular problem
and the last one is expect based
analysis collect the precise component
that is being mentioned either favorably
or unfavorably for instance a client May
write in a product review that the
battery life is too short the system
will then respond that the battery life
is the main complaint and not the
product as a whole so after seeing types
of sentiment analysis let's see some
application of sentiment
analysis organization can employ
sentiment analysis Technologies for a
number of purpose such as determining
brand popularity reputation and
awareness at a particular period or
overtime customer service requests into
categories and the next one is
monitoring consumer response to new
improvements or products and the fourth
one is identifying the demographics or
Target market and the fifth one is
determining the effectiveness of a
marketing
effort so here is one question for you
guys I will give you one minute for this
you can comment or you can give answers
in chat section so I can see if the
answers given by you are right or wrong
so the question is is text analytics
also refers to as text mining I'm
repeating again is text analytics also
refers to as text mining the options are
true or
false so let us know your answer in
comment section below or in chat section
so I'm starting timer of 1 minute minute
just type your answer in comment section
or in chat section do let me know your
answers so I'm starting timer of 1
minute I kindly ask that everyone take
part in this to make this live session
exciting
so the question is is text analytics
also refers to as text
mining 35 seconds are
left do let me know your answers I
kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make the live session
exciting two
one 20 seconds
left you can comment or you can give
your answer in chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong so time up guys so after the
allotted time has passed Those Who
provided the correct response will
receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one okay now let's move to our
programming part to perform sentiment
analysis using Amazon Customer data set
so first we will open command prom to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we'll write
Jupiter
notebook press
enter okay it's Jupiter
notebook
so this is the landing page of jupyter
notebook and here you can
select new python
file it's
loading so this is how the jupyter UI
looks like so at first we will import
some bunch of major libraries of python
which will help us in mathematical
functioning so the first one is numai so
first I will write numpy import
numpy s
NP is a python Library used for working
with arrays it also has functions for
working in the domain of linear algebra
and matrices it is an open-source
project and you can use it freely numai
stand for numerical
python so the next one is
pandas I will write here
import
pandas s
PD so pandas is a software Library
written for a Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structures and for manipulating
numerical tables and time
series after that we will
import
nltk so the natural language toolkit
nltk is a Python Programming environment
for creating application for statical
natural language processing NLP for
parsing classification stemming tagging
and semantic reasoning it includes text
processing
libraries
so after that we will import from
nltk dot
sentiment dot
Vader
import
sentiment
enity analyzer
okay there is no colum yeah so the
Lexicon and rule-based sentiment
analysis tool Vader Vader means Valance
aware dictionary and essential reasoning
is a customized precisely to Sentiments
expressed on social media Vader makes
use of variety of a sentiment lexicon is
a collection of lexical elements such as
words that are often classified as
either positive or negative depending on
their semantic
orientation Vader not only informs us of
the positivity and negativity scores but
also of the sentimentally of each
score so the next one is
import
re python re module fully supports
regular expression similar to those in
Pearl if a regular expression
compilation or use error occurs the re
modules raises the exection
re two key functions that are used to
manage regular expression will be
covered so R means regular
Expressions so the next one is
from X
blob
import
okay so a python 2 or three package
called text blob is used to process
textual data it offers a straightforward
API to explore typical natural language
processing NLP tasks like part of speech
tagging noun phrase extraction sentiment
analysis classification translation and
more
so the next one is
import
words
from word
cloud a word cloud commonly refers to as
a tag cloud is an image of words popular
words and phrases are highlighted using
Cloud creators depending on their
frequency and importance they give you
immediate straightforward visual
insights that can Inspire more through
analysis and the next one is
import
cbor
as
SNS
yeah so like an open- Source python
Library based on mat plot Li is called
seon it is utilized for data exploration
and data visualization where data frames
and the Panda's Library cbon function
with
ease so the next one is import met plot
lip dot P
plot as
PLT okay yeah seems good for Python and
its numerical expression numai
matplotlib is a crossplatform data
visualization and graphical charting
package as a result it presents a strong
open source substitute for matlb the
apis for matplot Li allow programmers to
incorporate graphs into GUI
applications and the next one is
import of links cff l n KS as
CF perfect another python module called
cuff link links plotly with pandas so
that charts can be easily created on
data frames in essence it function like
a
plug-in so next in
line at BL
lip at BL
clip so you can enable inline plotting
by using the magic function percentage M
plot Li in line which causes the plots
and graphs to appear below the cell
where you plotting commands are entered
similar to a jupyter notebook it offers
backend interactivity in front ends so
next we will
import what you can like we can import
okay
from shortly do
offline import
init uncore
notebook underscore
mode comma I
plot okay in it _
notebook
mode
get through
yeah
cf.
goore
offline
so yeah in order to display the plot
inside the notebook you need to initiate
plotly notebook mode as follows like
this keep rest of the script as it is
like it and run the notebook cell by
pressing you can shift plus enter graph
will be displayed offline inside the
notebook so basically it is used for the
offline graphing you can see okay so
next we will
import
home
plotly do subplots subplots are
important
import make underscore
subplot okay yeah the non-leaf nodes in
this figure schema are represented by a
hierarchy of python classes that was
automatically constructed and is found
in the plotly dot graph objects which is
normally imported as go these class
instance are refers to as graph object
the plotly defined fundamental
classes
okay so here we will import some like uh
warnings you can
[Music]
say like to get not
error so we will import let me give a
line space
import
warning warnings yeah
warnings dot
filter
warning
ignore warnings do
one
and this uh like will not
show and let me add something
PD do
set
option display do
maxcore clums
okay import import words from word cloud
okay there's an error let me check
what's the
error okay
import
this what cloud
from
wordcloud it's
capital and W is also
Capital here will be
Capital let it put is small
only from
wordcloud
okay my bad here from
wordcloud from
wordcloud import
wordcloud
okay yeah seems
good so where were
we yeah in warnings despite the
notification the software continues to
execute to playay warning messages
utilize the warn found in the warning
module the python built-in class
expection is a subass of the warning
module which is used to display warning
messages import warnings okay for seeing
full data every single columns like okay
there is error
cbor no module as cbor
so s will be
small
got it okay in
line this only
like something like that in
line okay any errors
no I guess no error
okay yeah for seeing full data like
every single column of PD so here we are
using this pd. set option so we can use
for it so moving forward let's import
data set so for importing data set we
will write
here
uh like DF equals to PD do
read
CSV
okay data set
name
yeah
so so you can download data set from the
description box below so no worries of
for
that so let me run
this
okay so like here is PD is for Panda's
Library read is used for reading the
data set from the machine and CSV is
used for the type of file which you want
to read so let's see our
data so here I will write DF dot
head
yeah so if you want to like if you want
to see top five rows of your data set
you can use head and if you want to uh
like see five rows of your data set you
can use tail insert instead of head this
one okay so this is our data set with
only five rows if you want to see full
data set you
can like from starting from zero and
ending it 4914 R okay 4 9115 rows and 12
columns
right so let me give something like this
for the better
visual yeah
okay so moving ahead let's sort this
Wilson bound column to ascending order
for better analysis so I'm talking about
this Wilson lowerbound column this one
for it's not 0 0 0 like in all the rows
so let me show
you so here you have to write like DF
equals to DF do
sort values
Wilson spelling should be
correct
lower
bound I will make it to ascending
order
ascending sorry descending order
so BF do
drop
named
okay un
name colum
zero okay in
place in place equals to
True comma XIs equals to
one okay so let's see your
data
so here you can see the data is sorted
in
as in as ascending order
okay so the provided row or column is
eliminated via the drop function the
drop method eliminate the specified
column when the column AIS is specified
the drop method eliminates the
designated row when the row AIS is
supplied
okay so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any queries or like any
queries regarding any code or there is
something question till here just put as
in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct
solution
okay so moving forward let's make a
function for missing
values so
okay so I will write here like
DF
missing
values
analysis
analyses okay it's DF for function we
use
DF
yeah
a
columns
to co for
for or Co n DF do
columns if
DF column
is
null
sum is greater than
zero _
missals to
DF na underscore
columns
score
is
null dot
sum dot sort values sort underscore
values like in ascending
ascending asending equals to
true
X
some be like this and
this that's fine I
guess yeah so here I will write
ratio underscore equals
to f
na underscore columns
underscore dot is
null same thing that
sum divided
by F do
shape
100 or
sort
values
standing to
True
fine okay
okay
is okay and the TF
part that sort value is equal to sending
to True fine
so here we will write
missing underscore DF = to
PD Dot
conat
do
round
ratio underscore comma
perfect their XIs will be
one
okay
is equals
to I will give
like total where I will write missing
values
missing
values okay comma
ratio underscore DF equals to
PD dot data frame
score
DF okay so let me
return
DF let me create one more function for
like check data frame so
DF check _ data
frame
okay equals to
5 comma
tail equal to
5 so here I will write
print
okay
Center 2
comma and for row
Sprint
CL
craes dot
format what
format do
shape
Z
so for columns
Sprint do
shape
PR and types like of types of
data Dot
Center same as like that
[Music]
882a
in DF do D
types
Center
just printing this is like you will see
don't
worry just stay with me you will see the
beautiful
result okay
print
values print missing values uh analysis
uh this is like
DF
okay
then
again
values like there's many how many
duplicated values are there so dot same
for the
center
three again this one
print have dot
duplicated don't worry I will explain
you like line by line just stay with me
let me write the whole code first
printes
like I'm printing multiple of things so
just be with
meent
comma EF
Dot
onti
five
comma
one
okay
check data
frame I'm hoping like there will be no
error
yeah so you can see now like
multiple information regarding data set
is
printed so this shape is for like how
many rows and columns present in the
data set like in types you can say like
every column type like object in 64
float 64 and many more are like present
so like you can see review text is like
object and day difference is n 64 and
Wilson lower bound is float
64 okay so total missing
values so total missing values are like
like uh one from here and one from here
like one in from reviewer name and other
is from reviewer
text and like there is no duplicated
values in our data
set and here you can see so like after
that quantiles a quanti defines a
particular part of the data set that is
a quantile determines how many values in
the distribution are above or below a
certain limit special quantiles are the
like qu quarter and you can say quintile
that the fifth one and the percentile
which is from 100 okay so quantile is
for like
quarter or the you can say the fifth one
so why I wrote this 88382 and this for
this purpose for making this something
look cool that is
why okay
and
yeah so moving
forward let's see unique values and in
each
column okay so I will write
def
check
plus
frame
unique FAL to PD dot
data
frame
variable
frame columns
comma
classes
colon data
frame
I I will write like n unique
unique
U
or I
in data
frame columns
like n
unique
[Music]
_ DF equals
to
sort
values
classes Comm
ascending equals
to
false
okay and
unique underscore DF equals to n
unique EF do
reset
index drop equals to true
return and
unique qu and
uni
DF check underscore class which one
DF so let me run this
first yeah it's running you can see
here
okay there is an error
classes
okay check class
DF is saying
that this
is okay C is capital c
small
let me run now
yeah so here you can see the every
column having unique values are sorted
in descending order like review text
have like more unique values so it come
first and then review name reviewer time
day difference Wilson lower bound score
average then goes to
overall okay moving forward let's do
some categorical Vari analysis for
overall okay so this will be like
amazing something amazing is going to be
happen
so constants equals to so I'm giving
here like some color values
so
b34 D 22
e b 00
C okay so you can change you can like
write whatever you want
color hasht oh I didn't write hashtag
here
hashtag three come
on
C 92
EB
z
c and then d you like five
right okay so DF let's make function
Okay small
DF
categorical
variable okay DF
comma
column okay categorical variable summary
yeah perfect so let make some figures so
make
subplots
dos rows equals to
1 comma
calls to
two
let me write from here like
subplot
metals
to count
plot like one for
percentage percent
so specs
space equals
to okay like
type
colon
it's
why
okaya same
type call in here
domain figure.
add and then
[Music]
Trace go Dot
bar like one bar and one that pie chart
okay y = to
DF
columns
name
value
values do to
list for X you can L
string yeah St
Str
I or
i n
yeah
column
name dot
value
counts
XT equals to
DF
column
name
value counts and then
bracket dot
values do to
list
okay so for text
font the size should
be 14 is enough I
guess to
column let go
name
X
position so I'm doing for like making
chart
so stay with me to see that amazing
chart okay so show
Legend
to
D
color to
constants so these are the like colors
so I'm giving here value like V variable
name
con
Trends comma
line equals
to
it's
hasht
DB
e 6
e
comma
one okay
small
okay let me just like go over
through everything is correct or not for
the column
name value count index yeah it's fine
text equals to DF column
name do value counts do values to to
list okay text font equals to T size
then okay 14 size is enough name equals
to column name and text position equals
to
Auto and show Legend fals and
Mark dict like color equals to constant
okay fine line equals to color and this
yeah this okay
cool L equals to
1 comma column equals
1 seems
good for p chart we will make figure dot
add so this is done for the like line
chart not line chart that bar chart and
this I'm doing for the pie chart okay
Trace go
dot
Pi F
columns column
name
value
is
values to
DF again that column
name
value
count
counts and Dot
values text
font
T
size I will prefer 18 is
enough
position like Auto is
fine oh
Legend to no need of Legend
false m equals to column
name
column
name let's like d then
colors equals to
constants
= to
one one columnal to two like in second
okay you will see and you will get to
know don't worry so
figure.
update
layout equals
to
column
or9
five
comma
X should be on
Center
and Y
anchor be on
top equals
to
shortly
okay I
plot
figure let me run this okay like call
equals to
two now let's see the chart of like call
overall one so we will write here
categorical okay
variable
Su and then data frame name DF comma
overall okay let's run
this okay it's loading here it's
loading yeah you can see this is this is
our bar plot and this is our pie
chart
so like this is
overall uh from overall you can say that
column so like
percentage bar and that bar plot so this
is how our like pie chart and bar chart
looks like I hope you guys understand
till here if you have any questions or
any query regarding any code okay like
any code any sort of code so just put as
in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct
solution so moving forward our goal is
to rank the com comments by the
sentiment analysis so we don't get hung
up on the other details I have sorted
this data set according to certain rules
before so moving forward we want to
clean our data so let's see the sample
data for
cleaning so DF
dot
review
text okay dot
head let me run this so so this is how
sample data looks likees so let's see
like data full data for this okay let me
see
for
what this I guess
okay or like any particular row you can
say I can take okay so I will write
review underscore
example example equals to DF
Dot
riew text uh I will take a random 2031 I
guess okay so
review underscore
example so this is like at
2031 there is one review text okay so in
that the whole data is here like uh like
so my lovely wife bought me a Samsung
Galaxy Tab for father this this this
this like to find the exact model number
this is a long you know comment I got
the this this this it works like a charm
okay
so after seeing this data what we're
going to do is like we will clean it
from punctuation and numbers using Rex
Rex what regular expression okay so here
I will write review underscore
example example
okay equals to r dot
sub and what I will do
is okay I will explain don't worry small
a to capital
A A to Z okay comma then
space comma riew underscore
example
examle add
sorry
yeah
review
so here we used re for regular
expression okay and so all the
punctuation and numbers are removed from
particular
data so let me check
first okay this A to Z then A to Z okay
fine so like all the punctuation and
numbers are removed from particular data
I will now convert the text to all lower
case our machine learning algorithm
recognized words that start with the
capital letters as a different word and
we will convert them to lowercase so
thus our machine learning algorithm will
not perceive words that start with a
capital letter as a different word so
what I will do is here I will write
review
example some example equals to G
[Music]
view again
example do
lower I will split
it
split
okay you
example so here you can see we have
converted all the words in the lowercase
letter by using lower function and why
they are coming in new lines because we
are splitting them using split function
okay if you see only did lower case for
single row like we did for the like 20 I
guess 2 3 1 okay yeah so let's make all
row same in lower case so I will write
here RT equals to
Lambda
X
St
Str Dr
X
DF
view
text E capital
text
DF
view
text
TT okay equals to
DF
view yeah do lower
we have.
head see all the data is in like lower
case so I printed just top 10 rows and
in like in reviews text column all the
are in the lower case now so I hope you
guys understand till here if you have
any question or any query regarding any
code or question till here like any code
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
and if you need this full code you can
comment down below
okay so now the time is come to do
sentiment analysis because all the data
is
sorted so what will I write
here let me do it little bit up
yeah so I will write
from yeah from
Vader
sentiment do
sentiment
V
intensity
analyzer
okay
f
it
subjectivity
subjectivity to
DF view
text
apply
PD do
series okay here you like
text
blob then again
Dot like
sentiment
let me run for Loop for
index comma
Row in
DF G VI
text what
it
items for
timent
intensity
analyzer
polarity
scores
row netive I
score
or neutral I will write
score if for
positive
if this is something crazy if negative
is greater than
positive then DF do
location
index
comma
sentiment equals
to
negative
okay
then El
if positive is greater than
negative then in this case DF
DOT
log
index
comma
sentiment
ALS
to
positive B
capital
else EF do
LC
index
timent
let's
to
neutral
okay so like this is for sentimental
analysis and text
blog this thing like text blob this blob
okay it's blob
text blob will return polarity and
subjectivity polarity indicates your
modood that is whether it is positive or
negative or neutral it returns a value
between 0o and one the closer to one the
more positive and the closer to zero is
more
negative okay let me run this it will
take a little bit time because this
sentiment okay it is getting error like
module Panda has no attribute series
okay which
one text
box X
sentiment okay here what is the thing s
is
capital let me run
now it is executing like f for a while
wait so it will take time to run because
like because of this sentiment intensity
analyzer it take
times can sentiment
intensity analyzer okay spelling mistake
again what y index index is not
defined sorry
again
index it will run I guess because
everything seems
good negative positive and this
loading so I have to wait like for like
2 minutes more I
guess still loading
guys it take
time sentiment intensity analyzer
so let me tell you again sentiment
analysis like this text
blob text blob will return polarity and
subjectivity so polarity indicates your
mood that is whether it is positive it
is negative or it is it will be neutral
it returns a value between 0 and 1 the
CL closer to one the more positive the
closer to zero more negative okay I
guess this
still
running so it will take time so let me
write code for that uh 20 interpretation
I repeat moving forward let's identify
the 20 interpretation now we can include
the positive negative and neutral status
of the command okay then
DF
sentiment what equals to
positive
thought
lower
sending equals to
false
okay dot
head it's
five if I will run it
may give errors to me because it's still
running still running here it's still
loading
so let let let me write code for that
unbalanced data problem so like we will
category that data into positive
negative and
neutral okay
so
categorical
variable
summary
DF
ment yeah it came like this because of
this wait I will tell
you yeah so here you can see the pie
chart distributed in negative positive
and neutral emotions okay or you can say
ratings and here you can see the bar
chart also
so and you can see the percentage
distributed in each like in positive
negative and neutral one so I hope you
guys must understood the concept of
sentiment analysis how we can implement
it using python if you want to become an
AI expert and gain handsome salary
packages look at the wide range of e IML
courses by simply learn in collaboration
with top universities across the globe
so what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll Now find the cost Link in the
description box so in today's session we
will discuss what fake news is and at
the end we will do a hands-off lab demo
of how to detect fake news using machine
learning before we move on to the
programming part let's discuss first
what fake news is and proceed further
for the same
what is fake news false or misleading
information that is reported as news is
called fake news a common goal or fake
news is to harm someone or something
reputation or to profit through
advertising the term fake news was first
used in 1890s a time when dramatic
newspaper reports were common even
though incorrect information has always
been dissed throughout
history however the phrase has no clear
definition and is often used to refer to
all misleading information high-profile
individuals have also used it to refer
to any news that is not favorable to
them so dear Learners if you want to
upscale your AI and machine learning
skills so give yourself a chance to
Simply learn professional certificated
program in Ai and machine learning which
comes with a completion certificate and
in-depth knowledge of AI and machine
learning check this course details from
the description box below now let's move
to our programming
part so first we will open a command
prom to write a command to open jupyter
notebook so here we will write
Jupiter
notebook
Center and here I have to select new
python kernel file okay so this is how
the Kel look lies so first we will
import some major libraries of python so
here I will write import
pandas s
PD and
put numai as
NP then
import C
Bor that's
SNS okay then
import
skar Dot model
selection
P train
underscore test underscore
split before that I will
import M plot
Li do p
plot at as
PLT okay
then I will write here from
eSalon dot
matrix
import
accuracy
four then
from
Escalon do
Matrix
import
classification to
report and import R then
import
string
okay then press enter so it is
saying okay here I have to write
from
everything seems
good loading let's
see okay till then numai is a python
Library used for working with arrays it
also has function for working with
domain of linear algebra and
matrices it is an open source project
and you can use it
freely number stand for numerical
python pandas so panda is a software
Library written for Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structure and operation for manipulating
numerical tables and time
series then cbor an open- Source python
Library based on matplot lib is called
cbon it is utilized for data exploration
and data visualization with data frames
and the pandas Library cbon functions
with ease then met plot lip for Python
and its numerical extension numpy
matplot lip is a crossplatform for the
data visualization and graphical
charting package as a result it presents
a strong open source suitable for metlab
the apis format plot live allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
gii applications then this train test is
split we may build our training data and
the test data with the aid of Escalon
train test split function this is so
because the original data set often
serves as both the training data and the
test data starting with the single data
set we divide it into two data sets to
obtain the information needed to create
a model like hor and test accuracy score
the accuracy score is used to gge the
model's Effectiveness by calculating the
ratio of total true positive to Total
true negative across all the model
prediction this re regular expression
the functions in the model allow you to
determine whether a given text fits a
given regular expression or not which is
known as
re okay then string a collection of
letters words or other character is
called a string it is one of the basic
data structure that serves as the
foundation of manipulating data the Str
Str class is a buil-in string class in
Python because python strings are
immutable they cannot be modified after
they have been
formed okay so now let's import the data
set we will be going to import two data
set one for the fake news and one for
the True News or you can say not fake
news okay so I will write here
efcore P equals
to PD
do read uncore
CSV or what can I say DF F okay
_
fake
okay then fake do CSV you can download
this data set from the description box
below then data dot true equals to pd.
read _
CSV sorry CSV
then fake news sorry true true.
CSV okay then press
enter so these are the two data set you
can download these data set from the
description box below so let's see the
board data set okay then I will write
here
dataor
fake do head
so this is the fake data okay
then data underscore
true
Dot and this is the two
data okay this is not fake so if you
want to see your top five rows of the
particular data set you can use head
and if you want to see the last five
rows of the data set you can use tail
instead of head
okay so let me give some space for the
better
visual so now we will insert column
class as a Target feature okay then I
will write here
data go
fake
plus equals to Z
then data underscore
true and
plus = to
okay
then I will write here data underscore
fake do shape and data underscore
true do shet
okay then press
enter so the shape method return the
shape of an array the shape is a tuple
of integers these number represent the
length of the corresponding area
dimension in other words a tle
containing the quantities of entries on
each axis is an array shape Dimension so
what's the meaning of
shape in the fake word in this data set
we have 2 3 4 8 1 rows and five columns
and in this data set true we have 21 417
rows and five column okay so these are
the rows column rows column for the
particular data
set so now let's move and let's remove
the last 10 rows for the manual testing
okay then I will write here data
underscore
fake let's go
manual
testing
to dataor
fake do
tail for the last 10 rows I have to
write here
10 okay so for I in
range 2 3
4 8 1 sorry
0o comma 2
470 comma
minus1
okay
and DF underscore not DF
data underscore
fake dot
drop
one instead of one I can write here
I
comma is equals to
Z
Place equal to
true then
data not here
data
underscore same I will write for I will
copy from
here and I will paste it here and I will
make the particular changes so here I
can write
true where I can write
true
okay then I have to change a
[Music]
number
write 21 40
6 -
one
same so press
enter x equal
to0 since X maybe you mean d0 or of
this okay we will put here double
course I'm putting this
. drop IX is z in place okay also WR
equals to and
equals yeah
so okay AIS is not
defined
now it's working
so let me
see now data
underscore pick.
shape
okay and data dot
true and data underscore
true do shape
as you can
see 10 rows are deleted from each data
set yeah so I will write here data
underscore fake underscore
manual
testing
class =
to0 and data
underscore
truecore manual underscore
testing plus equals
to
okay just ignore this
fing and let's
see data
underscore
bore
manual testing
doad as you can see we have this and
then data dot sorry underscore
truecore
manual testing
sing dot head
10 this is this is the uh true data
set so here I will merge data underscore
merge
to PD
Dot concat
concat is used for the concatination
data underscore
fake data
underscore comma
XIs =
to0 then data uncore
merge do
head
the top 10
rows
yeah as you can see the data is merged
here okay first it will come for the
fake news and then with the for the True
News then let's merge true and fake data
frames
okay we did this and
and let's merge the column then data do
merge dot columns or let's see the
columns it has not defined what data
underscore
much these are the column name title Tex
subject date class okay
now let's remove those columns which are
not required for the further process so
here I will write data
underscore or equals to data underscore
March
prop title we don't
need then
subject we don't need
then so
one so let's check some null
values it's giving
error because of
this
that's good then
data dot is
null
Su
Center so no null values okay then let's
do the random shuffling of the data
frames okay for that we have to write
here data equals to data do
sample
one
then data okay
data do
head okay now you can see here the
random shuffling is
done and one for the true set and zero
for the fake news one
okay then let me write here data
dot
reset _
index
Place equals to
True data dot
drop
comma X is = to
1 then comma in
place equals to
True
okay then let me see columns now data do
columns so here we have two columns only
rest we have deleted okay
so let me see data dot
add yeah everything seems
good let's proceed further and let's
create a function to process the text
okay for that I will write
[Music]
here
but okay you can use any
name
text and text equals
to text do
lower okay and
text to r dot for the
substring
remove these
things uh from
the datas okay so for that I'm writing
herea
okay then text equals to R do
substring
comma comma
text okay then have to write text equals
to I do
substring W
ww
dot s
plus
comma comma
text okay then text equals
to R do
subring
then
comma okay then text equals to R do
substring
then
percentage s
again percentage for r. SK
function right here
string do
punctuation
then comma then
text
right then text equals to R do
substring and
N
comma text equals to r
dot substring
right
here then again
D then
again
okay then
comma then again
texture okay then at the end I have to
write here return return text so
everything like uh this uh these type of
special character will be removed from
the data set okay let's run this let's
see yeah so here I will addite DF sorry
not DF
data
then
text to
data okay dot
apply to the function name wordp word
opt
okay press enter yeah so now let's uh
Define the dependent and independent
variables okay x equals to
data
text and Y =
to
data
class okay
then splitting training and testing
data okay sorry so here I will write
xcore
train comma xcore
test uh then Yore
train comma Yore test to train
underscore testore split
then X comma
y comma
test let's go size equals to
0.25 okay press
enter so now let's convert X to vectors
for that I have to write
here Z is
X
so here I will write from
Escalon dot
feature
extraction dot text
import T
vectorizer
okay then
vectorization
equals to T FID
D
vectorizer okay
then
C
uncore
train equals
to
vectorization Z ton
factorization do
fit then
transform xcore
train okay then X Vore test equals
to
factorization dot transform
xcore
test okay then press
enter
uh so now let's see our first model
logistic
regression so here I will write
from Escalon
dot linear uncore
model OKAY
import
logistic
regression then lot equals
to
logistic
regression and after WR here l
dot
fit then XV
dot not DOT x dot train
comma X Vore
test okay let's
enter
xv. here I have to write y
train okay and press
Center will work so here I will write
prediction
underscore linear
regression equ
to l r do
predict Vore
test okay let's see the accuracy
score for that I have to write L do
score
then XV underscore
test comma
Yore
test okay let's see the accuracy so here
as you can see accuracy is quite good
98% now let's
print the
classification
Miss
put Yore test
comma prediction of linear regression
okay so this is you can see Precision
score then F1 score then support value
accuracy okay so now we will uh do this
same for the decision free gradient
boosting classifier random Forest
classifier okay then we will do model
testing then we will predict this
school okay so now for the decision tree
classification so for that I have to
import from
skar dot
tree
import
decision
three
classifier okay then at the short form I
will write here I copy it from
here
then okay then I have to write the same
as this so I will copy it from
here
and
yeah
let's change linear
regression to season three
classific
okay then I will write here
same go
dtal dt.
predict
Vore
test still loading it's it will take
time
okay till then let me WR here for the
accuracy it do
score
vcore test comma y
let's wait
okay
R the accuracy so as you can see
accuracy is good than this linear
regression okay logistic
regression okay so let
me you the let me
PR
print so this is the accuracy score this
is the all the
report
yeah now let's move for the uh gradient
boosting
classifier okay for that I WR from
Escalon dot
emble
Port
radiant
boosting
classifier
clf I will write here
GB equals to let me copy it from
here
okay I will give here random let's go
State equals to
zero wait wait wait wait so I will write
here GB dot
fit X Vore train
comma Yore train okay then press
enter here I will write predict
underscore
GB to GB dot fit sorry
redit
three DOT
test doore test
till then it's loading so I will write
here uh for the score then I will add
gb.
score then Vore test
comma Yore test okay so let's wait it is
running this
part till then let me write for the
printing this
okay it's taking
time taking time still taking
time what if I will run
this it's not coming because of this
yeah it's done now so you can see the
accuracy
is uh not good
than decision tree but yeah it is also
good
99.4 something okay
so now let's check for the last one
random
Forest first I will
do for the random Forest we have to
write from Escalon
dot
symbol
import
random
Forest
classifier
okay and here I will write
RF
to right I will copy it from here
then random
State equals
to Z
then RF dot
fit vcore
train comma Yore train
okay then press
enter and
predict
underscore
RC r f equals
to rf.
predict 3core test
okay till then I will write here it's
still loading it will take time
so till then I will write for the score
score accuracy
score XV uncore test comma Yore
test okay then I will write here till
then
print
classification
p and Yore test
comma it will take time little
bit
so uh it run the accuracy score is 99 it
is also
good so now I will write the code for
the model testing so I will get back to
you but after writing the code so
so I have made two functions one for the
output label and one for the manual
testing okay so it will predict the all
the from the all models from
the repeat so it will
predict the it the news is fake or not
from all the models okay so for that let
me write here
news
to
string
put
okay then I will write here manual
underscore
testing
so here I will you can add any news from
the you can copy it from the Internet or
whatever from wherever you want so I'm
just copying from the
internet okay from the Google the news
which is not fake okay I'm adding which
is not fake because I already know I
searched on Google so I'm entering this
so just run it let's see what is
showing okay string input object is not
col okay let me check this
first okay I have to give here s Str
only yeah let's check okay I have to add
here again the script yeah manual
testing is not
defined let me see manual
testing
okay I have to edit
something it is just GB and it is just
RF GBC is not defined okay okay so what
I have to do I have to remot
this
everything seems
sorted
now as I said to you I just copied this
news from the internet I already know
the news is not fake so it is showing
not a fake news okay so now what I will
do I will copy one fake news from the
internet and let's see it is detecting
it or not
okay so let me run
this and let me add the news for
this
so all the models are predicting right
it is a fake news or you can add your
own script like this is the fake news
okay
I hope you guys understand till here so
I hope you guys must have understand how
to detect a fake news using machine
learning you can you can copy any news
from the internet and you can check it
is fake or not okay if you want to
become an AI expert and gain handsome
salary packages look at the wide range
of e IML courses by simply learn in
collaboration with top universities
across the globe so what are you waiting
for hurry up and enroll Now find the
cost Link in the description
box hello everyone welcome to the
session I'm Mohan from Simply learn and
today we'll talk about interview
questions for machine learning now this
video will probably help you when you're
attending interviews for machine
learning positions and the attempt here
is to probably consolidate 30 most
commonly asked uh questions
and to help you in answering these
questions we tried our best to give you
the best possible answers but of course
what is more important here is rather
than the theoretical knowledge you need
to kind of add to the answers or
supplement your answers with your own
experience so the responses that we put
here are a bit more generic in nature so
that if there are some Concepts that you
are not clear this video will help you
in kind of getting those Concepts
cleared up as well but what is more
important is that you need to supplement
these responses with your own practical
experience okay so with that let's get
started so one of the first questions
that you may face is what are the
different types of machine learning now
what is the best way to respond to this
there are three types of machine
learning if you read any material you
will always be told there are three
types of machine learning but what is
important is you would probably be
better off emphasizing that there are
actually two main types of machine
learning which is supervised and
unsupervised and then there is a third
type which is reinforcement learning so
supervised learning is where you have
some historical data and then you feed
that data to your model to learn now you
need to be aware of a keyword that they
will be looking for which is labeled
data right so if you just say past data
or historical data the impact may not be
so much you need to emphasize on labeled
data so what is labeled data basically
let's say if you're trying to do train
your model for classification you need
to be aware of for your existing data
which class each of the observations
belong to right so that is what is
labeling so it is nothing but a fancy
name you must be already aware but just
make it a point to throw in that keyword
labeled so that will have the right
impact okay so that is what is
supervised learning when you have
existing labeled data which you then use
to train your model that is known as
supervised learning and UNS supervised
learning is when you don't have this
labeled data so you have data it is not
labeled so the system has to figure out
a way to do some analysis on this okay
so that is unsupervised learning and you
can then add a few things like what what
are the ways of Performing uh supervised
learning and unsupervised learning or
what are some of the techniques so
supervised learning we we perform or we
do uh regression and classification and
unsupervised learning uh we do
clustering okay and clustering can be of
different types similarly regression can
be of different types but you don't have
to probably elaborate so much if they
are asking uh for uh just the different
types you can just mention these and
just at a very high level you can but if
they want you to elaborate give examples
then of course I think there is a
different question for that we will see
that later then the third so we have
supervised then we have unsupervised and
then reinforcement you need to provide a
little bit of information around that as
well because it is sometimes a little
difficult to come up with a good
definition for reinforcement learning so
you may have to little bit elaborate on
how reinforcement learning works right
so reinforcement learning works in in
such a way that it basically has two
parts to it one is the agent agent and
the environment and the agent basically
is working inside of this environment
and it is given a Target that it has to
achieve and uh every time it is moving
in the direction of the target so the
agent basically has to take some action
and every time it takes an action which
is moving uh the agent towards the
Target right towards a goal uh a Target
is nothing but a goal okay then it is
rewarded and every time it is going in a
Direction where it is away from the goal
then it is punished so that is the way
you can a little bit explain and uh this
is used primarily or very very impactful
for teaching the system to learn games
and so on examples of this are basically
used in alphago you can throw that as an
example where alphago used reinforcement
learning to actually learn to play the
game of Go and finally it defeated the
go world champion all right this much of
information that would be good enough
okay then there could be a question on
overfitting uh so the question could be
what is overfitting and how can you
avoid it so what is overfitting so let's
first try to understand the concept
because sometimes overfitting may be a
little difficult to understand
overfitting is a situation where the
model has kind of memorized the data so
this is an equivalent of memorizing the
data so we can draw an analogy so that
it becomes easy to explain this now
let's say you're teaching a child about
some recognizing some fruits or
something like that okay and you're
teaching this child about recognizing
let's say three fruits apples oranges
and pineapples okay so this is a a small
child and for the first time you're
teaching the child to recognize fruits
then so what will happen so this is very
much like that is your training data set
so what you will do is you'll take a
basket of fruits which consists of
apples oranges and pineapples okay and
you take this basket to this child and
there may be let's say hundreds of these
fruits so you take this basket to this
child and keep showing each of this
fruit and then first time obviously the
child will not know what it is so you
show an apple and you say hey this is
Apple then you show maybe an orange and
say this is orange and so on and so and
then again you keep repeating that right
so till that basket is over this is
basically how training work in machine
learning also that's how training works
so till the basket is completed maybe
100 fruits you keep showing this child
and then in the process what has
happened the child has pretty much
memorized these so even before you
finish that basket right by the time you
are halfway through the child has
learned about recognizing the Apple
orange and pineapple now what will
happen after halfway through initially
you remember it made mistakes in
recognizing but halfway through now it
has learned so every time you show a
fruit it will exactly 100% accurately it
will identify it will say the child will
say this is an apple this is an orange
and if you show a pineapple it will say
this is a pineapple right so that means
it has kind of memorized this data now
let's say you bring another basket of
fruits and it will have a mix of maybe
apples which were already there in the
previous set but it will also have in
addition to Apple it will probably have
a banana or maybe another fruit like a
jack fruit right so this is an
equivalent of your test data set which
the child has not seen before some parts
of it it probably has seen like the
apples it has seen but this banana and
jack fruit it has not seen so then what
will happen in the first round which is
an equivalent of your training data set
towards the end it has 100% it was
telling you what the fruits are right
Apple was accurately recognized orange
were was accurately recognized and
pineapples were accurately recognized
right so that is like a 100% accuracy
but now when you get another a fresh set
which were not a part of the original
one what will happen all the apples
maybe it will be able to recognize
correctly but all the others like the
jack fruit or the banana will not be
recognized by the child right so this is
an analogy this is an equivalent of
overfitting so what has happened during
the training process it is able to
recognize or reach 100% accuracy maybe
very high accuracy okay and we call that
as very low loss right so that is the
technical term so the loss is pretty
much zero and accuracy is pretty much
100% whereas when you use testing there
will be a huge error which means the
loss will be pretty high and therefore
the accuracy will be also low okay this
is known as overfitting this is
basically a process where training is
done training process is it goes very
well almost reaching 100% accuracy but
while testing it really drops down now
how can you avoid it so that is a
extension of this question there are
multiple ways of avoiding overfitting
there are techniques like what do you
call regularization that is the most
common technique that is used uh for uh
avoiding overfitting and within
regularization there can be a few other
subtypes like Dropout in case of neural
networks and a few other examples but I
think if you give example or if you give
regularization as the technique probably
that should be sufficient so so there
will be some questions where the
interviewer will try to test your
fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge and so on and so
forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like trick
questions that will be more to stump you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and test
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training set and
test set in machine learning model and
how is the split done so the question
can be like that so in machine learning
when we are trying to train the model so
we have a three-step process we train
the model and then we test the model and
then once we are satisfied with the test
only then we deploy the model so what
happens in the train and test is that
you remember the labeled data so let's
say you have th records with lab
information now one way of doing it is
you use all the Thousand records for
training and then maybe right which
means that you have exposed all this
thousand records during the training
process and then you take a small set of
the same data and then you say okay I
will test it with this okay and then you
probably what will happen you may get
some good results all right but there is
a flaw there what is the flaw this is
very similar to human beings it is like
you are showing this model the entire
data as a part of training okay so
obviously it has become familiar with
the entire data so when you're taking a
part of that again and you're saying
that I want to test it obviously you
will get good results so that is not a
very accurate way of testing so that is
the reason what we do is we have the
label data of this thousand records or
whatever we set aside before starting
the training process we set aside a
portion of that data and we call that
test set and the remaining we call as
training set and we use only this for
training our model now the training
process remember is not just about
passing one round of this data set so
let's say now your training set has 800
records it is not just one time you pass
this 800 records what you normally do is
you actually as a part of the training
you may pass this data through the model
multiple times so this thousand records
may go through the model maybe 10 15 20
times till the training is perfect till
the accuracy is high till the errors are
minimized okay now so which is fine
which means that here that is what is
known as the model has seen your data
and gets familiar with your data and now
when you bring your test data what will
happen is this is like some new data
because that is where the real test is
now you have trained the model and now
you are testing the model with some data
which is kind of new that is like a
situation like a realistic situation
because when the model is deployed that
is what will happen it will receive some
new data not the data that it has
already seen right so this is a
realistic test so you put some new data
so this data which you have set aside is
for the model it is new and if it is
able to accurately predict the values
that means your training has worked okay
the model got drained properly but let's
say while you're testing this with this
test data you're getting a lot of errors
that means you need to probably either
change your model or retrain with more
data and things like that now coming
back to the question of how do you split
this what should be the ratio there is
no fixed uh number again this is like
individual preferences some people split
it into 50/50 50% test and 50% training
Some people prefer to have a larger
amount for training and a smaller amount
for test so they can go by either 60/40
or 7030 or some people even go with some
odd numbers like
6535 or uh 63. 33 and 33 which is like
1/3 and 2/3 so there is no fixed rule
that it has to be something the ratio
has to be this you can go by your
individual preferences all right then
you may have questions around uh data
handling data manipulation or what do
you call data management or Preparation
so these are all some questions around
that area there is again no one answer
one single good answer to this it really
varies from situation to situation and
depending on what exactly is the problem
what kind of data it is how critical it
is what kind of data is missing and what
is the type of corruption so there a
whole lot of things this is a very
generic question and therefore you need
to be little careful about responding to
this as well so probably have to
illustrate this again if you have
experience in doing this kind of work in
handling data you can illustrate with
example saying that I was on one project
where I received this kind of data these
were the columns where data was not
filled or these were the this many rows
where the data was missing that would be
in fact a perfect way to respond to this
question but if you don't have that
obviously you have to provide some good
answer I think it really depends on what
exactly the situation is and there are
multiple ways of handling the missing
data or corrupt data now let's take a
few examples now let's say you have data
where some values in some of the columns
are missing and you have pretty pretty
much half of your data having these
missing values in terms of number of
rows okay that could be one situation
another situation could be that you have
records or data missing but uh when you
do some initial calculation how many
records are corrupt or how many rows or
observations as we call it has this
missing data let's assume it is very
minimal like 10% okay now between these
two cases how do you so let's assume
that this is not a mission critical
situation
and in order to fix this 10% of the data
the effort that is required is much
higher and obviously effort means also
time and money right so it is not so
Mission critical and it is okay to let's
say get rid of these records so
obviously one of the easiest ways of
handling the data part or missing data
is remove those records or remove those
observations from your analysis so that
is the easiest way to do but then the
downside is as I said in as in the first
case if let's say 50% of your data is
like that because some column or the
other is missing so it is not like every
in every place in every Row the same
column is missing but you have in maybe
10% of the records column one is missing
and another 10% column two is missing
another 10% column three is missing and
so on and so forth so it adds up to
maybe half of your data set so you
cannot completely remove half of your
data set then the whole purpose is lost
okay so then how do you handle then you
need to come up with ways of filling up
this data with some meaningful value
right that is one way of handling so
when we say meaningful value what is
that meaningful value let's say for a
particular column you might want to take
a mean value for that column and fill
wherever the data is missing fill up
with that mean value so that when you're
doing the calculations your analysis is
not completely way off so you have
values which are not missing first of
all so your system will work number two
these values are not so completely out
of whack that your whole analysis goes
for
right there may be situations where if
the missing values instead of putting
mean maybe a good idea to fill it up
with the minimum value or with a zero so
or with a maximum value again as I said
there are so many possibilities so there
is no like one correct answer for this
you need to basically talk around this
and illustrate with your experience as I
said that would be the best otherwise
this is how you need to handle this
question okay so then the next question
can be how can you choose a classifier
based on a training set data size so
again this is one of those questions uh
where you probably do not have like a
one size fits all answer first of all
you may not let's say decide your
classifier based on the training set
size maybe not the best way to decide
the type of the classifier and uh even
if you have to there are probably some
thumb rules which we can use but then
again every time so in my opinion the
best way to respond to this question is
you need to try out few classifiers
irrespective of the size of the data and
you need to then decide on your
particular situation which of these
classifiers are the right ones this is a
very generic issue so you will never be
able to just by if somebody defines a a
problem to you and somebody even if if
they show the data to you or tell you
what is the data or even the size of the
data I don't think there is a way to
really say that yes this is the
classifier that will work here no that's
not the right way so you need to still
you know test it out get the data try
out a couple of classifiers and then
only you will be in a position to decide
which classifier to use you try out
multiple classifiers see which one gives
the best accuracy and only then you can
decide then you can have a question
around confusion Matrix so the question
can be explained confusion Matrix right
so confusion Matrix I think I think the
best way to explain it is by taking an
example and drawing like a small diagram
otherwise it can really become tricky so
my suggestion is to take a piece of pen
and paper and uh explain it by drawing a
small Matrix and confusion Matrix is
about to find out this is used
especially in classification uh learning
process and when you get the results
when the our model predicts the results
you compare it with the actual value
Andy try to find out what is the
accuracy okay so in this case let's say
this is an example of a confusion Matrix
and it is a binary Matrix so you have
the actual values which is the labeled
data right and which is so you have how
many yes and how many no so you have
that information and you have the
predicted values how many yes and how
many no right so the total actual values
the total yes is 12 + 1 13 and they are
shown here and the actual value NOS are
9 + 3 12 okay so that is what this
information here is so this is about the
actual and this is about the predicted
similarly the predicted values there are
yes are 12 + 3 15 yeses and no are 1 + 9
10 no okay so this is the way to look at
this confusion Matrix okay and U out of
this what is the meaning convey so there
are two or three things that needs to be
explained outright the first thing is is
for a model to be accurate the values
across the diagonal should be high like
in this case right that is one number
two the total sum of these values is
equal to the total observations in the
test data set so in this case for
example you have 12 + 3 15 + 10 25 so
that means we have 25 observations in
our test data set okay so these are the
two things you need to First explain
that the total sum in this Matrix the
numbers is equal to the size of the test
data set and the diagonal values
indicate the accuracy so by just by
looking at it you can probably have a
idea about is this uh an accurate model
is the model being accurate if they're
all spread out equally in all these four
boxes that means probably the accuracy
is not very good okay now how do you
calculate the accuracy itself right how
do calculate the accy itself so it is a
very simple mathematical calculation you
take some of the diagonals right so in
this case it is 9 + 12 21 and divide it
by the total so in this case what will
it be let's me uh take a pen so your
your diagonal values is equal to if I
say d is equal to 12 + 9 so that is 21
right and the total data set is equal to
right we just calculated it is 25 so
what is your accuracy it is 21 by your
accuracy is equal to 21 by 25 and this
turns out to be about
85% right so this is 85% so that is our
accuracy okay so this is the way you
need to explain draw a diagram Give an
example and maybe it may be a good idea
to be prepared with an example so that
it becomes easy for you don't have to
calculate those numbers on the fly right
so couple of uh hints are that you take
some numbers which are with which add up
to 100 that is always a good idea so you
don't have to really do this complex
calculations so the total value will be
100 and then diagonal values you divide
once you find the diagonal values that
is equal to your percentage okay all
right so the next question can be a
related question about false positive
and false negative so what is false
positive and what is false negative now
once again the best way to explain this
is using a piece of paper and Pen
otherwise it will be pretty difficult to
to explain this so we use the same
example of the confusion Matrix and uh
we can explain that so A confusion
Matrix looks somewhat like this and um
when we just take yeah it looks somewhat
like this and we continue with the
previous example where this is the
actual value this is the predicted value
and uh in the actual value we have 12 +
1 13 yeses and 3 + 9 12 Nos and the
predicted values there are 12 + 3 15
yeses and uh 1 + 9 10 NOS okay now this
particular case which is the false
positive what is a false positive first
of all the second word which is positive
okay is referring to the predicted value
so that means the system has predicted
it as a positive but the real value so
this is what the false comes from but
the real value is not positive okay that
is the way you should understand this
term false positive or even false
negative so false positive so positive
is is what your system has predicted so
where is that system predicted this is
the one positive is what yes so you
basically consider this row okay now if
you consider this row so this is this is
all positive values this entire row is
positive values okay now the false
positive is the one which where the
value actual value is negative predicted
value is positive but the actual value
is negative so this is a false positive
right and here is a true positive so the
predicted value is POS positive and the
actual value is also positive okay I
hope this is making sense now let's take
a look at what is false negative false
negative so negative is the second term
that means that is the predicted value
that we need to look for so which are
the predicted negative values this row
corresponds to predicted negative values
all right so this row corresponds to
predicted negative values and what they
are asking for false so this is the row
for predicted negative values and the
actual value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is the way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify y the predicted row right so if
we say true positive positive we need to
take for the predicted part so predicted
positive is here okay and then the first
term is for the actual so true positive
so true in case of actual is yes right
so true positive is this one okay and
then in case of actual the negative now
we are talking about let's say true
negative true negative negative is this
one and the true comes from here so this
is true negative negative right N9 is
true negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the terms false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then uh you might
have a question like what are the steps
involved in the machine learning process
or what are the three steps in the
process of developing uh machine
learning model right so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way you can probably answer in your
own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model happens is like this so first of
all you try to understand the problem
and try to figure out whether it is a
classification problem or a regression
problem based on that you select a few
algorithms and then you start the
process of training these models okay so
you can either do that or you can after
due diligence you can probably decide
that there is one particular algorithm
that which is most suitable usually it
happens through trial and error process
but at some point you will decide that
okay this is the model we are going to
use okay so in that case we have the
model algorithm and the model decided
and then you need to do the process of
training the model and testing the model
and this is where if it is supervised
learning you split your data the label
data into training data set and test
data set and you use the training data
set to train your model and then you use
the test data set to check the accuracy
whether it is working fine or not so you
test the model before you actually put
it into production right so once you
test the model you're satisfied it's
working fine then you go to the next
level which is putting it for production
and then in production obviously new
data will come and uh the inference
happens so the model is readily
available and only thing that happens is
new data comes and the model predicts
the values whether it is regression or
classification now so this can be an
iterative process so it is not a
straightforward process where you do the
training do the testing and then you
move it to production no so during the
training and test process there may be a
situation where because of either
overfitting or or things like that the
test doesn't go through which means that
you need to put that back into the
training process so that can be an
iterative process not only that even if
the training and test goes through
properly and you deploy the model in
production there can be a situation that
the data that actually comes the real
data that comes with that this model is
failing so in which case you may have to
once again go back to the drawing board
or initially it will be working fine but
over a period of time maybe due to the
change in the nature of the data once
again the accuracy will deteriorate so
that is again a recursive process so
once in a while you need to keep
checking whether the model is working
fine or not and if required you need to
tweak it and modify it and so on and so
forth so net net this is a continuous
process of um tweaking the model and
testing it and making sure it is up to
date then you might have question around
deep learning so because deep learning
is now associated with AI artificial
intelligence and so on so can be as
simple as what is a deep learning so I
think the best way to respond to this
could be deep learning is a part of
machine learning and then then obviously
the the question would be then what is
the difference right so deep learning
you need to mention there are two key
parts that interviewer will be looking
for when you're are defining deep
learning so first is of course deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
so machine learning is still the bigger
let's say uh scope and deep learning is
one one part of it so then what exactly
is the difference deep learning is
primarily when we are implementing these
our algorithms or when we are using
neural networks for doing our training
and classification and regression and
all that right so when we use neural
network then it is is considered as deep
learning and the term deep comes from
the fact that you can have several
layers of neural networks and these are
called Deep neural networks and
therefore the term deep you know deep
learning uh the other difference between
machine learning and deep learning which
the interviewer may be wanting to hear
is that in case of machine learning the
feature engineering is done manually
what do we mean by feature engineering
basically when we are trying to train
our model we have our training data
right so we have our training label data
and uh this data has several let's say
if it is a regular table it has several
columns now each of these columns
actually has information about a feature
right so if we are trying to predict the
height weight and so on and so forth so
these are all features of human beings
let's say we have sensus data and we
have all this so those are the features
now there may be probably 50 or 100 in
some cases there may be 100 such such
features now all of them do not
contribute to our model right so we as a
data scientist we have to decide whether
we should take all of them all the
features or we should throw away some of
them because again if we take all of
them number one of course your accuracy
will probably get affected but also
there is a computational part so if you
have so many features and then you have
so much data it becomes very tricky so
in case of machine learning we manually
take care of identifying the features
that do not contribute to the learning
process and thereby we eliminate those
features and so on right so this is
known as feature engineering and in
machine learning we do that manually
whereas in deep learning where we use
neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
probably will add value to your response
all right so the next question is what
is the difference between or what are
the differences between machine learning
and deep learning so here this is a
quick comparison table between machine
learning and deep learning and in
machine learning learning enables
machines to take decisions on their own
based on past data so here we are
talking primarily of supervised learning
and um it needs only a small amount of
data for training and then works well on
lowend system so you don't need large
machines and most features need to be
identified in advance and manually coded
so basically the feature engineering
part is done manually and uh the problem
is divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so that
is about the machine learning part in
deep learning deep learning basically
enables machines to take decisions with
the help of artificial neural network so
here in deep learning we use neural l so
that is the key differentiator between
machine learning and deep learning and
usually deep learning involves a large
amount of of data and therefore the
training also requires usually the
training process requires high-end
machines uh because it needs a lot of
computing power and the Machine learning
features are or the feature engineering
is done automatically so the neural
networks takes care of doing the feature
engineering as well and in case of deep
learning therefore it is said that the
problem is handled end to end so this is
a quick comparison between machine
learning and deep learning in case you
have that kind of a question then you
might get a question around the uses of
machine learning or some real life
applications of machine learning in
modern business the question may be
worded in different ways but the the
meaning is how exactly is machine
learning used or actually supervised
machine learning it could be a very
specific question around supervised
machine learning so this is like give
examples of supervised machine learning
use of supervised machine learning in
modern business so that could be the
next question so there are quite a few
examples or quite a few use cases if you
will for supervised machine learning the
very common one is email spam detection
so you want to train your application or
your system to detect between spam and
non-spam so this is a very common
business application of supervised
machine learning so how does this work
the way it works is that you obviously
have historical data of of your emails
and they are categorized as spam and not
spam so that is what is the labeled
information and then you feed this
information or the all these emails as
an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is Spam and which is not spam so that is
the training process and this is
supervised machine learning because you
have labeled data you already have
emails which are tagged as spam or not
spam and then you use that to train your
model right so this is one example now
there are a few industry specific
applications for supervised machine
learning one of the very common ones is
in healthcare Diagnostics in healthcare
Diagnostics you have these images and
you want to train models to detect
whether from a particular image whether
it can find out if the person is sick or
not whether a person has cancer or not
right so this is a very good example of
supervised machine learning here the way
it works is that existing images it
could be x-ray images it be MRI or any
of these images are available and they
are tacked saying that okay this x-ray
image is defective or the person has an
illness or it could be cancer whichever
illness right so it is tacked as
defective or clear or good image and
defective image something like that so
we come up with the binary or it could
be multiclass as well well saying that
this is defective to 10% this is 25% and
so on but let's keep it simple you can
give an example of just a binary
classification that would be good enough
so you can say that in healthcare
Diagnostics using image we need to
detect whether a person is ill or
whether a person is having cancer or not
so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when New
Image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer or not
right so I think this would be a very
good example for supervised machine
learning in modern business all right
then we can have a question like so
we've been talking about supervised and
um unsupervised then so there can be a
question around semi-supervised machine
learning so what is semi-supervised
machine learning now semisupervised
learning as the name suggests it falls
between supervised Le learning and
unsupervised learning but for all
practical purposes it is considered as a
part of supervised learning and reason
this has come into existence is that in
supervised learning you need labeled
data so all your data for training your
model has to be labeled now this is a
big problem in many Industries or in
many under many situations getting the
label data is not that easy because
there's a lot of effort in labeling this
data let's take an example of the
diagnostic images we can just let's say
take X-ray images now there are actually
millions of x-ray images available all
over the world but the problem is they
are not labeled so the images are there
but whether it is effective or whether
it is good that information is not
available along with it right in a form
that it can be used by a machine which
means that somebody has to take a look
at these images and usually it should be
like a doctor and uh then say that okay
yes this image is clean and this image
is cancerous and so on and so forth now
that is a huge effort by itself so this
is where semisupervised learning comes
into play so what happens is there is a
large amount of data maybe a part of it
is labeled then we try some techniques
to label the remaining part of the data
so that we get completely labeled data
and then we train our model so I know
this a little long winding explanation
but unfortunately there is no uh quick
and easy definition for semi-supervised
machine learning this is the only way
probably to explain this concept we may
have another question as um what are
unsupervised machine learning techniques
or what are some of the techniques used
for performing unsupervised machine
learning so it can be worded in
different ways so how do we answer this
question so unsupervised learning
learning you can say that there are two
types clustering and Association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together and there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together this is
clustering then Association you can I
think the best way to explain
Association is with an example in case
of Association you try to find find out
how the items are linked to each other
so for example if somebody bought a
maybe a laptop the person has also
purchased a mouse so this is more in an
e-commerce scenario for example so you
can give this as an example so people
who are buying laptops are also buying
the mouse so that means there is an
association between laptops and mouse or
maybe people who are buying bread are
also buying butter so that is a
Association that can be created so this
is unsupervised learning one of the
techniques okay all right then we have
very fundamental question what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so machine
learning these are the two main types of
machine learning supervised and unised
and in case of supervised and again here
probably the keyword that the person may
be wanting to hear is labeled data now
very often people say yeah we have
historical data and if we run it it is
supervised and if we don't have
historical data yes but you may have
historical data but if it is not labeled
then you cannot use it for supervised
learning so it is it's very key to
understand that we put in that keyword
labeled okay so when we have labeled
data for training our model then we can
use supervised learning and if we do not
have labeled data then we use
unsupervised learning and there are
different algorithms available to
perform both of these types of uh
trainings so there can be another
question a little bit more theoretical
and conceptual in nature this is about
inductive machine learning and deductive
machine learning so the question can be
what is the difference between inductive
machine learning and deductive machine
learning or somewhat in that manner so
that the exact phrase or exact question
can vary they can ask for examples and
things like that but that could be the
question so let's first understand what
is inductive and inductive training
inductive training is induced by
somebody and you can illustrate that
with a small example I think that always
helps so whenever you're doing some
explanation try as much as possible as I
said to give examples from your work
experience or give some analogies and
that will also help a lot in explaining
as well and for the interviewer also to
understand so here we'll take an example
or rather we will use an analogy so
inductive training is when we induce
some know knowledge or the learning
process into a person without the person
actually experiencing it okay what can
be an example so we can probably tell
the person or show a person a video that
fire can burn the thing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
fire can cause damage right so this is
inductive learning compared to that what
is deductive learning so here you draw
conclusion or the person draws
conclusion out of experience so we will
stick to the analogy so compared to the
showing a video Let's assume a person is
allowed to play with fire right and then
he figures out that if he puts his
finger it's burning or if throws
something into the fire it burns so he
is learning through experience so this
is known as deductive learning okay so
you can have applications or models that
can be trained using inductive learning
or deductive learning all right I think
uh probably that explanation will be
sufficient the next question is are KNN
and K means clustering similar to one
another or are they same right because
that the letter K is kind of common
between them okay so let us take a
little while to understand what these
two are one is KNN and another is K
means KNN stands for K nearest neighbors
and K means of course is the clustering
mechanism now these two are completely
different except for the letter K being
common between them K andn is completely
different K means clustering is
completely different KNN is a
classification process and therefore it
comes under supervised learning whereas
K means clustering is actually a un
supervis okay when you have KN andn when
you want to implement KN andn which is
basically K nearest neighbors the value
of K is a number so you can say k is
equal to 3 you want to implement KN andn
with K is equal to 3 so which means that
it performs the classification in such a
way that how does it perform the
classification so it will take three
nearest objects and that's why it's
called nearest neighbor so basically
based on the distance it will try to
find out its nearest objects that are
let's say three of the nearest objects
and then it will check whether the class
they belong to which class right so if
all three belong to one particular class
obviously this new object is also
classified as that particular class but
it is possible that they may be from two
or three different classes okay so let's
say they are from two classes and then
if they are from two classes now usually
you take a odd number you assign a odd
number to so if there are three of them
and two of them belong to one class and
then one belongs to another class so
this new object is assigned to the class
to which the two of them belong now the
value of K is sometimes tricky whether
should you use three should you use five
should you use seven that can be tricky
because the ultimate classification can
also vary so it's possible that if
you're taking K as three the object is
probably in one particular class but if
you take K is equal to 5 maybe the
object will belong to a different class
because when you're taking three of them
probably two of them belong to class one
and one belong to class two whereas when
you take five of them it is possible
that only two of them belong to class
one and three of them belong to class
two so which means that this object will
belong to class two right so you see
that so this the class allocation can
vary depending on the value of K now K
means on the other hand is a clustering
process and it is unsupervised where
what it does is the system will
basically identify Y how the objects are
how close the objects are with respect
to some of their features okay and but
the similarity of course is the the
letter K and in case of K means also we
specify its value and it could be three
or five or seven there is no technical
limit as such but it can be any number
of clusters that uh you can create okay
so based on the value that you provide
the system will create that many
clusters of similar objects so there is
a similarity to that extent that k is a
number in both the cases but actually
these two are completely different
processes we have what is known as KN
based classifier and people often get
confused thinking that knive base is the
name of the person who found this uh
classifier or who developed this
classifier which is not 100% true base
is the name of the person b y s is the
name of the person but naive is not the
name of the person right so naive is
basically an English word and that has
been added added here because of the
nature of this particular classifier n
based classifier is a probability based
classifier and uh it makes some
assumptions that presence of one feature
of a class is not related to the
presence of any other feature of maybe
other classes right so which is not a
very strong or not a very what do you
say accurate assumption because these
features can be related and so on but
even if we go with this assumption this
whole algorithm works very well even
with this assumption and uh that is the
good side of it but the term comes from
there so that is the explanation that
you can then there can be question
around reinforcement learning it can be
paraphrased in multiple ways one could
be can you explain how a system can play
a game of chess using reinforcement
learning or it can be any game so the
best way to explain this is again to
talk a little bit about what
reinforcement learning is about and then
elaborate on that to EXP explain the
process so first of all reinforcement
learning has an environment and an agent
and the agent is basically performing
some actions in order to achieve a
certain goal and this goals can be
anything either if it is related to game
then the goal could be that you have to
score very high score a high value High
number or it could be that your number
of lives should be as high as possible
don't lose lives so these could be some
of them more Advanced examples could be
for driving in the automotive industry
self-driving cars they actually also
make use of reinforcement learning to
teach the car how to navigate through
the roads and so on and so forth that is
also another example now how does it
work so if the system is basically there
is an agent and environment and every
time the agent takes a step or performs
a task which is taking it towards the
goal the final goal let's say to
maximize the score or to minimize the
the number of lives and so on or
minimize the deaths for example it is
rewarded and every time it takes a step
which goes against that goal right
contrary or in the reverse Direction it
is penalized okay so it is like a carrot
and stick system now how do you use this
to create a game of chess or to create a
system to play a game of chess now the
way this works is and this could
probably go back to this alpago example
where alphao defeated a human Champion
so the way it works in reinforcement
learning the system is allowed for
example if in this case we're talking
about Chess so we allow the system to
first of all watch playing a game of
chess so it could be with a human being
or it could be the system itself there
are computer games of Chess right so
either this new learning system has to
watch that game or watch uh human being
play the game because this is
reinforcement uh learning is pretty much
all visual so when you're teaching the
system to play a game the system will
not actually go behind the scenes to
understand the logic of your software of
this game or anything like that it is
just visually watching the screen and
then it learns okay so reinforcement
learning to a large extent works on that
so you need to create a mechanism
whereby your model will be able to watch
somebody playing the game and then you
allow the system also to to start
playing the game so it pretty much
starts from scratch okay and as it moves
forward it it it's at right at the
beginning the system really knows
nothing about the game of chess okay so
initially it is a clean slate it just
starts by observing how you're playing
so it will make some random moves and
keep losing badly but then what happens
is over a period of time so you need to
now allow the system or you need to play
with the system not just 1 2 3 four or
five times but hundreds of times
thousands of times maybe even hundreds
of thousands of times and that's exactly
how alpha go has done it played millions
of games between itself and the system
right so for the game of chess also you
need to do something like that you need
to allow the system to play chess and
then learn on its own over a period of
repetition so I think you can probably
explain it to this much to this extent
and and it should be uh sufficient now
this is another question which is again
somewhat similar but here the size is
not coming into picture so the question
is how will you know which machine
learning algorithm to choose for your
classification problem now this is not
only classification problem it could be
a regression problem I would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm I'm going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably let's say limit
the number of algorithms but now within
the classification algorithms you have
decision R you have svm you have
logistic regression is it possible to
outright say yes so for this particular
problem since you have explained this
now this is the exact algorithm that you
can use that is not possible okay so we
have to try out a bunch of algorithms
see which one gives us the best
performance and best accuracy and then
decide to go with that particular
algorithm so in machine learning a lot
of it happens through trial and error
there is uh no real possib ability that
anybody can just by looking at the
problem or understanding the problem
tell you that okay in this particular
situation this is exactly the algorithm
that you should use then the questions
may be around application of machine
learning and this question is
specifically around how Amazon is able
to recommend other things to buy so this
is around recommendation engine how does
it work how does the recommendation
engine works so this is basically the
question is all about so the
recommendation engine again Works B
based on various inputs that are
provided obviously something like uh you
know Amazon website or e-commerce site
like Amazon collects a lot of data
around the customer Behavior who is
purchasing what and if somebody is
buying a particular thing they're also
buying something else so this kind of
Association right so this is the
unsupervised learning we talked about
they use this to associate and Link or
relate items and that is one part of it
so they kind of build associate between
items saying that somebody buying this
is also buying this that is one part of
it then they also profile the users
right based on their age their gender
their geographic location they will do
some profiling and then when somebody is
logging in and when somebody is shopping
kind of the mapping of these two things
are done they try to identify obviously
if you have logged in then they know who
you are and your information is
available like for example your age may
be your gender
and where you're located what you
purchased earlier right so all this is
taken and the recommendation engine
basically uses all this information and
comes up with recommendations for a
particular user so that is how the
recommendation engine work all right
then the question can be uh something
very basic like when will you go for
classification versus regression right
when do you do classification instead of
regression or when do you use
classification instead of regression now
yes so so this is basically going back
to the understanding of the basics of
classification and regression so
classification is used when you have to
identify or categorize things into
discrete classes so the best way to
respond to this question is to take up
some examples and use it otherwise it
can become a little tricky the question
may sound very simple but explaining it
can sometimes be very tricky in case of
regression we use of course there will
be some keywords that they will be
looking for so just you need to make
sure you use those keywords one is the
discrete values and other is the
continuous values so for regression if
you are trying to find some continuous
values you use regression whereas if
you're trying to find some discrete
values you use classification and then
you need to illustrate what are some of
the examples so classification is like
let's say there are images and you need
to put them into classes like cat dog
elephant tiger something like that so
that is a class classification problem
or it can be that is a multiclass
classification problem it could be
binary classification problem like for
example whether a customer will buy or
he will not buy that is a classification
binary classification it can be in the
weather forecast area now weather
forecast is again combination of
regression and classification because on
the one hand you want to predict whether
it's going to rain or not that's a
classification problem that's a binary
classification right it's going to rain
or not rain however you also have to
predict what is going to be the
temperature tomorrow right now
temperature is a continuous value you
can't answer the temperature in a yes or
no kind of a response right so what will
be the temperature tomorrow so you need
to give a number which can be like 20°
30° or whatever right so that is where
you use regression one more example is
stock price prediction so that is where
again you will use regression so these
are the various examples so you need to
illustrate with examples and make sure
you include those keywords like discrete
and continuous so the next question is
more about a little bit of a design
related question to understand your
Concepts and things like that so it is
how will you design a spam filter so how
do you basically design or develop a
spam filter so I think the main thing
here is he is looking at probably
understanding your Concepts in terms of
uh what is the algorithm you will use or
what is your understanding about
difference between classification and
regression uh and things like that right
and the process of course the
methodology and the process so the best
way to go about responding to this is we
say that okay this is a classification
problem because we want to find out
whether an email is a spam or not spam
so that we can apply the filter
accordingly so first thing is to
identify what type of a problem it is so
we have identified that it is a
classification then the second step may
be to find out what kind of algorithm to
use now now since this is a binary
classification problem logistic
regression is a very common very common
algorithm but however right as I said
earlier also we can never say that okay
for this particular problem this is
exactly the algorithm that we can use so
we can also probably try decision trees
or even support Vector meurs for example
svm so we will kind of list down a few
of these algorithms and we will say okay
we want to we would like to try out
these algorithms and then we go about
taking your historical data which is the
labeled data which are marked so you
will have a bunch of emails and uh then
you split that into training and test
data sets you use your training data set
to train your model that or your
algorithm that you have used rather the
model actually so and you actually will
have three models let's say you are
trying to test out three algorithms so
you will obviously have three models so
you need to try all three models and
test them out as well see which one
gives the best accuracy and then you
decide that you will go with that model
okay so training and test will be done
and then you zero in on one particular
model and then you say okay this is the
model will we use we will use and then
go ahead and Implement that or put that
in production so that is the way you
design a Spam fi the next question is
about random Forest so what is random
Forest so this is a very straightforward
question however the response you need
to be again little careful while we all
know what is random Forest explaining
this can sometimes be tricky so one
thing is random Forest is kind of in one
way it is an extension of decision trees
because it is basically nothing but you
have multiple decision trees and uh
trees will basically we will use for
doing if it is classification mostly it
is classification you will use the the
trees for classification and then you
use voting for finding the the final
class so that is the underl but how will
you explain this how will you you
respond to this so first thing obviously
we will say that random Forest is one of
the algorithms and the more important
thing that you need to probably the
interviewer is is waiting to hear is
Ensemble learner right so this is one
type of Ensemble learner what is
Ensemble learner Ensemble learner is
like a combination of algorithms so it
is a learner which consists of more than
one algorithm or more than one maybe
models okay so in case of random Forest
the algorithm is the same but instead of
using one instance of it we use multiple
instances of it and we use so in a way
that is a a random Forest is an ensemble
learner there are other types of
Ensemble Learners where we have like we
use different algorithms itself so you
have one maybe logistic regression and a
decision tree combined together and so
on and so forth or there are other ways
like for example splitting the data in a
certain way and so on so that's all
about Ensemble we will not go into that
but random Forest itself I think the
interviewer will be happy to hear this
word Ensemble Learners and so then you
go and explain how the random Forest
works so if the random Forest is used
for classification then we use what is
known as a voting mechanism so basically
how does it work let's say your random
Forest consists of 100 trees okay and
each observation you pass through this
forest and each observation let's say it
is a classification problem binary
classification zero or one and you have
100 trees now if 90 trees say that it is
a zero and 10 of the trees say it is a
one you take the majority you may take a
vote and since 90 of them are saying
zero you classify this as zero then you
take the next observation and so on so
that is the way random Forest works for
classification if it is a regression
problem it's somewhat similar but only
thing is instead of vot what we will do
is so in regression remember what
happens you actually calculate a value
right so for example you're using
regression to predict the temperature
and you have 100 trees and each tree
obviously will probably predict a
different value of the temperature they
may be close to each other but they may
not be exactly the same value so these
100 trees so how do you now find the
actual value the output for the entire
Forest right so you have outputs of
individual trees which are a part of
this Forest but then you need to find
the final output of the forest itself so
how do you do that so in case of
regression you take like an average or
the mean of all all the 100 trees right
so this is also a way of reducing the
error so maybe if you have only one tree
and that one tree makes a error it is
basically 100% wrong or 100% right right
but if you have on the other hand if you
have a bunch of trees you are basically
mitigating that error or reducing that
error okay so that is the way random
Forest works so the next question is
considering the long list of machine
learning algorithms how will you decide
on which one to use so once again here
there is no way to outright say that
this is the algorithm that we will use
for a given data set this is a very good
question but then the response has to be
like again there will not be a one size
fits all so we need to first of all you
can probably shorten the list in terms
of by saying okay whether it is a
classification problem or it is a
regression problem to that extent you
can probably uh shorten the list cuz you
don't have to use all of them if it is a
CL classification problem you only can
pick from the classification algorithms
right so for example if it's a
classification you cannot use linear
regression algorithm there or if it is a
regression problem you cannot use svm or
maybe no you can use svm but maybe a
logistic regression right so to that
extent you can probably shorten the list
but still you will not be able to 100%
decide on saying that this is the exact
algorithm that I'm going to use so the
way to go about is you choose a few
algorithms based on on what the problem
is you try out your data you train some
models of these algorithms check which
one gives you the lowest error or the
highest accuracy and based on that you
choose that particular algorithm okay
all right then there can be questions
around bias and variance so the question
can be what is bias and variance in
machine learning uh so you just need to
give out a definition for each of these
for example bias in machine learning it
occurs when the predicted values are far
away from the actual values so that is a
bias okay and whereas they are all all
the values are probably they are far off
but they are very near to each other
though the predicted values are close to
each other right while they are far off
from the actual value but they are close
to each other you see the difference so
that is bias and then the other part is
your variance now variance is when the
predicted values are all over the place
right so the variance is high that means
it may be close to the Target but it is
kind of very scattered so the points the
predicted values are not close to each
other right in case of bias the
predicted values are close to each other
but they are not close to the Target but
here they may be close to the Target but
they may not be close to each other so
they are a little bit more scattered so
that is what in case of a variance okay
then the next question is about again
related to bias and variance what is the
tradeoff between bias and variance yes I
think this is a interesting question
because these two are heading in
different directions so for example if
you try to minimize the bias variance
will keep going high and if you try to
minimize the variance bias will keep
going high and there is no way you can
minimize both of them so you need to
have a tradeoff saying that okay this is
the level at which I will have my bias
and this is the level at which I will
have variance so the trade-off is that
pretty much uh that you you decide what
is the level you will tolerate for your
bias and what is the level you will
tolerate for variance and a combination
of these two in such a way that your
final results are not we off and having
a tradeoff will ensure that the results
are consistent right so that is
basically the output is consistent and
which means that they are close to each
other and they are also accurate that
means they are as close to the Target as
possible right so if either of these is
high then one of them will go off the
track def precision and Recall now again
here I think uh it would be best to draw
a diagram and take uh the confusion
Matrix and it is very simple the
definition is like a formula your
Precision is true positive by true
positive plus false positive and your
recall is true positive by true positive
plus false negative okay so that's you
can just show it in a mathematical way
that that's pretty much uh you know that
can be shown that's the easiest way to
define so the next question can be about
decision tree what is decision tree
pruning and why is it so basically
decision trees are really simple to
implement and understand but one of the
drawbacks of decision trees is that it
can become highly complicated as it
grows right and the rules and the
conditions can become very complicated
and this can also lead to overfitting
which is basically that during training
you will get 100% accuracy but when
you're doing testing you'll get a lot of
Errors so that is the reason pruning
needs to be done so the purpose or the
reason for doing decision tree pruning
is to reduce overfitting or to cut down
on overfitting and what is decision tree
pruning it is basically that you reduce
the number of branches because as you
may be aware a tree consists of the root
node and then the there are several
internal nodes and then you have the
leaf nodes now if there are too many of
these internal nodes that is when you
face the problem of overfitting and
pruning is the process of reducing those
internal nodes all right so the next
question can be what is logistic
regression uh so basically logistic
regression is um one of the techniques
used for performing classification
especially binary classification now
there is something special about
logistic regression and there are a
couple of things you need to be careful
about first of all the name is a little
confusing it is called logistic
regression but it is used for
classification so this can be sometimes
confusing so you need to probably
clarify that to the interviewer if if
it's really you know if it is required
and they can also ask this like a trick
question right so that is one part
second thing is the term logistic has
nothing to do with the usual Logistics
that we talk about but it is derived
from log so that the mathematical
derivation involves log and therefore
the name logistic regression so what is
logistic regression and how is it used
so logistic regression is used for
binary classification and the output of
a logistic regression is either a zero
or a one and it varies so it's basically
it calculates a probability between zero
and one and we can set a threshold that
can vary typically it is 0.5 so any
value above 05 is considered as one and
if the probability is below5 it is
considered as zero so that is the way we
calculate the probability or the system
calculates the probability and based on
the threshold it sets a value of Z or
one which is like a binary
classification 0 or one okay then we
have a question around K nearest
neighbor algorithm so explain K nearest
neighbor algorithm so first of all what
is a k nearest neighbor algorithm this
is a classification algorithm so that is
the first thing we need to mention and
we also need to mention that the K is a
number it is an integer and this is
variable and we can Define what the
value of K should be it can be 2 3 5 7
and usually it is an odd number so that
is something we need to mention
technically it can be even number also
but then typically it would be odd
number and we will see why that is okay
so based on that we need to classify
objects okay we need to classify objects
so again it will be very helpful to draw
a diagram you know if you're explaining
I think that'll be the best way so draw
some diagram like this and let's say we
have three clusters or three classes
existing and now you want to find for a
new item that has come you want to find
out which class this belongs to right so
you go about as the name suggests you go
about finding the nearest neighbors
right the points which are closest to
this and how many of them you will find
that is what is defined by K now let's
say our initial value of K was five okay
so you will find the K the five nearest
data points so in this case as it is
Illustrated these are the five nearest
data points but then all five do not
belong to the same class or cluster so
there are one belonging to this cluster
one the second one belonging to this
cluster two three of them belonging to
this third cluster okay so how do you
decide that's exactly the reason we
should as much as possible try to assign
a odd number so that it becomes easier
to assign this so in this case you see
that the majority actually if there are
multiple classes then you go with the
majority so since three of these items
belong to this class we assign which is
basically the in in this case the green
or the tennis or the third cluster as I
was talking about right so we assign it
to this third class so in this case it
is uh that's how it is decided okay so K
nearest neighbor so first thing is to
identify the number of neighbors that
are mentioned as K so in this case it is
K is equal to five so we find the five
nearest points and then find out out of
these five which class has the maximum
number in that okay and and then the uh
new data point is assigned to that class
okay so that's pretty much how K nearest
neighbors work all right and with that
we have come to the end of NLP machine
learning course I hope you found it
valuable and entertaining please ask any
questions about the topics covered in
this video in the comment box below our
experts will assist you in addressing
your problems thanks for watching stay
safe and keep learning staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to no
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here